the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the country are back for the American
Cup in St Louis it takes a lot more than
luck to pull out a victory in such an
illustrious field starting with the
white pieces was like finding a pot of
gold in the women's section with three
decisive games creating a trinity at the
top of the standings Josh clouds loomed
over the open section but it was
sunshine and rainbows for Hikaru
Nakamura who defeated Sam sebian for the
solely American chess is in full swing
don't miss a second or you'll be Green
With Envy day two of exhilarating chess
coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to day two of the 2023 American Cup held
at the St Louis chess club we start the
day in front of the World Chess Hall of
Fame as well as one of the tallest chess
piece in the world it's been a fantastic
day one let's see what the players have
in store for day two let's go to the
studio and start the action with Jovi
and Yasser
we welcome you to Saint Louis Missouri
the capital of Chess in America this is
day two of the 2023 American cup from
the Saint Louis chess club
[Music]
and welcome from the Saint Louis chess
club studio and it's going to be a
thrilling day of action I'm
International Master at Ivanka houska
and it's a great pleasure to be here in
the studio calling all the action
alongside Grand Master yasa Sarah it's a
pleasure and honor to be with you in
Christian in studio to call all the
action hello everyone and welcome to day
two of the American Cup boy out of the
eight matches that were played yesterday
four were decisive it was a day of white
pieces as it was a whitewash for
decisive games let's take a look at the
standings Jovi and let's start with the
ladies definitely because we saw a lot
of bloodsheds the first day and uh just
taking the headline match Arena Crush
was absolutely dominant against Tate
abrahamian the very impressive Victory
from arena there and she leads one nil
and Moon moving down we go to the second
match between begin matokeo and chernova
against Katarina nemsova and their
tokichinova came with some fantastic
prep and just simply dominated in that
game must win situation from themselva
and in the Holy draw of this particular
section we saw a very hard Fort draw
between satonski and paikitsa it took
them 100 moves it did it was a century
and in our final match and the final
match was between 13 year old Alice Lee
against women's Grandmaster atusa
percussion and there Alice had the
pressure and she never let go she was
relentless and the scores in the Open
Bracket yeah and not so much Bloodshed
but a lot of Fighting Chess and
headlining the events with hikara
Nakamura and he was dominant with the
white pieces against Sam Sabian and he
leads one nails to have been in a
must-win situation it was a hard Fort
drop and a draw nonetheless in the game
between Lavon aronian and Dominguez two
local Grand Masters I would say and
moving down we also saw a very
comfortable draw by Grandmaster Sam
Shanklin as he held off Wesley so with
the white pieces and it was also another
draw in the game between Fabiano caruana
and this time it was actually Fabiana
caruano with the white pieces holding
off Ray Robson that's exactly right yes
and let's take a look at the format
reminding everybody it's a double
elimination yeah this is so exciting
this one is so thrilling and there you
can see it is a double elimination
bracket there are no draw offers allowed
and for the time being just for today
actually the players are all in the
Champions bracket and they're playing a
classical 90 minute plus 30 SEC second
increment format there is no second time
control but after today we're gonna see
eight players get sent down to the
elimination bracket where they will be
playing for their lives at the rapid
time control of 25 minutes plus 10
seconds 300 000 in total price upon 200
000 to the open and 100 000 to the
ladies and let's take a look at the
schedule oh you're in for a treat
because we're gonna see a lot a lot of
Chess today is the last time where
everyone is playing in the championship
bracket and it does mean that we are
going to see some deciders and if the
match is tied then we are going to see a
Playoffs being played later on today to
Rapid game playoffs and there's still a
type Blitz Games and then finally
Armageddon and tomorrow things heat up
indeed as we look at the playing Hall as
Alice is an early arrival reminding the
players that they have to go through a
security screen to get to the game and
we're very fortunate to have Christian
in studio nice to see you my friend and
what are the players who are the players
facing elimination what do they have to
do good to see you guys great to be back
in the studio for commentary here in day
two and what a fantastic start we had
yesterday I have to say in the open
section it was a story of Exquisite
opening preparation that H4 at move 16
by Fabiano caruana and the way Ray
Robson just composed replied with the
best moves that was just a fantastic
game and the clinical finish of Hikaru
Nakamura against Sam Seville and in the
latest section it was a story of this
ladies being so combative and ready to
fight for each and every point and let's
take a look at the head to head as we
are entering into day two in this
matchup in the open section the only
decisive results from yesterday was a
win by Hikaru Nakamura right now Sam
sevion is in a must win situation
situation to force the playoffs later
today and let's take a look at what
happened in the ladies section well
Irina crush the only Grand Master in the
the event just increase the pressure
throughout the game with the white
pieces yesterday and forced resignation
by tatev abrahamian who is now in a
must-win situation to force the playoffs
another big matchup yesterday was this
one the newcomer atusa percussion
against Alice Lee Alice Lee came with
that nimsa with F3 very aggressive
approach early on for from the youngster
and right now atusa is in a must-win
situation and the last decisive result
from yesterday's games was this one
pegimova well great preparation with the
white pieces defeated Katarina nimsova
who is now in a must-win situation to
force the playoffs later today and if
she doesn't win and if all those players
don't win they will be sent to the
elimination bracket right now the
elimination bracket is empty but
tomorrow this one will be filled guys we
have a fantastic event and we're ready
to call all the action in day two yes we
are uh Joey uh drill down a little bit
on the playoff scenario there just to
reinforce what the players will be
facing because it's going to be
spectacular day of Chess so there we see
it if the match is tied after two games
there will be first a two-game rapid
playoff
and if the match is still tied then it
will go down to the blitz playoff where
time is slashed even more with three
minutes plus two second increments and
after all this chess if the match is
still very much even then it all boils
down to an Armageddon game my personal
favorite where white will have five
minutes on the clock black will stop for
four minutes but black will play
withdraw odds but there is a there is a
silver lining for those players playing
the Armageddon because you do get a two
second increment from move 61 so
hopefully we won't have those mad
scrambles of my favorite and there we
can see the playing call we see Fabiano
carono arriving waiting to give a
handshake again sir Ray Robson and
Fabiano another local Grandmaster Ray
Ray too so yeah the two locals facing up
uh I was particularly uh surprised by
the interview yesterday that Wesley so
had with Sam Shanklin it was rather
funny as Wesley was just praising his
opponent to the skies Sam is so well
prepared he does this well he does that
well and boy you know I'm facing a guy
who's really really really hard on me
and then they had the head to head
Wesley beat him like five times no
losses nine draws it was like Wesley
said oh I didn't know I was that good
and uh today uh Sam with the white piece
was Christian
oh yeah that's that's that that's that's
a big matchup and this players know each
other so well right they play the match
just a one week ago in Berlin right that
one was won uh by Wesley so of course
that was a completely different time
format uh Jovi maybe you can tell us a
bit about that because you are actually
there I was actually there I was
actually commentating in that particular
format it was insanely quick I mean
players played a two-game head-to-head
match at the time control of three
minutes plus two seconds right and if
the match was still tied then it went
down to Armageddon and the whole
tournament series is called Armageddon
chess but ironically enough Wesley so
never actually got to an Armageddon
yeah and I think in that matchup
particularly there's a big difference
when it comes to shorter time controls
so I feel Sam has to put as much
pressure as possible early on in the
classical encounter because once they
get down to 25 plus 10 10 or 10 minutes
or even three plus two that's when
Wesley so shines and we know that
because he is the global Church Champion
he's been winning event after event in
this rapid templates formats and there
we go as we get started for this day two
of the American Cup 2023 defending
Champion Fabiano I mean you talked about
uh Christian this move H4 but uh
it didn't bring him any success and or
even an advantage I want to say look
that that was a that was a great
preparation that was a great move and a
great idea with this queen H5 that even
us couldn't understand right shocking
maybe even Fabiano didn't understand you
know I checked that with the computer
afterwards yeah and it turned out that
maybe Fabiano might have Mis moved so to
speak you know the best move by the
computer was actually to move the queen
to G4 so it might have been like an
overshot but he played Queen H5 very
quickly I think right if I'm not
mistaken nonetheless it was a crazy game
and I have to praise uh Ray's response
he responded so fine in that game that
Rook d8 move with the idea of Knight
wave or Knight to C5 and opening up the
D file I really liked the way he played
and I mean we've been talking about this
he's in Peak condition right now he's
been shining in every single event he's
playing and we've seen him at the U.S
championship in October he was very very
close to winning that event now over
2700 for the first time in his career he
is confident and he is shining
I do apologize I'm just having a little
problem getting getting the move relay
but I can put in the moves uh
okay all right okay and it's very trendy
at the minute to actually just push the
phone on dd2 push it two squares and
white has very comfortable what about H3
he used this particular opening just to
nullify Magnus
and that's a very good point Jovi uh I
feel like this is somewhat of a semi
draw offer perhaps he says okay
I'm not taking any risks with the white
pieces I know you're super well prepared
you're a Fabiano caruana Let's Take You
Down
to the rapid and Blitz portion you're
right and it is I mean that's a strategy
that you would expect from let's say
Hikaru Nakamura because Hikaru is really
known as a blitz and Rapid player but uh
Ray is probably thinking that his
chances
are best served in a a player that's
that seems to be the strategy after the
opening phase after what we're seeing
right now on the screen because this is
not considered to be a very testing
option no for white no this uh so-called
Scotch ending
um see far too many draws uh in this
particular ending yeah Bishop to D3 and
everybody is playing castles as well as
D5 but D5 and there's some like funny
moves uh White has been playing
differently than you know like the
automatic automatic captures but this
was how it used to go right like
everybody used to play it in in this
fashion uh castles Bishop G5 pardon me
with or without H7 H6 but C6 and queen
F3 and
I it just seems to me I've seen like
hundreds of games yeah from this
position
but white doesn't lose them
no and on that very rare occasion black
that's something dreadfully wrong okay
Bishop D2 this is a wrinkle oh yeah we
generally see he takes D5 that's by far
the main continuation
this is
somewhat of a challenge thrown by Ray
Robinson early on
Bishop to D2 of this kind of
getting the Zen here so my guess is that
if you do take on D5 which on e4 excuse
me which he didn't do he played Castle
instantly right
showing that he knows what he's doing
yeah Knight takes E4 and there's a
problem that you're ending up with
double pawns and really zip zero no
compensation so castles at once yes a
lot of sense
I'm assuming you
yeah so otherwise I mean if I take I
might even run into something awkward
after a rook check I don't think it's
terrible but I'm assuming it's castles
and then
well
there's a second can I can I capture a
pawn I just would like to see it
probably this is all Theory uh as well a
lot of Jovi This is actually the game
that you're mentioning between Ariana
and Magnus Carlson he orientare with the
white pieces chose the same idea with
Bishop to D2 and how did that game go I
can show you easy draw easy right
and in fact that Aryan actually came and
said I'm very very sorry to everyone for
actually not playing harder for the win
but I wanted to draw
let's be honest
wait a minute Bishop takes C3 Bishop
takes C3 right take on C3 what is this
yeah are you going to take back with the
Knight on e4 or with the pawn because
you do have to take that pawn right now
yeah I wanted to take the the the pawn
with the pawn and he's playing fast so
he must know because
this is a bit dubious right you take on
F6 then you I take on A4 and white is
getting what you are mentioning just
simply a better structure without not a
lot of compensation
can you take that all right yeah and if
you continue just for argument's sake
yeah
I'm not going to take oh well here I can
I can defend C6 so maybe you don't
probably go I mean the point that I
wanted to make was that if you do take
uh I was I wanted to play Bishop Acer so
not through B8 okay right and so I was
hoping that I would get in the tempo uh
with Rook d8 rather than putting my Rook
on B8 well we're going to see whether
yeah he's going for it
like I said guys this might be just a
straight line that goes into an equal
end game right the players are going to
shake hands very early on and very
possible
and then uh then obviously if the match
is a draw right we're gonna see if we're
going to see playoffs right I mean and
there's going to be a battle between Ray
Robson who is known for his speed right
he's also fantastic at the puzzle Rush
yes I was told I was told he practices
puzzle rush for eight hours per day I
bet that's just say it's a matter of
time I know and I was very naive when I
entered and there we actually gonna oh
he did play Rook B8 he did not play
Bishop A6 but sorry continue please the
players are on the fast track through
the draw right the vacuum yeah I mean
they think they're in the playoffs
already
[Laughter]
my goodness Bishop takes C6 Rook B8 and
this is all
known to both players it is theory yes
yes yes it's
a lot of games have been played in this
one in fact we've seen Wesley so versus
Magnus so it has been played at the
elite level as well I apologies but I'm
looking at this position I'm seeing an
ending and you're telling me this 49
games of theory with a rook and Bishop
and a rookie Bishop on the board right
now right now we're done with the
novelty I was going to ask about the
stats you know we found out those 49
games I mean has there been any
decisions 92 of the games have been
finishing in a draw 92 yes black has won
a grand total of zero games
and white has won maybe a couple that's
what or maybe you want to one white one
one game one game one game that's the
92.
the clash between karyakin and vidit
from January 2022. so uh videt is
immortalized as one of the only players
to lose this position basically because
of that game this line is not that
everybody's trying to uh emulate what
kariakin did to visit okay
let's jump to a game uh in the Champions
bracket where uh Hikaru needs to draw
Sam Seville needs a victory clear and we
have a very peculiar move in a very
standard Queen's Gambit uh decline
position everybody and his brother these
days plays Bishop B4 but at one time
Bishop E7 was the most popular move and
other times my personal favorite is
Knight B8 to D7 I never played and I
never even considered playing H7 H6 I do
know that Magnus Carlson
likes to throw in this move but H7 H6 I
don't know if this is the latest and
greatest or it just appears to me
frankly to be a lost Tempo I just don't
like this move but maybe it's okay I
mean it is okay I'm you know the theory
oh please I I do know that Theory I also
have happened to have lost this position
with the white pieces oh well done
wait me I was playing ariantari in in my
defense and I do know that Sam shankland
in his course recommends that you just
transpose into like a Catalan
and you just say what is this move right
um I've also been told that you can
actually probably put your Bishop on F4
yep
and just say hey look at that H6 doesn't
make any sense let's play into the other
lines well one of the things that I
would I love it when my opponent plays
these
non-threatening moves into the center
that is to say the move h7h6 takes
control of G5 you to stop Bishop G5 but
it does nothing to control the center so
from my perspective whenever my opponent
does something as obscure or off the
Beaten Track that's age 786 I'm always
looking to bust open the center in this
case E2 E4 so if I'm on the White Shoes
white side pardon me I would find the
move Queen C2 rather tempting it's not
like E7 E5 is going to blow I mean E2 E4
is going to blow black off the board
that's not but at least I want to
intimate yeah you know like this is my
way of trying to get some uh clear
Advantage it makes it makes a lot of
sense although you do have to always my
Golden Rule when I face an early Queen
C2 is if I'm playing with the black
pieces I'll be looking at C5 that's my
little antidote right yeah yeah and okay
and then we're kind of in a rush and
that makes a lot of sense what Jovi is
saying especially with the pawn on H6
right because there's no more Bishop to
G5 very often whenever you try to open
up the center you have to worry about
the pawn on D5 now you don't have to
worry about the pawn on D5 as black
because there's no more pin there's no
more Bishop G5 coming on the board so
right that's why Queen C2 it hasn't been
played as much uh at the elite level
because of this C5 reason interestingly
enough uh I don't know if Sam studied
your game with no worries Sam's opening
of course with Tyrion and Sam recommends
G3 but uh I was later told by one of my
friends and he said
no G3 no okay okay let's keep this quiet
between us and all our viewers no G3
just put the bishop on F4 and uh away uh
so this bishop F4 uh was played in the
world championship in 2018 with Fabi and
Magnus and there was no H7 H6 isn't
white a happy camper at this exact
moment oh there was Bishop to E7 which
is of course the main line instead of H6
and now the extra option that you have
with the presence of the the pawn on H6
is once again it's all about that
contact with the square G5 there's no
more Bishop landing on G5 so after
Bishop to F4 what black did and what
Hikaru already played is Bishop to D6
which forces either the bishop tray
either you retreat with the bishop all
the way to D2 but generally you don't
want to see as white those type of
retreating moves right then the bishop
on D6 is just fine there of course it
can be targeted and you can play C5 at
One Moment In Time time but in general
C5
it's not really seen with very positive
lenses by players playing the white side
in this type of structures
and uh so essentially what you're saying
is Bishop D6 has been seen this is still
that's right this is the main line yeah
and Hikaru knows it most likely Sam also
is aware of this variation I don't know
if he understands uh the Deep ideas in
the position nevertheless he knows what
he's doing for sure so uh if we were to
continue from this exact position
Christian with the move Bishop G3 Bishop
G3 is one of the moves yeah yeah I would
prefer Bishop takes Bishop just because
if I can uh toot my own trumpet please I
I actually played a London system not
that long ago against the Grand Master
and played a very perfect game by
playing Bishop takes bishop and that was
without black playing H6 and how did
Black respond to that Queen well they
tried to do B6 they did Queen takes
Queen takes
because this is an option it seems like
as well it doesn't look like a very good
option at least to my naked eye uh
taking with the pawn on D6 and allowing
the doubling of the pawns Queen D6 what
did you do three three I carried on as
normal and they carry you know after we
developed the pieces he went some B6
move which I thought wasn't very good
okay so a certain thing I'm just going
to make a move yeah I think yeah or
something or I'll I'll play even softer
Bishop D3 B6 yeah some something like
that and then import text porn happened
right and then it was just a very nice
game for me a perfect game I've heard it
was it was a perfect game
yeah I know because not often I play a
perfect game against the Grand Master
but you know I I went I went and I
checked her and I was I told my friend
you know you know hey tell me what the
computer said you know how much yeah and
I said oh you've got a scentsy-porn loss
of eight and I was like
I've never got that one before oh wow
this is like great move great move great
move not bad I mean I know it doesn't
often happen there's accuracy readings
are impressive I saw a game from the
European uh Championship Boris
girlfriend played I think the game was a
hard-fought draw but what was
extraordinary about that particular game
is both players had something like .006
inaccuracy I mean their moves were
virtually flawless I was like
remarkable so
what can I say but it doesn't really
make sense the Santi pornos because mine
was like ridiculously low but my
opponent was also quite low as well but
that can't have been the case right he
lost but let's uh let's check in with
the ladies before we do that yes I'm
gonna have to quiz you this is the first
quiz of an American Cup for you guys yes
what is do you trade only eight or do
you play Rook to B3 Rook to B4 things of
that nature what do you do I Retreat The
Rook
Jovi
wow you know you the players have set a
trend of exchanging everything possible
so why you know why
Rook takes C8 okay uh yeah sorry you are
right on this one Rook to B3 is The
Right Move Rook to you it actually
you're going to be worse as white in
this position and wow quite by a lot
because you cannot get your king no King
into any there's no more King to F1 so
the way you have to uh do things is to
go Bishop to D5 potentially keep in
contact with the pawn on F7 King to E7
and F3 the problem is you're not in time
Discord D5 for the bishop well I'm going
to attack it when the the king lands on
D6 so what I have to do is start with
the move F4 and once again after King to
F2 I'm going to create this cage for the
king
cooperation between the bishop 186 and
the pawn on F4 the king cannot get in my
king gets to the center very very
quickly and in fact you're on the press
space of potentially losing this game
right as uh White so don't exchange the
Rooks in that situation of course Ray
Robson knows he played the move Rook to
B3 and also it seems like Fabiano knew
the best response in the position which
is Bishop to E2 as you were mentioning
Jovi the players are going to exchange
some pieces but it wasn't the Rooks in
this instance it is the Bishops this one
is probably going to end very very
quickly I have yeah I think so too I
just have that inevitability yeah it
does you know I mean they've been
trading trading trading and I think
everybody knows it why fix it and yeah I
mean but uh say this game finishes it's
super early they will have to wait
that's right so Mayan I was at the
Players meeting we were both at the
Players meeting and uh at the
international Arbiter Chris Byrd
explained that the elimination games the
playoff games pardon me would be played
15 minutes after the final classical
game has been completed so they didn't
want people bashing the clock in the
playing Hall when somebody was uh so
we're expecting that uh 15 minute pause
let's turn our attention to the game
between tatv and Arena as we started our
show we explained that tatos in a Miss
must win situation with the white pieces
and one of the problems
facing arena is she's extraordinarily
cagey in her opening choices she has a
rather deep repertoire and and includes
Sicilians and within the Sicilian
complexes she can do a lot of things she
does a lot of dancing
things
she can be here
exactly classical Sicilian exactly
exactly she can throw you off so Tata
didn't go for any of the morosi bind
style of play just you know let's go for
these attacks early B7 B5 now I have
played this as black myself but for me
the real big practitioner was gotta
kamski
and he has only won the U.S Championship
five times and Challenger to the world
championship in 1996 was it yeah B7 B5
so this is early uh Queen side Palm push
as the black is basically saying to
White I'm going to play B4 Bishop B7 do
something and it's sort of like
you know could Tata get had guessed this
opening it was probably maybe the fifth
on her list maybe even further down than
that so uh again a very cagey uh uh
choice I want to say by Arena castles
and what are you going to do is Black
Knight C6 Knight takes C6 Bishop takes
C6 we're following a game
and I think the game we were following
was Hikaru Nakamura versus gato kamski
with Rook E1 the idea the idea behind
Rook E1 is for example if you played B4
is to jump with the Knight to D5 that
was not tata's Choice she played A4 B4
Knight
B1 okay that's a bit of a surprise for
me and
arena is actually uh thinking now uh
after this move Knight B1 bit of a
surprise I'm not that familiar uh with
this move or this position might be one
clearly tatv is reloading for Knight to
D2 to Knight to C4 but
I'm not a big fan
I must say of
you know when you play A4 and B4 you
know you really want to play Knight E2
and keep your knight in the center
Knight B1 feels like black
shouldn't have uh any problems here but
maybe I'm over underestimating uh this
position so I think you're you're
perfectly right about that Yasser and
that Rook to E1 was crucial instead of
the move A4 and that's the main line in
the position right look you generally
whenever you see the Sicilian you know
if you short Castle as white you're
probably going to try to tame the game a
little bit right you're not going to
have the craziness that's happening
whenever you have opposite side castles
but you still have to be forceful in
some way A4 and then retreating to B1
doesn't make a lot of sense why not
start with Rook to E1 and for example if
black tries to continue with the typical
D6 then I can go A4 and now black is in
deep danger because B4 is going to be
met by Knight to D5 and that's key if
Rook to E1 is going to force black to go
Knight to E7 or Bishop to E7 delay that
move these 6 well at least you're first
to ask questions in the position and I
think this is crucial and this is key
for this type of structures which that
unfortunately is not doing right now and
you sensed it right uh it does seem like
black Irina crush is out of danger out
of the opening yeah it's it's incredible
in the Sicilians how your knowledge has
to be
really almost Sublime you you you've got
to feel those exact moments and you got
to know the subtleties and one full step
light Knight B1 can toss away your
opening Advantage so for Arenas fans uh
she'll be happy let's take a look at
Katya
not exactly the H7 H6 uh that we saw but
at Queen's Gambit declined with the
bishop on
D6 let's just see how we got here yet
this is all standard stuff this was by
the way a big favorite position of uh
Miguel nidor he loved to do these b2b3
Bishop B2 Slow Burn attacks where he'd
put a knight in the center yeah
and boy did he clobber people it's like
a routine attack right right just know
exactly what to do and I've actually
also seen Hikaru play this type of Chess
as well you know when he just wants to
get someone out of their books right so
I mean it is popular I mean the thing is
it is quite straightforward for black
there are some antidotes already right
you can put your you can also play with
your knight on e4 as well on night on D7
yeah so for example just to buttress
your point B3 Knight D7 Bishop B2 not
waiting for white to complete his
development Queen E2 Rook to the center
you go 94 yourself you can go 94 yeah
exactly uh also a big shout out to uh
dear friend Arthur yusaport because
yusapov also like these B3 and slow play
did you ever get into these uh
Kali system I don't even know what you
call these attacks um I'm not very
successful whenever I play the white
side of these type positions because
I can never stop black from going C5 and
in fact getting just a good position
after C5 I don't know exactly how to
arrange my PC so that whenever black
plays C5 because they do play C5 yes at
the right moment I I cannot find that
moment where I can get the advantage so
no I try to shy away from this type of
situations I usually try to get my dark
Square Bishop in front of the pawn chain
either to F4 either to uh G5 as we have
seen in the Samsung versus the karuki
okay and then the two players who fought
to a standstill uh yesterday picking up
the action versus Anna we have a
I'd long last a very straightforward
Cadillac
how nice well well well we're not seeing
the last of this one because the players
are still just like rattling out they
should be rattling other moves because
this has all been played before Oh many
many many times and at one uh moment A7
A6 was all the rage I mean like just
everybody played A6 and followed by B5
and Bishop B7 so they're still early
days of the theory let's go to our 13
year old uh Alice Lee needing only a
draw to go on to the next uh match now
this is very strange by why she played
she plays the Petrov I mean yeah yeah
how much experience does this 13 year
old have hello
within her repertoire because I was also
checking out Alice's Lee's games and you
know she has a choice you know she can
pull out the
cariconikov you know just for those
fighting moments
D3 I'm not a big fan uh if you're going
to play a symmetrical position and you
want this the tiniest of pulls Queen E2
Queen E7 D3 Bishop G5 kind of makes
sense because it almost compels the move
Queen takes E2 Bishop takes E2 and you
could say I've won a Tempo in a
symmetrical position the way atticia
played it with uh D3 right away and D4 I
mean this symmetrical position
how are you going to create an imbalance
you're going to have to play C4 and it's
just not that great what about you know
because the first thing that always like
jumps to my mind yeah you could
unbalance the pawn structure but hey how
is black gonna actually deal with the
pin you know once that Bishop goes to G5
transforms itself into a dragon you know
okay hovering around the city yeah it's
on the board I mean what does black do
just like defend it does black copy yeah
just like in there copy works for me
until it doesn't
you know how that goes right and I guess
you go Knight D2 Knight D2 right and I
guess
you've established a pattern
I might not go 92. the aggressive
approach I go H3 H3 Bishop H5 and then
G4 how is this position
Christian well you've created aggressive
movement
you created an imbalance but I'm not
sure this isn't there's no 95. Knight E5
okay
I'm just throwing pieces at you yes wow
that
um okay
you you almost compel me to consider C5
I I I never saw a situation where I
really wanted to play C5 but I don't
know maybe you are okay let's try let's
let's go let's have some fun
so can I go F4 now yeah
wow read I know the lack of a better
word
greed is good huh uh
look I said a I have to say B at this
point I mean true true
I I so want to play Knight takes D4 I
mean with every fiber of my being and I
takes D4 Bishop takes a B6 Bishop C5
yeah the Discover check isn't that great
it's not the it's not the most
devastating I wouldn't trust it too much
no no which therefore kind of if F5 is
is a serious threat right you have to go
but now if I take with the queen I feel
like I finally got something yeah
I mean well yes and no I mean I'll give
you the fact that you've got your knight
on E5 but you know you've lifted uh your
Pawn shield in front of your king that
could be repercussions in case I get in
94. yeah no I agree and I have to defend
that score as fast as possible Right
probably Knight to D2 or Knight to C3
exactly but it's still a problem right
what is I mean the night coming to E4 I
mean can you use tactics to you might
have some tactics right yeah perhaps H6
followed by Knight takes G4 is that
well I get you I get there okay uh now
having said that whether we like it or
not maybe that's what white needs to do
I mean she's got to win the game she
can't just sit back and expect that
she's going to outplace up play at last
part but but this is a very interesting
psychological decision right because yes
you know she can't be expected just to
do nothing but at the same time you know
is she gonna burn the bridges so early
on in the game when she could just
develop the pieces and leave that
decision till later right I whenever I'm
playing an opponent who's just desperate
to make a draw it's like I almost want
to go slower and slower and slower
because then it's sort of like they
start trying to take pieces off the
board when they don't need to but they
react in in a poor way we'll keep an eye
on this one as well as we go back to the
championship section because I'm more
than curious what Sam sevillion was
going to do against Hikaru again in the
open section Sam is the only one needing
a win and after Bishop D6 okay let's
update he didn't play he took I guess
let me just update my board I apologize
um
yeah he took on D6 the move that you
wanted to play uh Jovi takes E3 castles
Rook C1 now the problem here is there is
a an idea of takes in Knight B5 thanks
to the Rook being on C1 suddenly uh the
C7 Square would really be uh
which compelled therefore the move A7 A6
now essentially I think what Hikaru was
saying is you can go ahead and get a
Carlsbad structure
with the pawns on A6 and H6 and I'm not
that unhappy I can play Bishop G4 and
trade off the bishop
um
the other Christian you mentioned C5
this is also I feel like the test of
this variation because he didn't get
away with it and you just go Bishop do
you need to rush with it and then I'll
just go Bishop E2 I I don't know I just
you know like you know like want my grip
I want my grip okay yes I understand
that but what if I go Knight C6 now
Knight C6 I have to do something fast
exactly I have to create my own company
A3 and now E5 yeah then you just leave
it because there's no dark Square Bishop
on the ball to meet you you can just as
long as you oh yeah
I mean yeah
oh you're thinking oh my goodness yes
sir hey look I gotta win the game I mean
it's not my fault but I've got to win
the game I might as well try to win the
game with a pawn in my pocket all right
all right all right
um
you're actually asking some serious
questions here well you were the one
with 85 but yes I am let's uh take on F3
first okay that's a hakasito yeah
now I'll take on default yep and you've
got a nice Tempo I give you that right
and let's try to take advantage of that
nice Tempo route to d8 okay
I mean let's go back get out of there
we're gonna go there okay all right
even though Bishop B6 here
you're a sneaky man well thank you I
resemble that remark
I forgot about how sneaky you are you
see yaser uh I need an adjustment period
whenever we hear him in the Contour
Studio I mean I agree with you that E5
is definitely the right way for black to
react and get counter play maybe a
little preparation with Rook d8 uh as a
possibility but uh maybe I have to play
C5 to try to create something yeah one
thing I just kind of wanted to say about
this type of position is um okay so even
if black manages to get E5 yeah and
doesn't abandon the D5 Pawn
I think white can I actually just go
Bishop Bishop B2 get the king to safety
and because there's no dark Square
Bishop on the board White's King is
relatively safe oh definitely abandoned
and then you can just concentrate on the
plan of just swarming yeah A4 V5 yeah
okay uh we'll keep an eye on this one
another Centurion game uh played
yesterday between Lanier and Levon uh
extraordinarily hard-fought draw to a in
a rook and partner ending uh we've got a
Berlin
yay and these days it's sort of like
it's getting rarer to see the Berlin
ending everybody's playing rookie one
and other little uh nasties uh
and amazingly enough they're still in
theory and it's looks like it goes for
quite some time A5 Rook d8 are all very
popular moves for
black okay keep an eye on that one Sam
Shanklin versus Wesley so another Berlin
how about this another Berlin ending I
mean to say
right here H5
and some with one hour and 30 minutes
while was the only one hour and 13
minutes
wow
still in theory though so they're in
theory they're still in theory yes
Knight to D6 is the moving distribution
Knight to D6 right it has to do
something so that makes a lot of sense
probably the the only move uh
a good General should lead his army into
battle right and he played
right this is Sparta the king comes up
King E6 that is the only move to
maintain the balance oh really yes yes
okay I was hoping that you know light
was somehow with a Super Active King
maybe I could tilt the balance in my
favor you're very right yeah yeah 36 has
to be played
that's actually a very very very funny
shot as uh Maurice is
is that a I I I think that's a screen
it's a great picture it's a TV yes yes
right so do they have different photos
that Loop through yeah I'd be terribly
distracting I would be very distracting
right yes and I'm sorry
Maurice for a while I think it is and
yesterday we were seeing Gary uh on any
of those TV screens as well so right
yeah so all all the world champions all
the famous people in the Chess World are
there in that hole right now E6
apparently this is all Theory theory yes
and how does it Go Christian and by
Theory I mean there has been three games
played in this position uh the most
famous one being the game between Grisha
and Anish giri from 2015. so perhaps
this is just one of those tries of Sam
where he's testing the memory of his
opponent hey do you remember how uh
Spanish played and how Anish defended 80
years ago well if you don't then you
might end up in trouble if you do sure I
understand we're going to go and play a
playoff later on in the day okay take us
break down the position first uh
Christian because in from my way of
thinking after the move King E6 if I get
to play Rook d8 correct yes I'm just I'm
super happy because my king is in the
game and your king is on G1 and I don't
see I see white having to to equalize
not so there's a few pitfalls that you
have to avoid one of them being I
probably have to defend the pawn on E5
with the move F4 right and now Rook to
d8 a or H doesn't really matter whoa
whoa Knight E3 93 right now F5 are you
sure
King back King back yes but this pawns
right now F6 I think you might be in
trouble yes sir well if I I'm still
forking check this out yes check this
out boom yeah
what if you take I take on F6 first
yeah look this is no okay this is well
known at least by these players I
guarantee you they've seen this and
they've analyzed this uh so they know
this type of patterns F4 Rook d8 you
wanted to show us Rook da root 2 d8 is
problematic in fact because now I have
time to set up this potential discovery
check with a move Rook to E1 so now the
Knight on D6 is more or less Untouchable
I cannot take on D6 because I'm going to
take with the pawn I'm going to invade
with my Rook on the seventh Rank and
then you're going to be in deep trouble
so this is not the best move what black
has to do is to take on these six in
fact
Force white to take with you cannot take
with the pawn because then I just hide
my king follow it up with Rook 28 you
don't have time to get your Rook to E7
and then I'm going to Corral the pawn on
D6 capture that and be opponent you
don't have enough uh as white so what
you have to do after Knight T6 you have
to take with the Rook but now I go King
to F5 and then we get this position
which once again seems to have been
analyzed extensively by the best chess
players in the world Rook 86 I can just
challenge that Rook with Rook to C8 and
this Rook The Rook on F1 is tied to the
defense of the Pawn on F4 if you lose
this Pawn if you try to invade with the
move Rook to D1 Rook to D7 I'm going to
capture the pawn on F4 and then you're
going to lose either G5 or E5 so it does
seem like I have enough compensation as
we expected the game between Ray Robson
and Fabiano caruana right now is headed
towards a draw and the players are
looking at chrisborn guys I mean look
rook and Three Points rook and three
pawns there's absolutely nothing we knew
that there will be nothing long time ago
exactly and the players did manage to
get to rook in three versus rook and
three
and we will be seeing them likely at
five o'clock just depending on how all
the other games uh continue but uh
that's what we're expecting we're going
to have at least one playoff match and I
think we're going to be getting a lot
more probably more
do you think we're going to see any
comebacks
yeah
yeah I think there's going to be at
least one which one that you're gonna
only time will tell you
I've been watching your shows
I watch your podcast too uh so I I know
all those commentary tricks
uh how about yourselves do you
anticipate a comeback one two men uh no
I don't think so no comebacks comebacks
wow okay but playoff number one that'll
be coming up later in the show Christian
you're anticipating a comeback or not I
anticipate one comeback one okay
um
I'm anticipating named Sova to win
against occasionally he's betting
against
him wait a minute it wasn't she your
choice to win the event
right then at least I got it right if
I'm wrong then my student wins and my
opinion right so okay it's a win-win
situation for me you know it's an
insurance I get it I get it okay so we
have one our first result uh drawn uh
let's just jump hold on to Sam sevillan
because
after A7 A6 Sam did not sa C5 he did not
play takes on D5 played the move A3
waiting for B6 which was played and now
you're more or less you're compelled to
take because if you don't Bishop to D B7
Knight D7 and black is absolutely
perfectly fine with this queen on D6
he's not been injured at all with those
moves age six and A6 and he'll have a
perfectly good game uh on the other hand
after takes takes we have these
imbalances where okay after Bishop D3
it's clear I'm going to go 92 Knight G3
eyeball the F5 square and by Queen C2
I've got the half open C file something
to nibble on but he's going to need more
than that Jovi yeah Sam is if he wants
to come back
it may be but I mean like just kind of
kind of quote you guys time will tell
you I don't know if that's allowed I
mean
one for broadcast right
but what I wanted to say is that you
know you just have to develop your
pieces I mean you just have not you
can't stress about the results you
simply just gotta play the game play
what's in front of you and as long as
your opponent hasn't equalizer as long
as the position is not simple
mistakes can be made of course uh one
other uh I don't know if you saw the
book it's a absolutely marvelous book
it's uh 200 best games of athletes be
slow
and uh smisov uh contrary to what a lot
of people think just played everything
just everything under the sun uh he had
ideas in groomfeld you name it and in a
position like this from the book uh
Smith played a move that would not have
been on my radar as a class player as a
class player I would have played Bishop
D3 in castled and things of that nature
Smith played the move G2 G3
and that was a really thought-provoking
move because the idea is that if you put
your Bishop on D3 black is going to play
Bishop B7 and Knight to E4
by not putting your Bishop on D3 it
means that a move like Knight E4 can be
met with simply Knight takes E4 like
okay you do get uh let me put a another
move on the board just for a second so
that you can see like I'm trying to
prove to get you to blunder okay
there you go there you go that's exactly
what it is it's a double hit to the pawn
and the idea that the bishop on G2 from
afar uh protects the E4 Square was uh
very insightful I've just felt like I
learned I picked up a lot from that one
single game with this move G2 G3 anyway
uh we'll see what that is Christian uh
do you have a position that caught you
right well I'm looking at this game
between
um percussion and Alice Lee and she did
it happen yes but in a different way she
started off with the move H6 first which
I do believe that in fact helps white to
get the type of positions that we were
looking at for example after Bishop to
H4 which was played Bishop to G4 came on
the board and now the question has to be
asked what do you do after the move H3
is this an improvement over the lines
that we were looking at and I think the
answer is yes why after Bish page five
G4 Bishop to G6 there's no more Pawn on
H7 so you only have one defender of that
Bishop on G6 what that means is that
after Knight to E5 this kind of forces
you to trade the Bishops on D3 and this
is something that you didn't want to see
on the board right right you wanted to
force me to weaken my position even more
wait for me to play the move F4 exactly
get another Tempo maybe play C5 maybe
try to strike in the center
unfortunately for you as black right now
you're forced because if you do give me
another move I'm just simply going to
take on G6 and be a pawn up Bishop takes
G6 follow it up with Knight takes G6
you're going to be in trouble you have
to take on D3 but after Queen takes D3
we get this type of positions with a
nice centralized Knight it's very
difficult to get rid of this pin if you
do play G5 well after the move Bishop to
G3 and F4 you're going to be huge huge
danger as uh black so I'm seeing this
position with the inclusion of the moves
H6 and Bishop to H4 and I have to say
I'm liking what atusa percussion is
doing and I'm seeing some chances right
now yeah nice and I was going to ask the
question okay so black can sorry if
white were to play h2h3 Black can of
course you know take up the gauntlet and
Retreat the bishop but can I also kind
of play it safe as one in a must
situation yeah can I actually go Bishop
takes Knight I mean when it comes to
these type of positions you know where
the pawn starch is symmetrical is it a
big deal you know that one side has a
knight the other one has a bishop I
don't think it's a big deal I don't but
it's one of those things where
psychologically it's sort of like
I want something I don't even know what
I want I force you to give up the extra
minor exchange I won the two Bishops I
don't know it's psychologically you
don't want to play the move but I agree
with you like how devastatingly bad is
it I don't think it's devastatingly bad
I think it's it's a position you can
play maybe you're not that excited about
the prospects but then again all you
need is a draw yeah I mean you just have
to huddle up in a little board
absolutely we do have a guess in the
studio we are ended with Ray Robson Ray
I have to start with this question
yesterday's game he came with this
incredible preparation very deep line of
the Catalan and this H4 move that made
you Ponder your options how did you feel
at that point
yeah I mean obviously I was not
expecting that line at all but I guess I
knew it a little bit not too deeply but
I knew some maybe General ideas but yeah
H4 I wasn't really sure I thought
probably his ideas to play H5 next but
apparently it's just like a I guess a
useful waiting move which was kind of
hard for me to figure out over the board
um but I think I reacted okay oh you
reacted almost the best it seemed like
right and at some point maybe you even
were taking over did you feel like that
yeah I mean this line is is a kind of
risky for white also like why it's
definitely risking to get worse in some
positions
um probably I had some chances for
Advantage
but it is difficult to play I really
during the game I felt like E5 is
probably the strongest I had a strong
feeling but
I couldn't quite convince myself and
I've been attending C5 the whole time
so I spent a long time there but I went
with C5 which is still okay but after
that kind of he equalized tell us the
story of today's game you came with the
white pieces it didn't feel like you
chose a very combative line would you
frame it that way no I definitely didn't
I guess I chose probably the most solid
way to play
um yeah just I guess strategy and also
based on how I was feeling
um I think also in the past I've I've
lost a lot of games with the white
against Fabi so I just felt like playing
Saul today and we'll you know we'll
probably have a lot more fights in the
playoffs how do you assess your chances
in the playoffs as the time control gets
shorter
ah well he's still the favorite but
um
I think I I do believe in myself so I
think if I
play well I think I'm playing fine so I
think I'm going to have some chances I
hope so but uh yeah I think it's gonna
be a tough match hopefully very close
one and yeah this year they added the
possibility of Blitz before Armageddon
so it could also be a very long match I
guess we'll we'll have to find out but
it is going to be difficult if we do go
to Blitz I think just all this
transitioning between time controls it's
probably going to be difficult for both
of us I assume have you done any
specific training
to transition quickly from time time
formats well I I just played in Berlin
which was a blitz tournament it was
called Armageddon
um so I guess I was playing some Blitz
recently it was three plus two so same
time control that we could play here but
nowadays there's so many different
tournaments also online which are either
Rapid or Blitz that a lot of the top
players play in so I guess everyone is
kind of used to playing those time
controls regularly nowadays
um I think I'm still not that
experienced especially
maybe in Rapid I feel like I'm maybe the
least experienced comparing between
classical and and Blitz and Rapid
um but obviously I played in the protest
League several years
some training games so I mean I have I
have enough experience there too right
he's still a big match a long match but
potentially ahead of yourself will let
you go get some rest and we'll see you
later quick quick question for you Ray
because uh Jovi's I know you're Pat
you're fabulous at puzzle rush and I
think you actually just won a puzzle
Rush Championship as well but she said
and I quote that you do eight hours of
training uh with puzzle Rush is that
true
eight hours of puzzle per day per day
um definitely not recently I'm sure I I
could like I've probably played more
than anyone in the world
um
and yeah I mean the I guess when I was
really like
playing a lot trying to like break
records and stuff I was basically
playing all day so I'm sure I did
um yeah nowadays I definitely don't play
eight hours a day
um and I do
try to cut back even more I think I
don't think it's necessarily actually I
think it could be harmful
um not just because of the time
spent not focusing on regular chests but
uh also you just get used to only
looking for certain patterns you're not
really using your brain that much to
like think more broadly about Chess so
um yeah I'm not doing any puzzle Rush
during the tournament or anything all
right very good luck to you in the
playoffs thank you Rick
and turning our attention yeah I know
speaking of the playoffs yeah we do have
to remind everyone how the format is you
know it probably starts around about
and here it is if the match is tied you
get the two game rapid playoff where the
time control is 10 minutes plus a five
second increment if the match is still
tied then you get a two game Blitz
playoff three minutes plus two second
increments and then finally it matches
again still tied we go down to
Armageddon where white will have five
minutes and black will have four minutes
but does get draw odds and the two
second increment will kick in from move
61. marvelous and we have another guest
with Christian in studio
Fabi in our eyes a very tense match so
far between yourself and Ray how would
you describe it up to this point yeah
well it had didn't have so much content
the first game had had some content for
sure
but I didn't really get many chances and
in fact I think he was the one who had
probably a better position at some point
the opening wasn't really a success it
was more based on surprise value but he
knew it uh more intimately than I had
hoped and today Ray took a decision
um to go to a wrap the rapid playoff
rather than try to press and potentially
make it a three result game
I mean I knew that this was an option I
wasn't sure what his mindset would be if
he wanted to do this or if he wanted to
to play a full game and uh and see what
happens but but it's certainly a
strategy I mean I I think were you ready
for it
well there's not much to be ready for
like if he wants to dry it was I was
wasn't opposed to the idea
I was ready for the possibility let's
say but you can't prepare
um
let's say for a draw unless you're
really trying to press for women black
and I didn't feel like like that was a
necessity
so um yeah I was more like trying to
figure out ways that he would try to
outplay me the opening or again imagine
the opening not that he would try to
clean up the game because
that's just you know we'll go to Rapid
and see what happens a big point of
discussion has the has been this balance
between the time formats you play
classical then you play rapid maybe
Blitz maybe even Armageddon are you
ready for that how do you get ready for
those type of situations and I think
we're really used to it because a lot of
events have a mix of different time
controls and especially 10 minute is
quite um
quite in fashion these days like okay
it's played here with the five second
increment but also there's a lot of
online events where it's played with a
two second agreement and last year there
was also a lot of online inventors
played Without increment so we have yeah
slightly different types of time
controls but but the spirit Remains the
Same I mean rapid has its own set of uh
let's say Necessities compared to
classical chess and Blitz is of course
even even more different and Armageddon
is a whole other thing which still we're
getting used to I think a lot of players
because it's not so common but
um but I have to say like in the last
let's say two years three years I've
probably played more Armageddon than in
my entire career before that potentially
a long match ahead of yourself what are
you going to do for the next three hours
are we going to get some rest are you
going to train look at his openings
what's the schedule probably a mix of
all that and and also keep an eye on the
games that are in progress but yeah some
some prep uh some strategy and and some
rest as well is important guys any
questions yeah quick question for you
fabric uh the conjecture of my colleague
Jovi it's not me this is Jovi She said
in game one after you played the move H4
that Queen H5 was you you messed up your
preparation you intended to to play
Queen G4 is what she said
confuses Top Choice is Queen G4 we were
confused by age four and queen H5 what
explained that is the best so the Box
stops with Jovi exactly
so so again H4 was sort of preparation
but A6 I wasn't ready for I didn't know
uh the nuances of that compared to A5
which I thought was a bit more natural
to push the pawn a bit farther
and after A5 I was going to play Queen
H5 after A6 I I figured there's probably
some difference the B5 Bishop is a bit
more secure so maybe C5 is more of an
idea for him
but I didn't want to think about uh
intricacies in a position where it's
going to be very difficult to figure out
you know the differences so I decided
anyway to quickly play Queen H5 and see
what happens
it ended up probably not being the best
move but also Queen G4 King AJ it's not
like I saw the next move so clearly like
what my plan is I wasn't sure I thought
basically my ideal setup is to
be able to put like a bishop somewhere
let's say on F4 to put my other work on
B1 and to put a queen on F3 but uh yeah
the setup is very hard to achieve and in
the game I didn't quite manage hmm well
Jovi is very satisfied with your answer
thank you
thank you for
trying
so he he prepared Queen H5 against A5
but when A6 came he played It Anyway
same thing right okay good luck in the
playoffs uh
um Bobby uh turning our attention uh to
the game between
um Naji and Anna actually it's funny I I
introduced uh I played against Walter
Brown and then world champion Anatoly
karpov is white this move uh Bishop F4
in this particular position with the
inclusion of castles and B5 uh
not actually interestingly enough played
excuse me not castles but Bishop F4 at
wands and it in the case of
um
uh karpov when he played the move Knight
D5 I was very happy to allow him to play
Knight takes F4 I wanted to play that
position uh with that imbalance uh
Bishop D6 was also played uh against me
again with the moves castles and B5 on
the board but now A Different Twist uh
by Naji immediately Knight E5 and this
puts some questions uh to Black's
position you don't want to play B5
anymore I mean this bishop on G2 is just
lurking on this diagonal and B5 is just
a temporary move it kicks my queen but
so what I go back to C2 or B3 why did
you weaken yourself with B5 but in the
meanwhile I mean you've got to do
something and C5 it well you know no
you're not ready for this so yeah the
question is do you have to go Knight H5
do you have to go 90 five are you
familiar with any of this looks
um more natural I have to say I mean I
definitely will just kind of like piggy
back on your point about opening up a C5
do not do that unless you have a safe
place for your queen exactly and you
actually developed often C5 comes as the
last kind of like the cherry on the top
you know Knight D5 makes a lot of sense
to me and I was wondering about the
situation to take the bishop off as well
as the pawn structure and here I was
ready to Castle long as white oh yes
exactly I've got the half open G file I
started I'm not certain no no no I mean
as a commentator I can take my moves
back the players can't but yes uh half
open G file I mean it's it's an
intriguing uh challenge that Nazi Naji
has set for Anna we'll see uh your quick
take would you like to play Black here
kings are going on opposite flanks no I
actually wouldn't like to play Black
even though I do love the bishop pair I
mean just take a look at why it's power
on the on the bishop in a G2 is just
it's great cutting the position in half
is very difficult to unravel right and
also there's a lot of dynamic potential
with these doubled F pawns you know yes
you do have the possibility of going F5
at one side maybe even D5 I'm not so
much worried about the G line
um I'm not sure I would be as bold to
put my king on the queen side I was kind
of uh verging more towards putting it
towards stick it in the corner keep it
nice and safe and then kind of play E3
protect everything but
um I think this is very difficult for
Anna to unravel I mean if she has to get
her night out the bishop out
not an easy task at all I mean the only
person I know who really thrives in this
type of cramped positions with the
bishoper is gattacamski I mean not
necessarily in this particular situation
but I've seen him play a little Shuffle
on the back side has this talent for
like waiting and then you know when he
arrived where the time is right he
pounces he unravels and those two
bishops come to life Christian jumped in
on this uh situation do you like I love
playing with the G file open like that
yeah yes and with that powerful knight
on E5 I really like the structures for
white so I would play Knight C3 in a
heartbeat yeah if um did you guys cover
why Bishop takes D5 is not working why
there was a discover check exactly that
was a little bit frightening
very difficult
very very dangerous yes
I probably
probably have fallen for that before
that's the first thing I'm looking at
right give me that pawn right no right
C3 is just a powerful move and in fact
there is a big game between uh Gary
Kasparov you might have heard your team
and Ulf Anderson from 1985 Gary was
white he did play the move Knight to C3
they did enter those type of positions
with the double F pawns and Gary did win
that game so I do like the dynamic play
that white infuses into the position by
this uh change of structure taking with
a G3 Pawn to F4 so I like the move
Knight to C and we yeah and look at the
board Knight C3 is not on the board yet
but we have 95 95 is on the board yes
and let's not forget
Naji if she wins this game she wins the
match exactly outright and I'm sure she
wants to see uh that happen right you
don't want to go into a playoff into a
playoff anything can happen you want to
put as much pressure with the white
pieces on your opponent and she actually
pressured Anna satonski with the black
pieces as well let's not forget
yesterday's match so the trend is
definitely in her favor in this match
and take a look at the clock situation
44 minutes for Anna zatoski 1 hour and
22 minutes for Naji paikidza that's a
huge time difference and I'm sure she's
going to make use of that situation
thank you Christian and as we prepare
ourselves for a break tell us about
today's special at Q Boutique working
out for our viewers well you can
celebrate the 2023 American cup with a
super soft limited edition t-shirt
featuring the Saint Louis chess logo on
the front and the American Cup 2023 logo
on the back and it's available right now
online at qbtecstl.com
sure lovely shirts nice red color
absolutely and we'll see you on the
other side of the break
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-sized chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16-year-old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chess board
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind of has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
sinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time I like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back on day two of the American
cop which is going to be a thrilling day
because today is a day when things are
going to be decided by the playoffs and
we already have one match that is going
to go to playoffs Carolina and Robson
that's Even Stevens one point a piece
and we will have playoffs around about 5
30. right allow us to correct ourselves
5 30 is a report that we're getting it
and then the ladies and in the women's
section and we have several players in a
must-win situation to take the match to
the playoffs we have Arena crash and
it's Tata who needs to win with the
white pieces in the second match we have
Katarina nemcover also needs to win with
the white pieces and uh is what half a
point between zatonski and aikitsa
meanwhile honestly she is in cruise
control because she comes actually won
her game yesterday and it is a two-step
procession the newcomer who needs to win
let's just jump right into the game
between tatcha and begum because things
have really uh
heated up in this game we have the move
E6 E5 and uh I think
um Christian was explaining that he
didn't really like these positions as
white because he never really found a
good answer with C5 normally speaking I
don't
when I'm in these positions is black I
don't play for the move e6e5 myself I do
play for C5 and I usually include the
Prelude
a7a6 to prepare C5
um begum she just went for it and played
the move B E5 and this allowed akacha
this very crafty little move which I
like a lot Bishop to F5 sidestepping the
threat of E5 E4 while putting pressure
on the Knight on D7 and after E4 Knight
D2 there's nothing really wrong with the
French defense
uh but one of the things that can go
really really right
with the French defenses when the center
becomes overextended and in this
particular case I'm looking at this
situation for begum and I'm saying hey
wait a minute you know if if it's white
to play takes on D5 and Center collapses
like it's just like really really over
and it's not like the move C7 C6 is a
dream kind of move it's not a dream but
I I have to say it's the first move that
appeals to me it doesn't it does yeah
because I love a stable Pawn Center and
the one thing I would say about this
particular pornstar Archer is Black's
Bishop on D6 is a dream piece when you
want to attack the white king which is
what this Pawn structure is just
screaming at me yeah and uh yeah you got
the piece on the ideal square and white
has to do something right unfortunately
chipping away oh yes there is a
counterpart to that the bishop D6 is
beautiful but look at the bishop on B7
right
so let's go F3 let's try to move
something you said let's do we have to
do something we do have to do something
and that is the move F3 and once this
lands on the board what is the bishop on
B7 actually going through right yeah I
wanted to say the same thing you've got
the beautiful Bishop on D6 I mean I'm
I'm with you all the way Joby I love
that Bishop Bishop on B7 says hey coach
I'm a little bit uh I'm a little bit
stuck and the move F3 is a very timely
break takes Queen takes F3 we can sort
of start to see that we're seeing the
attack coming right I've got something
for free
so there there are issues suddenly and
and I think it was really of begum's own
you know it was self-induced the movie
E6 E5 you know she she needs a draw and
she's on to the next round and the move
E5 she was probably expecting a lot a
lot of trades in the move Bishop F5 but
push back a little bit look at that yes
sir E5 Bishop to F5 yep you're in a draw
is good type of situation that's always
the match yeah why would you ever play
E4 and not just simply chop the pawn on
D4 I agree on D4 yeah if you take with
the Knight I'm going to take on C4 as
right that's going to give me a better
Pawn structure and finally the bishop B7
is going to have a beautiful life right
ahead of itself and if you take with the
pawn then I mean sure but how do you
continue after it exactly the best one
B2 right now is kind of locked you don't
have F3 to open up the position it's
quite symmetrical as we look at it so it
just makes a lot of sense that you don't
want to create any more imbalances by
placing that pawn on e4 I I'm a little
doubtful was she maybe fearful of some
kind of a pawn sacrifice
I I don't even have to take it right I
can go Bishop Bishop E5 apparently I'm
sorry even at that point after Knight to
B5 uh yeah okay you take on B5 maybe I
don't have to
I would not play the move E5 E4 leave
the board full of pieces yeah with all
kinds of possibilities for my opponent
and If You're Gonna Play E5 you trade
them off especially when you need a draw
look yeah if she was in like an equal
situation or a must-win situation sure
consider E4 keep more pieces and more
opportunities on the board for both
sides right but since you only need a
draw eliminate as much material as
possible you guys have been too
objective
I think you look at it as well
and it's like it's too beautiful just
take a look at that let's turn our
attention to the game between Tata and
arena for a second because we felt that
the moves A4 B4 Knight B1 by Tata if
we're a little bit mistimed and we
thought that Arena was going to be able
to get an easy game Bishop C5 Bishop D6
intriguing way of play
I'm sure when Todd Taft played the move
Queen E2 she had one thing lurking on
her mind and she was probably hoping
that Arena was going to play a move like
A5 and taker threat seriously Arena
ignored it with the move Knight G6 F4
castles and we're up to date with the
players uh
and as uh We've mentioned uh all she
needs is a draw Arena to cruise to the
second round now again she's coming in
as the defending champion and we saw her
performance in 2022 was Stellar I mean
she just won her matches clean and was a
convincing uh Champion uh and this is a
key position right now a key moment
for tatev she needs to play a very
specific move but first she needs to
understand why
okay what is Black's threat and this is
something that we always as trust
players ask ourselves what is my
opponent's threat in the position in
this case it's not a tactical threat
it's a strategic thinking is going to be
e6e5 exactly put the Knight on F4
exactly so what do you have to do stop
and counteract that how do you stop it
but G3 feels wrong but do I have to play
E5 no you have to go G3 G3 is the right
move which dominates the Knight on G6
this is quite key about this spawn push
it looks artificial especially since the
bispawn C6 will most likely have some
fun on the long diagonal right you know
that long diagonal has opened up but
what you can do and what you can build
up upon with this move G3 is not only
that you take away the F4 Square for the
Knight but it can also improve your
position later on and you have a clear
plan ahead of yourself after the move H4
H4 H5 kicked that Knight back get the
king to H2 and try to do something on
the king side so this move G3 in fact
gives tative white in this situation
quite a significant Advantage wow stuff
because I I didn't know I'm very
reluctant to play G3 I don't know about
you
it makes a lot of sense actually when
you're objective about the whole thing
and you're like oh yeah control the
Knight to something which I'm really
quite keen on
um I did not even think about the idea
of E5
so I have to say you guys
I mean that I was I was not on my radar
at all I was thinking about f 5 I was
thinking about A5 as being a kind of a
positional idea for black
um I mean I was going down completely a
different uh pathway myself I was
wondering can I go whole hog and go E5
and F5 and make the pretense uh that I
met at you know a gleeful attacker but
uh I must say I I personally find the
move with G2 G3 a difficult move to make
that is it is you know but you know if
you can play G3 Bishop D2 rookie one and
keep it going fine it's I I guess
develop your pieces right go Bishop E3
right right one and the problem with
Bishop B3 once again this is the
critical idea in the position is that
you play the move E5 as black and follow
it up immediately after F5 which most
likely is going to come on the board
with the move from Knight to F4 right
and that's key right
yeah nice nice idea I I'm learning in
this practice every day I mean E5 very
instructive put in the memory bank right
uh we took a break here and I was really
really curious to see how Alice is going
to deal with uh this pin on uh her night
she played the move uh
oh Knight C3 C6 HC so we included Knight
C3 uh the bishop dropped back and I
guess we were expecting 95
and C5 yeah I mean hmm
I have to say
last move C 5
because because
and it was just to kind of again to
piggyback on almost yes last the last
games point you know there we were
looking at the move G3 to kind of
control the night circuit here the pawn
on C6 I really am big fan of stable Pawn
structures it does a great job of just
keeping this Knight on C3 out of the
game right and where is it going
back to E2 essentially I I don't have
any forward hops but the move C5
conversely does give it does give the
forward hop and uh I mean I'm guessing
Alice only played this because she must
have thought that F4 F5 was like a
serious
threatened yeah but then that just
raised the question that after Knight B5
well I mean don't you have to play
Bishop E7 now yeah I mean more or less
you're compelled and I'll make a square
at least in this case for my pieces uh
the night something like this uh and
well Alice has saddled herself with an
isolated Queen Pawn maybe something for
the light a little nibble here and
there's also ideas of going Knight GG
for the right time G4 okay now we've got
H3 for free right exactly nice uh let's
just check in on Kate before we and we
do have C7 C6 on the board by big and we
do like the move F2 F3 for white
breaking open uh the center and uh well
seizing the initiative how about you
Christian what uh what games have caught
your eye well what move caught my eye
and this move rooked away so so this is
the position Anna satonski spends a lot
of time on this one and she plays the
move Rook to A7 what do you guys she
wants to play Bishop D7 Bishop EA or
perhaps she wants to go
right or B5 Bishop B7 that's another
idea Bob but it just strikes me as such
an odd configuration to to start off
with this move Rook to A7 and what if I
just get the queen back
to day three I mean is it so bad you go
B5 well now I can go long Castle right
Bishop to B7 and I'm now I'm going to
viciously attack you on the G file once
you play the move G6 at this point is
going to go down the board H4 H5 open up
the king side Checkmate to you right
this is not looking good and I don't
feel like she has Anastasia that is
enough speed in the position to counter
attack on the queen side while on the
king side things are not looking bright
for that King on G8 so I really like
what Naji is doing right now I also like
her time
Management in this game and I don't like
Anna's time management
I was gonna say uh you know the more I
look at it the more I'm actually
agreeing with Christian and you the King
has to go to the queen size exactly and
uh yeah don't forget there is no second
time control right that's true 27
minutes and then you're going to play on
increment
but there's such a thing in chess is
playing ugly
and I gotta tell you guys I mean rookie
seven to my mind is just an ugly move I
mean you know you've done something has
gone wrong
if you have to play a move like Rook A7
because that's just not a move that you
want to play you want to play F7 F6 you
want to play Queen H4 uh you you don't
want to just sit around passively uh
Queen H4 hitting the pawn provoking E3
making Queen side castling a little bit
awkward you want to play F7 F6 drive
this powerful night out uh away you want
to play Knight D7 Rook A7
I mean I'm almost happy that you want to
play the move B5 uh go ahead uh my queen
isn't doing that great on C4 now I start
to think about shifting it over to
either H3 or G3 followed by Rook G1
these type of things boy I'm
I I mean I'm almost feeling like a rook
takes G7 is just about to uh land uh
yeah Square in the position yeah I mean
black can't even set up a world
formation by going E6 F7 G6 you're right
um because of course the peace sacrifice
will happen that's right G6 but I have
to say maybe Anna has kind of
underestimated this up this possibility
of castling Queen side yeah I think
maybe she's just kind of been fixated
that white wall actually castled to the
king side and then B5 Bishop B7 makes a
lot more sense well even in this case
um it's like one of those things where
you kind of mentioned yourself that you
don't mind castling
King side tucking your king into the
corner playing the move King H1 as a
Prelude to Rook G1 doubling along the G
file and then you find your king is safe
on H1 or maybe safer on H1 than on C1 so
I mean for me the whole idea of B5
Bishop B7 trying to solve the problem
the bishop is way too slow well keep an
eye on this one I wanted to turn our
attention to the game of Hikaru for just
a moment because Hikaru is one of those
players and the only player in the open
section who's uh leading and needs only
a draw to continue in the Champions
bracket when we left it we left it
around these parts let's see how the
play continued takes takes Rook a seven
I like this move a lot by Hikaru the
open file is the a file let's Double
Trouble
Rook A1 and one Trader Brooks and Knight
E1
um
first first take is black has no issues
he's played the move Knight E4 the only
weakness I would say in Black's position
is the Pawn on C6 and that's comfortably
defended it's actually not even that
easy for white to attack the pond I mean
they're half open C file is not enough
and 94 Hikaru is doing well linear
versus Lavon this is the Berlin ending
and if you tell me that this is still
Theory
[Laughter]
oh dear uh
balanced it looks even Christian well
white definitely has the upper hand why
it has a majority King side doesn't have
to worry about a majority on the queen
side for black because of the Double C
pawns so any sort of end game is going
to be just uh preferable for white right
this situation now the question is let's
back it up a few moves
before this move H takes G4
so Bishop to E7 G4 at this point he
played the move Bishop to E6 I think
this was an oversight and he played it
very quickly in two two minutes I
checked it uh on the database now if you
take on G4
take on G4 and now you go Bishop to E6
once Rook takes d8 comes on the board
King takes d8 Knight to F4 now what you
can do
is move the bishop away
or try to defend it somehow but you
don't have to allow white to take on E6
if you do it with the pawns on H5 and H3
which is what happened in the game
now you have to allow Knight takes E6
and the messing of this structure right
and entering of this position because if
you go Bishop B7 or Bishop C8 hide away
the bishop Knight takes H5 come on the
board you're a pawn down so it feels
like this is a very basic oversight
unless Levon has studied this position
and knows that it's a fortress the
position that we have currently on the
board with the spawn on G6 white is
obviously going to try to create a past
Pawn with the move F4 King F3 at the
right moment King three four
how is black going to respond to that
the question I would ask black and help
me out here guys I want a straight
Bishop ending oh yes
and trade the road wait wait with white
with white really right yeah yeah I see
only two results my understanding was
that you actually don't want to exchange
the Rooks because that would be a
fortress what yes that that was the way
I saw this position play out interesting
in the words of uh
somebody great nobody believes you
okay Larson uh hold on just a second uh
okay so you're saying the Fortress would
occur after the trade of the Rooks yes
okay because I put my king on F7 let's
see oh and I'm just waiting okay because
I will put my king on e4 that's fine I
don't know if I want to play C5 the
white ones you know what you have ideas
of maybe trying to get a king and pawn
ending like with the King on H3 put the
bishop on H4 my Bishop is out it's free
yeah baby yeah I'm just gonna B6 I don't
know if I want to put the pawn on C5 but
let's assume I will go this this route
now what
um
[Laughter]
let's say I go C6 uh bishop and her
Bishop is out I just wanted to go King
E4
and yeah this bishop page four is kind
of annoying
and I I just thought it was winning so
it was like a really surprised that uh
what if I go King he ate it was oh I
don't see Fortress breakthrough Bishop
f8 okay this is where yeah
the king
um I'm going to stay on D7 this time
okay just because I don't want to allow
I understand so you stay here and I'll
get in there okay we're we're working on
magic or or should we put our Bishop
here first just to dominate right
exactly yeah and now I think you have to
take I have to take yeah yeah and now I
go king of seven but then you go F6 and
yeah you have to yeah you have to break
through somehow right also but wow uh
okay uh different
I I guess the approach I have in these
kinds of circumstances is this ending
this bishop ending I shouldn't say I
find it winning or one only that it's
two results I always I've never lose
yeah and I gotta win once or twice uh
draw so that's his achievement the Rooks
as well right right he's on the board
with the rocks on the board there's two
results as well
I mean unless you swap it off that black
Rook on H1 HR h8 is going to be super
annoying but but for me I'm sorry here
again I'm showing my generational uh age
if you will for me the move Bishop E6 is
not carpovian move the karpovian move is
you you never allow your your pieces to
get tickled by a move like Knight F4 you
would just put your Bishop on C8 where
you can never touch karpov's pieces they
were like you know at a distance and
when you played the move Knight F4 it
doesn't come with this Tempo against the
bishop so I agree with you
wholeheartedly that like LaVon fell
asleep on the position and he's allowed
Knight takes E6 and he's finding himself
in a very awkward moment and meanwhile I
I have to say that uh so I think Lanier
said F4 I can always play Rook H1 that's
not going away
F4 is a move I I want and perhaps the
reason is that if you do go Rook H1
first yeah maybe I can take take and
play G4 and go G5 yeah I think this is
what he was worried about
okay I get a pass Pawn you do get a pass
Pawn but then I drive my king to G6 and
yeah perhaps that is uh the Fortress
that he was thinking okay I I I can I
can support that and the move F4 I I I
mean if your intention is to take away
that option with G5 and you go Rook H1
next
Levon tortured yesterday he's returning
the favor yes he will this is going to
be a long torture indeed and uh
uh well uh F4 uh whites for Choice big
time Sam Shanklin versus Wesley so whoa
this is the Berlin ending
um
this was the one and he did take on
anything
I remember Christian was not a big fan
of that move because of the king just
parking itself on D7 and did Sam managed
to get a nickel as we a little bit it
seems like Sam actually came with a very
interesting uh he's got it
this Rook to D3 was some sort of a
novelty and it was a
very intriguing novelty I have to say
Rook to D3 yeah
right really good move really really
good move to ask some questions from
your opponent well intriguing uh lee
enough at the opening ceremony as having
dinner Sam Shanklin was at the table
he's telling me that he had been doing
an enormous amount of book a work on his
new book of Rook endings
there we go okay guess what he's got
he's got a rook ending and uh he's
better yeah it's no question he's better
I the question Christian that I would
ask you is how much better is white well
supposedly not that much better really
yes not that much better after either
King to D6 or even King to F6 both of
them seem to be playable nevertheless
with the engine is this right right
without the engine with some pressure
piling up knowing the fact that if you
do lose this game well you're out you're
really yeah they lost one of your lives
right so you want to make that draw
there's some pressure this is a game of
two results and definitely with the
white pieces Sam Shanklin this is what
he envisioned at home I want to get this
type of position I'm not risking
anything there's no way white loses this
exactly absolutely no way
I'm technically playing almost with a
pawn up at this point right that F Pawn
that's the majority for black on the
queen side doesn't really matter right
so I like what he did I I'm I'm really
in Marvel of uh of his preparation and I
think he got what he wanted out of the
opening as far as I can tell he's
achieved all of his objectives because
in this case nimsovich really did have a
good point the idea was that the pawns
on the queen side black doesn't have a
candidate passer whereas white already
has a pass Pawn on on the file and after
the move Rook E4 objectively speaking
white is playing a pawn ahead and the
move Rook E4 or besides just being kind
of a good active move it does it's a
Prelude to an attacking move like Rook
H4 and if you do end up doing something
like this I'd probably be inclined to
recapture the pawn because I think the G
Pawn as a passer would be more effective
than the F Pawn G4 the G Pawn would be a
little bit further away from White of a
black skin yeah to result game yeah
definitely two result game I have to say
though I mean that is that Rick and pawn
ending that you had there on the board
it feels like the black king needs to be
like maybe yeah
black Rook can kind of liberate itself
and go to D the d8 file and go to D2 and
then of course itself a nuisance so I
just wonder why
maybe this is why he's thinking about
perhaps putting his King
on F6 yeah I wasn't quite sure where to
be honest with you I think he wants to
have the D file open for his Rook to try
to invade right and create some sort of
uh counter chances I can understand why
uh the move King F6 might be a little
bit if I'm thinking F5 he played King F5
King F5 remarkable okay so I mean for me
you know inviting The Rook to the
seventh I mean I don't have to be asked
twice it doesn't feel right
but then you have Rook takes Rick takes
work okay check yeah you're gonna take
with the King yeah it might be a little
bit more inclined in this case I mean
had you know alert
on E7 I don't know I mean not a big fan
not a big fan okay
wow uh by the way uh once again to
remind people
um this match is tied the first game was
a draw but Wesley came in yesterday
louding his opponent to the skies only
to discover that he had an incredible
plus score with Sam Shanklin Sam
Shanklin has never defeated Wesley in a
classical uh game no so this would be
now would be a good time and a decider
so is this going to turn into some sort
of a race of who gets to pick more Pawns
rookie seven let's say let's say Rook
takes G3 and then Rook to d8
and it's some sort of a uh
gunfight
you mean after takes takes Rook did you
take away the pawn or no the king that
was initially you want to take with you
yeah you want to take this okay I did I
do I I now look to d8 I guess
okay and now we're up to the end and
you're saying the the race flares Anew
here
is that true take my Pawn I go Rook to
D2 and how do we assess this position is
my love
my favorite living condition
okay
continues I take yours
okay C4 yeah how how is this position
uh check you give me a check okay that
check was a sneaky one and I did not see
it yeah
[Laughter]
what's better than being one part
okay you have to go B4 then before yes
that's a good move yeah okay give me
another Pawn
which takes
all right let's go King F4 first king F4
oh wow
wow
guys I'm in I'm in the two result
territory you're enjoying yourself I see
I see yeah but okay but I understand
what you're saying uh you started
looking at counter play Maybe H4 H4
first yeah maybe H4 it came just okay to
a little later now at least well I don't
know
A5 but now you don't get to my pawns
that easily right right now
hang away one second you can you don't
have to rush with Rook B7 you can first
go Rook C7
[Music]
and now A4 yeah yeah you guys are taking
the words right out of my mouth
are you reminding me of Meatloaf you
took the words right out of my mind it's
not a pleasant position for a black guy
no
um you have to be if you're still within
the drugs uh Zone you have to be very
precise I I agree with you
wholeheartedly we'll keep an eye on this
one uh Sam sevion once again okay uh he
ended up capturing on e4 and playing F3
um the car is doing well I don't think
Hikaru is suffering at all here he's
making a very uh he's he's playing very
solidly I'll put it like that let's turn
to the ladies because again a lot whoa
let me see if I've got this right I'm
going to just refresh the game of Anna
whoa Rook how about these apples Rook A7
Rook D1
go ahead and play your B5 no Anna
changed her mind play Queen H4 and B6
huh
okay a little bit confusing
I got a little bit messed up here uh so
after cat I was about to say after
castles a moment I was about to suggest
Castle short queen E2 on the board
feels like uh whites
much Superior I I really like White's
position here uh very much in the game
of tatv and Arena
arena is really trying to force that if
to go play G3
a very standard move by the way it's
interesting how many Sicilians tie
monops you go Queen C7 it's like an
automatic the queen always belongs on C7
but in this particular line this early
B5 expansion Queen often goes to B8 it
actually is a better Square sometimes a
move like E5 can be met with a nice
retreating Bishop to C7 the queen B8
yeah
he's trying to get her to play TV that
is pretty funny is G3 a good move yes
it's the best moment it gives white the
advantage right well especially now for
a while yeah especially now that you've
managed to include the move A5 so your
Pawn isn't actually on pre the bishop
could find itself in a very attractive
Square on B6 but once again uh from a
human's perspective it's difficult to
open up that long diagonal which
bishop's still sitting on G on C6
exactly it's just very very difficult
yeah we have this mindset of you know
something might happen on that long
right the queen might end up on D5 after
I play E5 and get checkmate right it's
in the back of your mind yeah we're born
with fear
you know it's a part of us the engine
says what are you talking about the
bishop is just play G3 just by E3 you're
fine uh let's jump to Katya and whoa
very a very very different approach
after the move C7 C6 we were expecting
F3 Karcher went A4
aha okay if I can if I can imagine what
he wants she wants to take take Knight
B5 let's say Bishop
back yeah Bishop A3 and capture control
of the D6 were that she's afraid of the
move Bishop A6 so she thought aha I'll
be very clever I'll play A4 so I want to
do this queen B8 tickles H2
G3 and A6 to stop the very idea I just
showed A5 and why would she play A5
because B5 B5
I think she's just saying look at your
light Square Bishop
it ain't good it ain't good but uh for
the moment black is keeping everything
closed on the queen size so how do we
react guys do we go B5 or do we take on
A5 I play B5 you play B5 yeah yeah I
have to say
please say it I was more tempted to
actually take on A5 very good very good
the training's working but I think I
think in an actual game I probably would
have gone before right preserve the pawn
structure you're gonna go back to your
makes it the four nations chess League
I go C5 right now C5 yeah yeah okay just
seeing the position and I feel like
white is the only one that can play for
something which is the move F3 okay I go
B4 we close shop yeah and then now you
get the queen out of Dodge oh yes
I want to go back to d8 okay I was
thinking
yes yes this is my plan but okay I like
your one better Bishop
so do I have time to open up the
position with F3 well uh can we snare
upon you have to go for it let's do it
okay I've got I've got uh uh uh so stamp
of approval you're blackmailing me right
now yeah exactly exactly I only needs a
drawer to get through to the
championship okay that makes a lot of
sense that's probably a good strategy
wait wait wait we're not done yet we're
not done yet I take on e4 you're gonna
King H1 how is this
well uh
yeah but I have some compensation I feel
like
it's it's awkward if I can't I I of
course I wanted to play Queen G3 uh but
I'm a little bit afraid of Knight F3 my
Bishop's trap but can you not just go
back to the plan and just go Bishop
where no Bishop Bishop C8 Bishop C8 yeah
Bishop C8 can I take that
yeah and and here I was thinking the
worst thing is like you have to take
with a rook right yeah I take a take
with the Rook yeah although it is
actually possible to take the queen but
from that perspective of culture I mean
you know damn the torpedoes I mean she's
got oh she's crazy
she's got E5 can you take with the queen
This was oh I apologize it's definitely
a move yeah yeah because I've got Knight
G4 at the end of it and I I realize that
perhaps this is not what you want to do
when you just need to draw but you know
look at that poor cane it's coming let's
go off let's go
have been poor for some time now let's
go to G3
yeah Queen F3 it does feel like white
has I mean I've got two minorities
you know dynamic equality if you want to
put it well I mean again this is the
type of position that Kate could dream
about coming into today's game she needs
to really really uh mix it up but I I I
was thinking completely in a different
way which was like after Knight f8 F3
take it take it get get your Bishop back
to C8 and just say okay uh solid solid
uh chess please
and uh begum needs a draw but uh I was
about to say that uh A5 B5 C5 it was a
strange approach from White's
perspective uh let's jump into the game
of Alice Lee for a second
situation is
Tusa she needs to win absolutely and
Alice just has to hold the fort
and
there was a moment ago you had said
something about Knight G4 in this
particular case I might be tempted to
play Bishop to G4 but hmm I
like White's position yeah I was just
wondering two Bishops two Bishops it's
nice I mean feels good but how should
white approach this because with the
obvious let's go B3 okay uh just to chip
away at that yeah I want you to play B5
uh I I can meet B5 with either capturing
on C4 or even playing the move A4 if you
capture on the other hand then you're
opening up my rook and I'm ready to play
C4 with more Center
if you are what I have a comfortable
pull
feels like katusha's gotten something
here it seems like everybody that's in a
mastering situation has got them
something exactly in in this uh well
maybe not Samsung maybe not yeah Hikaru
seems to be defending uh that position
quite accurately but everybody else
seems to have some chances exactly let's
go to the champion section to see if Sam
no nothing happened since F2 F3 in this
game again we do know that Ray Robson
and Fabiano caruana are going into a
playoff
for those who are joining this late
expect that match to start more or less
around 5 30. by the way after King F5
Rook E7 by Shanklin was played and Rook
takes G3 and we have a pause
Rook takes G3 stop I
okay dare I say let's go King takes G3
that makes a lot of sense yeah that's
what we were looking at and
the question is how is this a rook
ending of The Rook d8 or do you just
protect those pawns with every single
piece that you have just The Rook a rook
d8 that was the one that was the uh
I wanted to say in the most testing
right
That's My Philosophy you know I feel
like if you want to disturb the balance
for someone who has an advantage in a
broken Pawn ending you need to activate
your work your Rook is in
it's a great piece and maybe I frighten
you guys from from the line but but
there is this possibility of going to
and even three pawns down where your
passer on C3 might be just enough
counter play to force some kind of a
Perpetual pet in the position so I think
Wesley's still in the drawing Zone but
it's getting
close it's getting close linear versus
Lavon again he went Rook H1 so we're
about to I'm Christian if I could ask
you what does the engine think about the
game between Lanier and Levon does it
think it's a draw it's it's very
difficult to say the engine is saying
plus one but we know that plus one can
mean that this is a fortress and why it
doesn't actually have a way to break
through but they will be enjoying a very
nice Advantage for the rest of the game
or playing for two results right now but
it is on plus one it is a big question
can you go King to G2 King to H3 and
then your plan that you're very
accurately pointed out to take this
bishop off the d8 H4 diagonal because if
you manage to do that then the king
might invade through uh that pass right
King H4 King G5 and then maybe you get
your F5 going
so let's take a look at that
came to F7 King to G2 let's say I wait
King to uh E8 you go King H3 you go
Bishop to F2 right
let's say I go Bishop to f8 and you
finally got your diagonal I keep staying
on this diagonal you go Bishop to d8 I
defend
how do you make any progress how do you
continue making any progress you've got
pretty much everything you wanted oh
definitely you gave me everything I want
you my king on e4 and what my Pawn on F5
so you don't want to go King to eight we
can go King age we can't go King age you
can if you want yeah right yeah on G5
you know because I kind of like it
though yeah yes yes but I like it on e4
that's fine yeah
right
King to E4 yep King to F7 now continue
yes here in one C4
C4 I was thinking that because you want
to follow up with B4 lock your Bishop
out yeah exactly this is why I wanted
yeah I'll continue waiting okay before
before maybe C5 right okay yeah yeah
it's legal it's legal and B5 B5 I take
take yeah
I think I was a little Hasty with the
movie before I believe uh we go back to
that moment and let me get in F5 okay
you get that five yes yeah so now I have
to exchange everything I think so I take
take
right maybe even continue taking wow
okay so this is a dream you get
everything yeah easy easy
that's fine I wait wow
okay so really I I've made as much
progress as I possibly could I feel I
feel great about that is the question is
it the Fortress or not wow right
so you put a point on witch Pony five
uh can I can I hunt your Bishop with
King E4 and King Bishop D4 sure
but then I go Bishop uh
that was my but that should still be
okay because I go King E7 right and King
F5 king of five and now I wait
wow and even this somehow
wow because you get this end game and
then you get the king here but now I can
go B5 maybe even King to have fate wow I
have to wow B5 is the only move in this
position in fact really yes
everything else loses because I go E7
followed by King to E6 right B5 makes it
imagine
trying to calculate all of these ideas
right trying to defend by playing this
precisely without an engine this is the
task that Levon aronian has like the
challenge that is a challenge as well
and also you know you have to bear in
mind that say we rushed with a lot of
decisions and a great end game plan
what would have actually kind of just
massaged yeah you know Advance the apple
and perhaps got an appointed A5 or
something so that when you do get that
King and pawn under you're ready with
your little trump card exactly yeah
um wow I think lavon's under severe
stress but you said something I thought
was very intriguing Christian you said
How Deeply has Lavon studied this when
he played the move Bishop E6 did he
think that we don't yeah did he know it
was a fortress I don't think he did I
think it's just a gut instinct
which is dangerous
relying on your gut instinct is
dangerous but these guys are a former
2800 level players so
they have a pretty good gut instinct
right it's the stuff that you think you
know that gets you into trouble and
that's a little ignorance is uh was no
sorry a little knowledge is worse than
no knowledge right a little now
um okay uh very good and Hikaru is still
uh again he I think his car was doing uh
I think he's doing great right and this
is also one of Hikaru strands you know
the last few years he's really worked on
changing his style becoming more solid
she's not stable you're resilient what
was really surprising for me was uh in
the city of the interview that a
Christian had with Hikaru yesterday
where Hikaru came on and confessed I
haven't played since Madrid I haven't
played since the candidates I mean I'm
as Rusty as Sin that was nine months ago
I was like
because he didn't play the U.S
Championship right and he skipped the
sinfield cup as well I mean lots of
things he didn't play I mean of course
he's very busy with the stream and power
to him but uh yeah that's a long time uh
and he came back with an impressive
emphatic win in fact it was a really uh
for somebody who's hasn't been on the
president if your car is just another
level right you know I mean just even
take the streaming you know he says
there he talks to Chad he engages with
them he plays great chess he wins title
Tuesday's Gone Wrong and there you can
see his world ranking it's something
ridiculous right he's won like 40 title
Tuesdays I mean and and this is again
feels a world-class Fields it's
ridiculous and I can tell you I've
discussed this with many other streamers
and I'm because I'm just trying to start
streaming myself and I say you know it's
it's really difficult to talk to chat to
engage with them to think of things to
say
and then playing your game and
concentrating or trying to concentrate
on what's happening on the board in
front of you and then you know trying
not to get emotional about it you know
when obviously things go wrong and
everyone is telling me it's difficult
any person in the world who can actually
pay great chess talk to chats do all
these things Hikaru and you see that
here you know nine months without
playing for most people you know there
would be some roughness and you know he
opens up with a bang you know he
completely demolishes a Sam sebion re
remarkable indeed we're going to take a
short break and we're going to see you
on the other side
thank you
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why just as
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
foreign
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
the sound of personalized Health Care
sounds like life and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11-time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the World Chess Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back
and we're right in the middle of all the
action of day two indeed and it's been
an eventful day as we have four players
pacing elimination we're thinking one is
going to win but uh which one uh we have
a very intriguing game going on between
uh Lanier and Lavon they have drawn
their first game but we've we're in a
situation where it's a two result game
thanks to these double pawns from the
Berlin white is the one who's going to
create a candidate passer with the move
F5 and we have been intrigued by this
ending can Levant does Lavon have a
fortress or not we're still unsure it's
almost like we're giving white
everything he wants and we still haven't
managed to win it for Lanier and I think
we don't need to give white everything
they want also you don't even have to
right so we've been putting the bishop
on the A7 G1 diagonal Levon is taking a
completely different approach putting
the bishop on H6 he's staying there so
how do you kick the bishop out the King
on E8 has a very specific idea in mind
and that is to defend the square d8
there's no Bishop d8 there's no Bishop
takes C7 you're not winning that pawn
exactly so I'm just going to stay on D7
and E8 how will it continue and the idea
that we've uh been talking about is just
putting their King on E8 and saying you
can have your Pawn on E6 and that's it
you don't get your Bishop to d8 you
don't get your kingdee uh to C8 or
anywhere and I just wait it's it's a
remarkable conception Sam Shanklin is
enjoying a rook ending but now after
this recapture with the pawn on G3 I'm
thinking Suddenly It's much closer to a
draw than it was when we left it uh and
that match also would go to tie breaks
which again we're expecting to at about
5 30.
unfortunately for Sam sevillian's fans
he's not making much of an impression
against Hikaru he needs to win the Sam's
heavy and having lost the first game and
uh it's about even let's jump to the
ladies as Alice Lee slightly worse I'm
going to say she's given up the two
Bishops white has a more comfy control
of the center so a little bit of
something for atusha in this game the
funny one or the fun one was this game
between uh Katja and begum after the
move A5 guess what
she took it she took it we were looking
at B5 I think we we flipped the coin
here
I did you know my instinct was to take
the ball exactly and my positional
instincts kicked in and I was thinking
no no I cannot ruin my Pawn structure
like that yeah there's double pawns on
the queen side okay well keep an eye on
this one and another game that was
really heating up was this a Catalan
between Naji and Anna Queen E2 provoke
Queen E7 well
this seems rather
indecisive I want to say bayano as she
played Queen H for for a purpose now she
retreated a queen queen came to H5 if
you go backwards I'll go forward and
maybe on a good day I'll try to force
induce a weakness with the move Bishop
E4 okay now the Bishops came off the
board Knight jumped to E4 and what is
that Rook on B7 doing
uh not much
it's overprotecting all the points
I know it looks weird but you know there
is C5 in the air so one day yeah okay
I'm gonna move my knight okay and now
the first thing is can can she get away
with okay Knight D7 first right
97.0 G1 yeah yeah what do you have
basically I'm not worried about a bishop
Shack the move Rook Bishop check forces
me to go King the E2 I'm not worried
about it so Rook G1 no concrete threat
but just
black continues you know with the idea
of I'm wondering whether to throw in the
bishop check and then go C5 in uh let's
say I invite you to do it in one way and
invite you to do it the other way with
your Bishop on D6 or the bishop and
either way the response will be D5 yes
exactly so uh in either case you ruin my
fund
I'm just like you know I mean Christian
is actually the party pooper around here
he's the guy who's telling no you can't
do that no it doesn't work no sacrifice
with the title yes yes uh embrace it but
we do think that uh Naji is building up
something tatv another of the players
needs a win and guess what she didn't
play that move G3 Queen d8 did provoke
E5 Bishop went back and after D7 D6
feels like tatv has got pardon me Irina
has got things uh well under control
suddenly in the night on G6 is actually
a good piece when the pawn was on G3 the
Knight wasn't that great but now we can
see that any captures
hello yeah you know that is uh that's
fun and there's two Bishops right
pointing towards the black so the white
king exactly it's a bit scary I mean can
you try to throw caution to the wind and
just go it's all in 1924 is one thing I
wanted to play exactly that's a Tempo
yeah and probably you know I I like this
diagonal so much and I I'm reluctant to
abandon it by playing a move like Bishop
to D7 but Bishop D5 and now you want to
go takes an F5 I don't want to take oh
you don't this is where I said abandon
my pieces and then after night here I
want to get F6
guys guys guys check check the last move
uh by Nazi
okay uh well we were in the the death
throws of something going on here I
wasn't checking out I wasn't sure
whether it was inspired or horrible but
okay
the lat you know sacrificing a piece
exactly
whoa It's the best movie in the position
yeah Rook to G1 is the best move
alongside short Castle
really and basically saying what that
this extra piece is
nothing you will actually take it with a
d-pawn
with the Deep even yes yes oh my
goodness with a d-pawn then I would
assume you're going to give me a check I
always assume let's go King it working
to F1 yeah both of them should be
working quite well so I was trying to
get the queen
oh Knight F6 check exactly that's the
key of Rook to G1 oh Knight F6 check and
that's curtains that is big time and for
example if you try to go Knight D7
then I have ideas
followed by Knight to F6
well in this case I do have a check on
DC3
some of the fun right
because you've got to put your king
suddenly on G well then I can trade
Queens so perhaps I have to do it with
the King on E2 ah okay you mean right
here start with this move let's try it
out like that
and let's just have a quick by the way
maybe I should take the bishop B4 first
with A3 like a normal human thing yeah
exactly that was the thing that I also I
found very very disturbing what am I
going to do about A3 I mean the bishop
simply trapped and I I I didn't think
that I thought that run right you just
have to I didn't think I had the time to
save the bishop by giving myself a
square it's like what is my Bishop even
doing over there when when I might just
be getting checkmated right that's right
yeah yeah
wow
Rook G1 it's a really good move
especially given the fact that Anna only
has 13 minutes left on her clock so she
will have to figure out all these
complications in 13 minutes with less
time by the way for the remainder of the
game there's no second time control this
is the only match that is tied should
one of these players win and all the
wrestling games are drawn there'll be no
playoffs
very combative chess and this is this is
brewing up to be the
I love this move Rook G1 I mean that is
a really really she's piling up the
pressure yes powerful move I want to say
yeah just asking and that is not a move
that Anna wanted to see exactly at this
moment either and uh also bearing in
mind as Christian mentioned the clock
times you know Anna under 13 minutes to
navigate these troubling Waters verses
14 42 minutes he has 41. yeah that's wow
huge time difference and it's you know
they have this expression yes where I'm
from it's easier to attack than to
defend it's true it really really is and
uh especially when you're in time
trouble it feels like your clock is not
your enemy when you're attacking when
you're defending and you're in time
trouble the clock it feels like your
worst enemy and we do have a draw as uh
our second playoff in the Championships
section was there any chance for Sam in
that ending that he it felt like he had
something something at a certain moment
but was the computer ever convinced no
no no no no otherwise Wesley defended
quite accurately it was difficult from a
human's perspective as we understood
early on but Wesley also understood that
he has to create counter chances he did
play the move Rook to d8 as we were
anticipating that's why he decided to
keep the King on the f file so that he
keeps the D file open for the invasion
of his Rook Rook to d8 came on the board
Rook to F7 Rook to F2 so white Sam
decided to take a passive approach don't
munch on those pawns because black is
going to munch on the pawns on the queen
side as well and that's going to create
some difficulties and it ended up in a
drafter King F5 just a repetition and
these two players are headed towards the
playoff all right thank you for that and
turning our attention again back to the
game of kacha and begum we did see the
move Knight f8 something that I was kind
of well pounding the table was strong
but you know that Bishop on these yeah
and it's real I mean it's a sore thumb
you look at that video
exactly the way of the world these days
basics of uh good strategy and in this
case uh I would love as white to go back
to that F2 F3 break I think that gotcha
missed her opportunity earlier in the
game to get in the F to F3 break now
that the bishop is actually on H3 F3
does not come at the expense of Bishop
takes to G3 so I think it it's now or
never you want to play F3 or you you
won't get in it I'm fearful if I don't
play F3 then Bishop C8 and I could have
problems on the inside I mean but even
if you do get F3 I mean black is really
not obliged to capture that pawn you
turn no because you can go Bishops you
can go back to your plan Bishop C8 I'll
take it and then Queen takes I'm gonna
sacrifice an exchange don't ask me twice
but I will sacrifice an exchange on F6
[Laughter]
on her clock
um hard for me to tell it's like they
put it in like three it is three three
points six minutes six or just under
seven minutes wow that's not a lot of
minutes especially when you have to
start calculating moves such as F3
see that for for me the issue there is
confidence or in this particular case
lack of confidence I bet your coach has
been you know analyzing analyzing and
then double checking and treble checking
and that's where the time trouble comes
from you know sometimes you just
you play your instinctive move that you
want to play and you don't just dwell on
it for you know 10 15 minutes and watch
your clock tick away I think you're spot
on on that one this is a lack of
confidence for yeah exactly and it's
because she doesn't play as enough right
she is a PhD student after all that is
her main focus and she doesn't play that
much and whenever you don't play that
there's a ring rust there right right
right this is actually one of the
biggest difference between
um boys and girls I want to say is not
to do with playing so to speak but it's
actually to do with playing Blitz I
often see that a lot of young boys and
even males just get together and they're
able to play Blitz against each other as
much as possible meanwhile when it comes
to women I mean we just don't somehow
just don't do that and I often find that
a lot of players just learn by playing
absolutely and if they're and then if I
think back to my childhood I basically
basically became an international master
of the back of all these like five
minute games that I played against my
brother you know it was just me too
Relentless I absolutely feel that's the
case uh you know
he played thousands of Blitz games
against my friends and uh today with the
internet I would have been playing much
more it was very hard actually to always
meet week after week in a certain time
in a certain location but now you can
play all the time and I do hear you loud
and clear I go to these summer camps or
chess camps and you can just see at
night when all the instructors are like
you know we're dead the kids are playing
but the boys are ravenous yes but I
think that's to do with numbers if I'm
honest with you you know I think think
because the local numbers you know the
girls are kind of a little bit more
intimidating it is a much more
intimidating if you're like one or two
or three out of 50 or something you know
and you know you get a lot of attention
and I think that's a hindrance and as
soon as we kind of balance out the
numbers and we get everyone playing as
much as possible get that connection
pushing those pieces of wood then I'm
gonna I bet you we're gonna see the
difference become a lot less exactly by
the way talking about confidence for
just a quick second naji's Rook G1 to my
mind that shows great confidence that's
like okay let's go let's let's have some
fun and take my piece and we do see the
move C5 well first of all the D5 is one
question but what if I go Knight C4 now
Knight C4 and then I have options of
even just taking the pawn on C5 right
correct like you have to go Bishop C7 I
don't see anything no other choice and
now I can also just take the pawn I can
go D5 right and that's probably the best
move in the position the move D5 is the
one that always uh frightened me you
know what let's go D5 let's not get
greedy let's not get greedy and give the
Rook on B7 play right Cody five
uh that looks it's just completely
killing that that looks a really strong
Christian I mean that is just well wow I
mean you you've got everything uh look
there's a rook on B7 there's a knight on
B8 Bishop d8 I mean that's such an ugly
move but if if it belongs the game it'll
survives you know you're down for that
yeah
sometimes yeah you have to do what you
really really don't like but okay yeah I
mean but the move C5
oh boy uh C5 funnily enough Rook G1
and then you know you you want to play
this attacking game and then suddenly
you're playing the safety game with
Knight C4 and D5 it doesn't seem like it
meshes uh is there a way of just going
all in
after the move C5
um
Jump Right In you guys have shown me
Knight C4 yeah difficult to kind of
suddenly Switch and Go well maybe I'm
going to lift up The Rook well let's
have some fun I mean we're commentators
we can take our move back very very uh
good um
okay Rook takes
okay so I'm wanting I want to play
Knight takes DC yeah so then I'm
thinking you know there's an attacker in
the middle of my field
attacker in the middle of my field boy
you're
okay because I mean okay I know that
this is really bad because the night
thanks for coming oh I'm glad I got you
this is not this is not your doing I
mean you're suffering here this is the
kind of stuff that happens in my
nightmares right I attend a position and
it's like this and you're just thinking
I didn't make these moves and the
Arbiter goes well yes you did we have
pressure
but somehow when we're doing commentary
Maurice and I together
he sometimes complains why am I getting
the bad positions why don't I get the
chance to okay you defend this position
yes or he would say to me this is why I
really loved commentating with Judith
Paul yes I mean she she would always
take the attacking side right and she
and we would have to defend these
terrible positions
yes I was like I'm loving it uh two very
attractive moves for Naji Nazi for I
must say I that that is such a powerful
looking move to my mind but also D5 as
well or the combination of both Knight
C4 and D5 looks like uh Naji is cruising
I just want to again check with kacha oh
this was a very different approach f
2 F4
I'm not a fan what about yourself I I
kind of like it I feel that it has a lot
more tension in the position I feel that
we don't know don't forget all she needs
is a draw the move F4 doesn't open the
position that's true but it does keep a
lot of the pieces on the board whereas
F3 did invite some simplification okay
therefore you know you can still imagine
a future where I'll fall for it Bishop
C8 uh just uh I mean that's my bad
Bishop let me trade it off and that is
the type of position that I have to say
is very difficult to understand with a
human's eye with a human's perspective I
go F5 now
my guess is this is what she wants to do
she wants to launch an attack via F5 G4
G5 and try to open up the instruction
there now pulling out what we all know
and understand about me I said I'm I'm a
demonic uh tactician
I'm not a pawn Grabber it never happened
Pinocchio get out of here Bishop takes
yes you want to take take and Nigeria
that's your idea I do I do
it holds a lot
um
yeah let's
but I cannot continue this uh I don't
have Rook to E1 because at least you
have a draw right yeah F2 and if I
probably have more than that yeah I I I
fear that I actually do have more why
she took an ampersand interesting uh I
expected this you did I I did expect
this bishop to C8 is by far the best
move from an objective point of view but
I expected her to take on F3 just
because from a human's perspective right
uh I don't understand that after Bishop
C8 F5 it's that easy to play for black
psychologically take Bishop C8 makes
also a lot of sense psychologically it's
kind of funny right your opponent plays
F3
forcing you to capture but no your
opponent plays F4 and then you go
I'm gonna do it I'm facade anyway okay
there's also a saying you cannot refuse
Amazon right you can't refuse when
Amazon is on the board you have to play
it it's like a force move uh-huh
[Music]
the streamers Bishop C8 on the board
again uh Katya with much less time on
her clock she's gonna have to go into
James Bond mode now I mean she really
needs a victory to force a playoff and
uh it's time it's in 30 seconds it's
time to capture and play E4 and close
your eyes and just hope that the attack
hits hits
yeah yeah it's time that's what I'm
thinking is capture and E4 let's go uh
Alice Lee let's jump
again we still think that white is for
Choice here more more space in the
center two Bishops still looking uh
pretty good for two
yeah let's uh let's
quickly check in on Tata yeah when we've
left it we've just seen this position
with uh the move D6 and I I didn't see
Queen H4 coming for some reason I
thought the pawn on F4
really needed uh defense I'm a little
bit surprised that we didn't see the
move F5
I would have been very attracted to this
move F5 again because I just think that
it's not so easy to defend this Pawn
we can include anytime you like 94
Bishop dd5 I
something about this uh looked
attractive Arena
said hey Queen B7 Rook F2 and what are
the clock times in this game
30 minutes on her clock only 12 minutes
for tatif and again tatv is the one in
uh situation yeah to force a player and
talking about other people in must win
situations can we just uh revisit the
game some Savion against Hikaru Nakamura
because
I'm just doing yes around
the playing Hall uh double attack there
is a double attack
C6 and uh okay just a second
just a second can I just get the last
moves here so
it's night
Queen
three
okay
[Music]
um
uh
uh Queen G5 do I have another move
I don't think you do queen G5 looks kind
of forced
right I mean you if you take I got a
check so by the way so if you do play
Rook to E1 yes do I have Rook A1 is is
that a move
that was my follow-up actually
okay one you take Queen E3 King F1 is
the question is isn't there a knight to
but that's it yeah we're good we're good
well we're golden here right that is
but it is also Rook a
you can start with okay yeah yeah get
the you like that and get the extra
check yes
uh the extra chat
the extra check
um in fact you you're kind of forcing
you're kind of positive because
otherwise Queen F4 precisely right very
nice yeah
and now it's two Miners and a rook but
your team is very weak
yeah the white king the white king I
might have enough no it's very stable
are they you know because you can but
Rook A1 was uh maybe an overreach it was
just like one of those things that you
know if I can get away with it you know
like I I'm really really eager but here
what else I I'd have to drop back with
the night but Pawn on C6 is hanging
I don't like that at all
Rook A1
the times in this and this one uh 35
minutes for Hikaru 11 minutes for Sam
Seville
wow
and in the current position
is there an alternative to Queen G5 I I
didn't say let's take a look yeah a
queen of G5 is by far the best move
Queen to H4 is another alternative but
after Knight takes C6 white is just a
pawn up exactly so Queen to G5 you have
to create
This Thread This Thread and then rookie
and then what is the scenario after Rook
E1 yeah absolutely Rook A1 we calculated
that we calculated it correctly it's
just uh Rook A1 Rook takes A1
and if they say wonk we need three
that's the main line King to F1
Knight to D2
and we're entering exactly that specific
end game Rook a king H7 Bishop takes a
five G6 and now Bishop to D3
yeah
and
and you guessed it um
I mean there's no way to escape the
checks exactly no no
if you've dropped the bishop in the way
that cost you your knight with such an
open King there is no way you're going
to escape and this is the only way that
Hikaru can save
well it's also the only way in which Sam
is not going to be worse after Queen to
G5
that is to say he has to play variation
for both players right if Carl finds it
and I'm sure he sees this type of
patterns he dreams this type of patterns
in his spare time
um well if he finds it it's most likely
going to end in a perpetual
by the way I have to reflect upon that
whole puzzle Rush thing the idea of
doing eight hours of puzzle rush I mean
my brain hurts after like two hours I
mean that's just unbelievable that you
can do that and push yourself to that
kind of a limit yeah it's incredible
actually because I won't tell you the
source of who told me that right they
rated eight hours but uh the sauce is
also very strong Grand Master and he
said because I asked him about his own
routine and he said he started the day
off with tactics okay but uh ones that
you can find online you know you just
keep going and then
in the evening he focused on openings
and in games
not so much middle game right so tactics
to wake yourself up and then that was a
standard and and roughly four hours per
day
impressive impressive uh we do have
Queen G5 on the board or
I yes it's not there yet no it's not
there yet I'm sorry he's still trying to
figure everything out calculate
everything wow the last moment check
this out in the game of Lanier and Lavon
uh Lavon you know is basically said hey
look I've got a fortress
even without the pawn exactly now that I
have a question for you guys a
psychological question please you are in
this instance you're on the white side
right and Levon starts stretching starts
getting you the side eye like why are
you still playing we both know that this
is a draw this is a fortress how does
that impact you psychologically are you
like okay let's hurry up and make a draw
or are you like no no I'm gonna show you
that I'm actually better I'm like I'm
going to show you but actually I still
find it quite comical if my opponent was
collecting and I'm like why are you
flexing you're opponed out I got all the
trash
listen
it shows you that he knows something
that you probably don't right right does
that impact you at all well because I
would be perhaps a little bit impacted
but on the other hand this is like you
cannot lose this I feel tasered and
Hazard by the fact that my opponent is
just so you know blase well I'm sitting
there saying you know I've worked very
very hard for this part exactly finally
I have a portal and now this might be
running around the playing hole with a
big smile and I'm pulling up you know
look at me yes
it's gonna grovel for 50 moves at least
but I tell you this is really uh I
opening for me this this idea of like
sitting on with the King on EA just
ignoring everything that's happening
around your queen side dropping the pawn
on C7 and saying your king really is not
going to penetrate to D6 and it's not
penetrating the B6 and you can go all
the way around the horn here but I'm
keeping my king on E8 this is I don't
know I feel it's very risky because you
know yes the king doesn't get anywhere
if it dots off to the right but you know
if it starts moving and it can create
some Mischief Mischief on the left side
queen size all right
here right uh King to D6 King to C7 but
I'm just thinking you know first of all
to put the bishop on D6 and then start
moving stop moving the king round and
try to get the king to perhaps um
I don't know g b before and then try to
I'm going to meet you okay so let's make
some moves here so I'll say here here
and you can get all the Tempe yeah uh
that you want very happy right exactly
I'm just I I mean it's like I'm
channeling my inner Lavon and I want to
meet your king before with Bishop to B6
so basically I'm saying okay now you're
stuck now you're stuck now if you wait I
will wait with my king going back and
forth between d8 and E8 I'll just
Shuffle so at certain moment you're
gonna have to play A4 A5 or Bishop C5
the bishop C5 unfortunately fails to A5
oops
and then suddenly I'm stretching
and I left red face right right but I
was actually thinking oh is there any
moment where a white could sacrifice the
bishop in order to get the king round
and difficult to see it definitely yeah
unfortunately it is right it's it's a
remarkable conception and I have a very
strong thinking uh feeling that this is
something that Lavon had actually looked
at so deeply absolutely
he's amazing he just responded with him
look at him he's just giving him yes I
saw the I'm just hanging around here
come on let's just finish the game look
at him like I have some shopping to do
and yes after I've done my shopping I'll
uh make myself some tea
and then I'll prepare for the playoffs
it does look like he's thinking right
come on every every school child he's
not even looking at the board right
and here we go uh Gary Kasparov had this
habit of when he thought the game was
over he just put his he put his watch
off at the start of the game and then he
put his watch on when he said okay
that's it let's yeah let's go
yeah
uh Lavon has his own
ways let's jump to the ladies and just
uh pick up uh because all four games are
going on here and we do have Bishop
Arena again needs a draw and she's
through to the next uh round Bishop
Mission D6 E7
okay
I mean I don't see this attack going
anywhere for tatv on the king side and
this Pawn on B4 is actually a real
irritant in the position
means that when I bring a rook to d8 and
one day Bishop F6 uh will be awkward I
think uh irina's well on her way to
qualifying this is this is the fun game
but gotcha very little time we
about I have to say guys this is the
most dangerous position for tokyojanova
that she had in this match despite the
fact that the engine is giving her as
the clear favorite right now it's minus
1.5 but minus one point minus 1.5 but if
you look at the position what is your
first instinct
what's the first instinct what do you
play Queen to D7 to defend upon on D5 uh
take on e4 for me it was take on e4
Queen to D7 is by far the best move okay
why why take only four because after
Queen to D7 I really don't like at least
visually the idea of allowing E5 right
E5 now you go Knight G4 you can hit that
Knight again with H3 it feels like
finally white is gaining some speed so
momentum it bounces around yes exactly I
don't like that okay it's the best by
far objectively but without hey if you
take now you're in a worse position yeah
because now now if you do something like
this I start to anticipate most like D5
oh yeah this is getting dangerous like
seriously dangerous like you you like or
no it's a very difficult position from a
practical perspective without the engine
with the engine of course black is
better maybe winning objectively
bought from a human's point of view this
is a very dangerous situation with all
this power coming towards your king
queen on F3 The Rook on F1 the knights
ready to get energized coming into the
center and that Bishop on B2 once that
opens up it's game over yeah it's buried
for the moment but uh speaking of a
position that I found enormously
dangerous was Anna satonski's position
we were looking at both Knight C4 as
well as D5 and the problem was for us is
that both moves are so compelling and so
good we didn't know which one to choose
Knight C4 and capturing the pawns not a
bad decision either I mean after all the
queen on H5 is ready to pounce with any
captures you capture with the queen and
D6 as well so and by the way guys she
took on e4
oh
she took on e4 and now now she's worse
oh oh boy but it felt like it right it
felt like she's probably going to take
on e4 this is the this is what I was
saying about the clock you know when you
only have three minutes on your clock
and you're defending that three minutes
is just gone when you have three minutes
on your clock and you're attacking you
feel like you've got a luxury yeah like
oh three minutes bang night takes let's
go d4d5 let's go I mean you're smiling
as you're making all of these breaks and
suddenly your brain is working and
you're seeing everything you know when
you're defending it's like you're in mud
everything's a problem and also you have
to bear in mind that the match situation
exactly catcher is in a must-win
situation it makes so much easier
exactly she doesn't have to play
risk-averse chess you can just go
forward exactly enjoy everything who
cares it's a critical stage now and
there are some crazy lines right now you
take on e4 are they gonna seven then I
open up with D5 and try to check Mateo
on G7 there's chaos right position right
now
and this is exactly what kashka wants to
see in a must-win situation yeah no this
is a dream uh again like you say you
know throw caution to the wind uh it's
all or nothing and it's so easy to play
you don't even have to worry uh where on
conversely if we had drawn the first
game now like like do I do I recapture
on e-board or do I capture on F7 you
start shaking yeah yeah you start making
this no when when you're down one you
take on F7 and let's go uh exciting game
going on there Anna's just uh upon down
and in trouble I just see you know as
night is about to land on D6 and this is
a a huge uh passer in the positions and
on top of that she only has five minutes
left on her clock
it gets worse and worse she's she's down
on the clock as well so uh big things
happening if she does survive this this
would be a miracle against Alice because
how did the queen get to G3 what are
some G3 um there is a threat of a bishop
takes oh she
allowed well hang on a second yeah
Bishop takes H3 is a huge threat well
right yeah yeah sorry I'm like we're
right at the final position yeah I was
thinking uh Bishop takes and but
Bishop G3 Knight takes Pawn takes Queen
takes uh I'm sure
etusha was planning this hoping that any
recapture would allow Bishop takes D5 in
a coordinated attack against F7 did you
think Bishop H3 was important here well
no not now after because after Pawn
takes porn yeah you know White's King
solid it's it's it's it's fine
and it's not going to be as solid right
critical moment Knight takes C4 has been
played will she take on F7 uh between uh
begum and uh yeah this is the big moment
right now right is she going to take the
bull by the horns let's take on F7 uh
historians will call me Brave
let's do it okay
I'm the one having fun too
I'm spending too much time here inside
right yeah
G7 mate
do I need to actually
play a D4 D5 immediately I mean because
you can go Knight takes Knight first
right yes yes and then after Rook takes
now we come in well now we should be
fine either way but I I like the having
the piece the knights on the board why
because exactly in this position where I
played the move D5 I was thinking that I
could go for a line that looks like this
and this is she what she's calculating
right now right
uh I'm not so what if I go
Queen D7 correct
I'm not sure if I've talked it's such a
difficult line to calculate right I'll
take you take now I take on F7 you take
on F7 that's annoying
okay just a second did I do something
terribly wrong
maybe one minute left on the clock she's
entering her final minute
well come on catcher Queen F7 let's go
let's not forget there is no second time
control she will be playing on increment
for the rest of the game yeah
and she does get 30 second increment per
move and goodness 45 seconds yeah she
has to do or die right it's time to roll
the dice well the problem is if she does
Recapture on e4 that gives black just
that
half ply that she needs
and you know protect the D5 Square
so down to 23 seconds you have to make a
move
down to her last 15 seconds guys wow
10 seconds left you know I don't think
she's gonna take oh she she talks
herself out of it and there was a grin
by begging she was like yeah
wow
so Knight takes E4 and we're expecting
Queen D7 and I think that's the end of
the attack frankly can you generate
something with is she thinking of D5
yeah maybe D5 also there you can throw a
knight in that direction
of the king you know G5 F6 here here I
have to quote bent Larson with the
Knight on f8 I never get mated yeah uh
and after Queen D7 let's go with D5
because Katy you got to do it I mean you
gotta throw caution to the wind now the
whole idea behind D5 is that I've got
this type of uh made on the long day but
I will take with uh the queen on D5 oh
she's gone Knight D6 Knight to D6 okay
you'll take with the queen on D5 really
why not
I cannot take only four don't even think
about taking on e4 so G7 have to drop
back to E6 and now now I feel like I've
got something something but at least I'm
exchanging the Queens right Queen to E3
how is that end game I don't know it
looks very dangerous it is
what I'm thinking
annoying yeah rookie rookie seven at the
end of it oh no there's Knight G's to
say Knight G6 yeah yeah oh my goodness
she's played Knight D6 yeah
apologies uh and again
um begum has plenty of time right 25
minutes oh oh that is that's a huge
difference Knight D6 well I mean I want
to take it but you have to take it I I
have to take it yeah you cannot allow
that night too so takes takes
and C6 is a hanging F7 is hanging no F7
is not hanging
the desirable Queen takes D6 does hang
F7 so Rook C8 yeah just keep it keep it
simple keep it simple
simple is a simple does and there we see
they can play that move
and how do you continue the attack as
white I don't have an attack anymore I
think I'm now I start thinking in terms
of uh end games and I'm thinking that
well I've got to maintain the pawn on D6
I'm going to play Bishop a three I'm
gonna go Queen F5
I'm gonna try to exploit yeah I just
want the queen say I just wanted to say
that by the way
um Hikaru Nakamura actually followed the
line that we recommended so the whole
shebang and it looks like that will
shortly end in a draw yeah yeah yeah
Hikaru he calculated everything by the
way that's one of the
incredibly gifted skills that he Cairo
has is I find his calculation uh Vichy
Anand I thought was like one of the
world's greatest calculators I've ever
come across and uh yeah Hikaru Vichy
Gary were are just extraordinary they're
just really off the chart extraordinary
and how many times I've seen uh Hikaru
calculate
a difficult long lines with Precision
it's impressive Bishop A3 on the board
uh how does the computer assess the
begum
kacha position that one is balanced
right yes yeah Dynamics
yeah Dynamic equality three results but
you know it's all about the time right
now right Knight E6 by the way
and here well Queen F5
Queen F5 makes a lot of sense just
pinning the Knight tickling this pawn
and probably I have to defend that Queen
with one of the roost d8
okay we'll keep an eye on this but I saw
you had the game between Lanier and
Levon behind you uh anything to say
about no it's just a side eye it's it's
lavon's highlight right now he's just
waiting for the scoresheets to be signed
there's nothing happening okay you
simply cannot penetrate into my position
and yeah this one is going to finish and
draw okay jumping to the game between
anaji and Anna uh well white has just
simply a dominant position
incredibly powerful night on D6 and
extra Pawn she played the move a2a3
which for me I find a little bit
surprising because I think a lot of
players would be anxious just to connect
the Rooks put the king into safety I
mean you you you maybe you calculate a
little bit the move F4 F5 because the G
file is open but I think you tidy things
up on the king side first a283 is what's
happening over there nothing A3 B4 Queen
E2 takes okay Naji is eyeballing the
second Pawn Rook A7 Anna likes her pawns
but uh
no this is just just
too strong yeah 54 too good everything
is uh she has complete control of the
position dominant and talking about
control of the position I mean take a
look at the Tusa against Ali Alice Lee
because that it feels like things have
gotten wild or uncontrollable at least
interesting a t-shirt took on C6 you
could have taken on D5 we were we're
briefly taking a gander at you know
takes on D5 and then taking on C6 and
getting the pawns rolling
ooh Rook B1 uh that's a powerful
reminder that it's not just about the
bishop capturing on H3 but there's a
rook B1 sighting
huh
sorry please yeah no I mean rugby one
does look
so good it's something that you're
Uninvited to the party yeah I mean
obviously white will have to start
backpedaling as furiously I was thinking
Bishop out to G4 Bishop to G4 yeah
so with the idea of if I do go Rook to
B1 yeah then
Queen I think I'm going to lose
something I don't know something might
something fall off yeah the problem is
Queen D2 is going to walk into Bishop to
D3 right yeah I don't have I was kind of
banking on the fact that
the queen could come and neutralize yeah
but I was miscounting yes um okay so no
not Bishop G4 that does not help at all
it's a difficult position for white
isn't it
the queen D2 but that's to think you
still play with rugby
Maybe
Rook B3 don't I have some Bishop takes
H3 maybe Rook takes F3 ideas yeah
pouring fuel onto the fire okay but now
you have Queen F2 that's always my
Golden Rule when you're your king is a
little bit shaky and I use little bit in
the British understatement type of way
your house is burning
go for the ending the Golden Rule swap
the Queens whenever your house is on
fire yeah I think you had a very good
idea what do you want to be one yeah
yeah well that was the one that scared
me as well the problem is that if we do
trade off uh there is a a an issue here
and I don't no no because Bishop comes
out to D3 oh anyway oh
yeah so that suddenly is not uh
not good
has to well find defense with only five
minutes left on her clock it is there
well that's a big
yeah that thank you
I mean like I'm looking at it now I I I
might have to give up my queen something
like Rook C5 Rook B1 Rook takes Rook
takes Rook takes
and yeah but you're in a must-win
situation I got two connected past bonds
I can think of a Perpetual right right I
I'm sure black could find it Perpetual
I'm just saying that I feel like uh uh
I'm on the back foot yeah that's my
problem that's why and it might be just
your only way out right
right with Rook to B1 coming it's it's
it's scary Rook B1 rookie one uh the
first the back rank is weak
I mean could you do hang on hang on I've
got to move Queen to A1
there you go you're not okay oh yeah you
still can go but you can still go rookie
one
what about your Golden Rule of trading
Queen how did Queen A1 yeah we'll help
the queen trade
I'm gonna go look at it yeah how to play
chess according to you yeah the golden
rules Queen A1 where did that move I
just thought
position there's simply no good moves
yeah and it seems to be the case in this
situation Rook to B1 is coming whether
you like it or not right there's no one
wrong idea I have one Bishop out to D5
okay there you go we were kind of
waiting for this and then after Rook B1
Bishops oh Bishop yeah yeah Bishop Diggs
F7 check oh yeah good we're on the same
track just wanted to make sure we were
on the same track so Bishop D5 that's
well that you could also do queen takes
Rook as well just
to force it so okay so we go
B2 and now but now Queens come off Queen
F3 no let's let's be aggressive we have
to be aggressive what Rook B2 is not
aggressive
okay
so uh we're on track yeah we're
at Queen F3 so we do have a check we do
have Rook B1 still how what were we
doing after Rook B one week
let's go with the King and then we have
um okay at the very I guess you have
Bishop takes work or queen takes Queen
takes work
Queen either one yeah yeah although
Queen takes work and I know you're good
to go Bishop takes work now and big
threat on the board of Rook coming up to
f8 once it's a big threat no it's not
actually I mean uh how big a threat is
Rook Cafe so you have Rook F2 uh C6 is
Right Rook F2 C you take on systems I
take back and we play that position it's
sort of like the the the the line I was
trying to yeah as a queen give up the
queen for a rook and a bishop
combination must be able to find the
Perpetual I'm sure I'm sure again Queen
E3 and it just feels like there's going
to be a prepared but 25 is the good move
I mean you have to play right right
you're in a must win situation you
cannot go for this Rook C5 you have to
complicate Maps exactly take chances if
you lose you lose it is what it is right
right but at least you gave your best
shot what if I try this King to a chain
move
is that
something that
I think nimsovich basically destroyed
generations of players with these
prophylactics
I mean the Golden Rule yes follow the
code yeah
follow the Golden Rule when your house
is burning trade Queens
I really hate this
hate this the Golden Rule I really don't
like this golden room
what are your thoughts on insurance and
you know fire Insurance all right you
know what queen F3 is a real threat I
believe you know yeah okay
quickly by the way things are moving
fast
you've got to be aggressive I went Rook
me too this is not aggressive enough and
he just proposes King h8
what the heck man Alice Alice said give
me your queen I want your queen
right does she what why is it well hang
on there is okay options options let's
run through them
but that looks really well King takes F7
the problem is not Rook takes F5
although Rook takes F5 is a really good
move I was fearful full of Queen takes
and you you're Bishop's in a pit yeah so
she's picking up yeah
H7 I'm saying she's going to go to age
eight well no the way she was it was
like it was a
it was a push of the king towards the
upwards yeah
see you gotta you gotta understand this
uh it's tactile it's talking feel no
okay so King H7 we missed something I
think what did we miss we missed that
after you take on B1 yeah they can be
one take only eight yes we have Queen to
E3 and after I take only eight that
attacks the rook and you don't have time
to take my Bishop
um
good point great Point Holy Spirit this
is what she calculated and perhaps this
is what has missed that's the problem
you don't get to take the bishop
this has got to be no this is no it's
not I I'm not in time to double my Rooks
because you've got Bishop G6 but even if
you go Bishop
Bishop
horses it's gonna cause some trouble
it's true it's true it's not that you
have to resign it's that materially
speaking Alice is going to be doing very
very well
King H7
and this is the current situation you
should have played I don't think she can
mix the moves in any way can't you
doesn't feel like it no
no
does feel like she's got to play Queen
takes B1 and Bishop takes E8 uh I think
Alice is doing very well let's just jump
to the game of kacha versus begum for
just a moment to see how things have
developed when we left it yes indeed
Queen F5 and Katya is basically really
low on her clock so she is playing as
quickly as possible
and what's your take on this position
this is
the pawn on D6 yeah but it's not going
anywhere now now I can
round it up excuse me that was uh that
was wrong and then the night was
supposed to go to E4 and then to D6 I
mean I want to take that pawn on D6 I
feel that pawn on D6 is the most
threatening if I can get rid of it my
only problem with Knight D4 I feel is
something like D5
oh okay
and I take on C5
yeah aren't I making a
I was about to say
yes
Knight takes Knight takes Queen takes
I feel like I've got like B4 you might
be close but do you want to risk it
I feel comfy here as black I don't be a
rookie five yeah I don't think I'm I'm
risking too much after rookie five and
I'll start what you know once you trade
on D6 I'll start walking with the King
interesting sorry I just wanted to go to
Arena our defending champion and how is
she doing we thought she was doing very
well
just about back here
and
yes she is doing very well
this is almost like a I mean they talk
about these Sicilian endings you know
kind of a dream ending for Black where
you know the Rooks are on C8 with this
awkward pressure whereas the white Rook
on the f file doesn't have the same
awkward and I do want to go through
hikaru's game please just for a second
because I think we might see a handshake
in that one and that would be our first
qualifier it does seem like Hikaru has
found the Perpetual they are repeating
right now and there is the draw
well for somebody who hasn't played
classical chess in nine months you sure
he is really strong he's pretty good
and he doesn't actually and he even says
that playing chess is not his full-time
job he considers himself first and
foremost a streamer exactly so not bad
start for our amateur yeah
yes tomorrow is this match for Hikaru
was effortless yeah
that's strong but he sure was impressive
yeah yeah I mean Sam well it didn't make
it easy but yeah it was an impressive uh
achievement and Lanier and Lavon are
going to sign score shapes which means
that we will have three playoff matches
in the uh open and let's go to the
ladies because again we had three
Victory three Victors coming into
today's uh game uh with the ladies and
tataf is one of those who needed a win
oh yes I think there's a Checkmate
coming in Tokyo Nova I'm thinking that
too because the Knight is going to plonk
itself on F3 there's a queen on H3 yeah
but I was thinking once The Rook comes
to F2 or Bishop comes to F2 the Knight
comes to F3 and it's Checkmate on H2 oh
that's a nice check mate King H1 Queen
takes H2 and it's the checkmate with the
Rook that's coming yeah
and it does seem like only 20 seconds
left
or kachka at this point
okay turn it away from the clock she
doesn't want it
excitement there she knows she's got two
and I'm guessing not F3 check puts it in
the bag yes indeed Knight F3 check King
H1 and queen takes H2 and we have an
Arabian mate on the board Arabian mate
okay
I did a check mating Course and there
you go we see a handshake
begum is uh going on to the championship
stage
congratulations to her and you our
Oracle
over here said that uh begum yeah she
was the one who was going to lose
[Laughter]
situation
you were happy to be mistaken are you
gonna sting him so when no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no not at all
there's a commentator's Creed you know
we stick together on these moments we
have our little power backs right yeah I
will be your roof on this one you were
confident throughout the whole way wow
impressive uh 2-0 that's sending a
statement I have to say but kashka's
time management was her downfall in this
game because she had her chances we've
seen that move E4 take on e4 but the
position was opening up if she would
have had enough time at that point to
calculate everything I think she would
have played the queen F7 and gotten a
better position instead of that after
Knight takes C4 that's just too slow and
begging took advantage of her hesitation
indeed
I think that really says it very very
well indeed uh tatv versus Arena I like
Arena's position I think she stands
better at this moment uh Naji well when
we left it it was completely one-sided I
think she got distracted by the way with
this whole A3 business right here I
thought you just go King G2 King H1 you
connect the Rooks so that everything is
comfy A3 and now it's a little bit
Gravelly or is it still completely
winning
what's your take it feels like it's
winning to me
I'm just if I was if I were white I'd
probably just I've won one yeah I would
want to be seven to to trade the knights
so that I could
uncover the pawn I guess I have to play
this I mean that's the queen takes and
then and then can you pin yeah I mean
I'm groveling it's it it's really really
bad but uh yeah what else can I do I'm
not a happy camper at this moment and
since we have the first qualifiers could
we take a look at the brackets right now
to see sure who they might be facing in
the next round yeah Hikaru as the top
seed he would be going up against the
third and four right yeah so he he will
be
yeah we're we're putting this so I think
you will be facing the winner of
Dominguez aronian so you will be
definitely watching
[Laughter]
closely an interested spectator
yeah okay I want I want I want something
stronger than Knight B7 though it just
feels like uh it's not enough I want
something more you want something more
than maybe seven let's find something
more
well there is a problem because it's not
like Rook C1 was played everything is
really super coordinated I think this is
the move you like this move it's about
that Bishop where do you put that Bishop
and check out Anna's clock she's under
the minute yes
under the minute another player that's
struggling a lot with her time
management always has always enough
she's been very very successful uh
um multiple US champion Anna zatonski
and yet I have seen her throughout her
career even at her really best moments
she has this time trouble
mismanagement and it has cost her
and well 20 seconds it's just and she
drives them with a bishop three that
looks loose that looks very loose it
sure does Rook B8 looks really
compelling doesn't it there is sort of
takes the eight Knight F7 sighting yeah
but there is Rook C6 uh possibility
uh at first I I was really excited by
this so let's see but C6 I do go Knight
F7 check which night uh from D6 from D6
and I guess I have to play you have to
go there and now
maybe I can go Queen A8
that's a funny move it is a funny movie
it is but it's it's it's like it hits
everything it's almost like a pinball
kind of Move That Just Hits everything
uh bumper on d8 on on C6 that's winning
that's simply winning yeah it is just I
up to B8 if that comes on the board it
does feel like it's a visual
and how much time did marshy 10 minutes
10 minutes 10 minutes plenty of
that's a lot of work
and when I mean is that are there any
moves it does kind of feel like almost
anything well we'll get you through it's
interesting line uh here I just yeah you
want to play Rook
no I mean Rook B8 is so compelling you
really want to play Rook B7 I think
that's kind of like your dream move and
then you know you kind of get stuck when
you see this move Knight takes uh Knight
F7 check well that doesn't really make
that much sense this must be arguably
the best feeling in chess
you're in a mini match with a win you
finish the match you're in what looks
like a better position visually right
and you also have 10 more minutes than
your opponent and your opponent doesn't
have the second time control she plays
on it this must be so comforting right
now for Nazi right
I had precisely this kind of situation
in the U.S Championship I was up against
Alexander shabalov and just as you
described it my position was
overwhelming and winning and and I
spoiled it and Larry Christensen accused
me of preparing my victory speech
yesterday
so hatefully he was right
I was already thinking I'd like to thank
my opponents who played so very well
[Laughter]
but here let's take a look at the open
section bracket so far yeah and we can
see that as one person continuing onto
the Champions bracket and that is Hikaru
Nakamura who defeated Sam Sabian in the
head-to-head encounter well we have some
playoffs though coming up first one is
between Ray Robson and Fabiano caruana
and Weslo
in the elimination bracket for the open
section we have Sam sevillion that he's
already going to be joined by Pacha on
the ladies side but let's take a look at
the uh well I guess not
the ladies
we actually have a results so we do have
a drop
it was a complete Fortress and therefore
ends in a draw and it's a third match in
the open section that is headed off to
the playoffs playoffs and these players
don't have a lot of time to think it
through they will actually have to go
look at their opening preparation and
come back in less than an hour to play
the playoffs match we are expecting the
playoffs to begin at 5 30 but in case
all the games were suddenly to be
finished immediately uh there would be a
15-minute break between the the the the
last last the last classical game it's
the last classical game right it's not
the last classical game yeah of both
brackets before the playoffs will begin
and we have a guest with Christian in
studio we are indeed with Tokyo Nova
after a uh sort of convincing Victory
but uh it felt difficult towards the end
did you feel like that as well it was
tricky actually during
her idea with A5 C5 and seemed nice but
I thought she had to play F3 immediately
instead of like Bishop H3 after Bishop
H3 I was like I was happy I'm like sure
I'm not gonna lose this game but after
F3 I guess
like she was scared a little bit she
played F4 were you surprised by this
decision of hers I thought maybe I
shouldn't take it and just like you know
Bishop C8 H5 and I'm doing all right
like I'm Pawn up and it does seem like
this would have been indeed the right
decision but I had a feeling I gotta
play like I wanted to open my pieces a
little bit and have a kind of
interesting position to play I was like
okay here I need to just like slowly
play slowly but here so you wanted to
give her some chances is what you're
saying I just want my pieces to play as
well I was like I felt like I'm not here
to make a draw I'm here to like make
most of which I think are the best so I
thought this would be better and this
was the critical moment right here yeah
I actually played E4 I know I didn't
want to take it that was that was a
mistake my original idea was to play
like initially I wanted to play Queen E6
E5 97
maybe like Knight E2
and after like even Knight of four she
doesn't have anything right she's not
threatening anything
well all of our pieces are kind of
coming to like I started to panic for no
reason I was like oh my God maybe I
missed something but there's nothing
and she played this movie for and this
was once again the critical moment once
you exchanged she had this option of
going Queen takes F7 were you worried
about this I calculated it and it seemed
very interesting text T5 Bishop E5 and I
was thinking of Knight D4 Bishop b296
yes but I felt like after Queen D7 my
position is slightly better and the
pawns are actually not moving yeah so I
calculated it and I felt like I'm better
so and the only way it seems like she
would have had to take on E5 and then go
Knight to C4
Knight to C4 and Knight to P6 is very
difficult to spot this idea we didn't
see it either we were looking at Knight
takes C4 and Knight to D6 as well and we
felt like after Queen decision have to
take an A4 that's why you don't play
it's song I don't know why I did that
but also she only had one minute on her
cloth that's true that's why I was like
okay if I get something like at this
point for some reason you know uh I knew
that the draw is fine but I felt like oh
the position is so playable maybe I have
some chances and the king is weak if I
can like put my knight on G5 it felt
like it's very good for me and with one
minute uh I felt like it's almost
impossible to defend the position and
you finished with a very beautiful
Checkmate after night we have three
Queen two H2 well 2-0 that's uh a very
encouraging sign for you but you will be
we don't want to get ahead of ourselves
but in case Irina does not lose this
game you will be facing Irena yeah do
you see that matchup play out oh I love
playing her she's a like she's an
interesting player to play with
uh she creates lots of like ideas and
was very tricky so in general I'm happy
that I'm playing her and you've been a
teammate of hers as well during the
Olympiad did you get to learn any any
tricks about her or anything of that
nature no I think we know each other
quite well as well so uh we know
whatever we should know and we'll see
how it goes guys any questions no our
congratulations indeed uh very nice 2-0
that's sending a message to the
competition uh I am very well played
very well played absolutely uh one
player who didn't play it very well is
Alice Lee and things have gotten very
very confused when we left it we left it
about these parts Bishop takes Rook
takes not recapturing
um not capturing on E8 because we saw
that move Queen E3 then after Rook f8
which kind of I don't know does did that
did that sit settle right with you Rook
f8 yeah I guess you had to move the rook
and you can't move it off the bottom row
because of Bishop G6 right but I mean
you got Rook B8 you've got Queen E3
checks they're they're all Alternatives
something about this move just didn't
seem right because now you're
awkwardly facing a move like Bishop G6
uh yeah that that could really upset you
right but what stopped her from playing
Queen E3
you're taking the part yeah
I see a pawnai takes upon and after all
training is working
uh you know it was the funniest thing I
thought it was Bishop Jesus Bishop G6
and rookie six we take on a feather
rookie six or do you have some checks
well I was kind of banking on some
checks yeah making a prepet maybe even
Queen d8 yeah yeah you shouldn't be too
worried about it and
yeah and uh we have a guest in studio
we do have indeed Hikaru Hikaru first of
all the first word that comes to mind
when I see your match is effortless it
felt like that for us how did it feel
for you yeah I wouldn't say it was
effortless I think I played a pretty
pretty terrible game today
um you know I I basically want to
surprise Sam the opening by playing some
nonsense with his age six move um I mean
I think the opening is isn't that bad
for black but just the way that I
followed up was definitely not uh all
that great and I think somewhere in the
middle game was significantly worse
there was a tweet at this particular
moment uh Anish was asking which speed
run this is with H6 and A6 well I mean
but didn't um didn't Anish a second
Irwin let me play H6 with black or
perhaps yes I think he did but anyway
um no I mean A6 and B6 I think it's
relatively okay I don't think it's that
bad I mean maybe maybe I'm supposed to
take on C4 I don't know but I wasn't
really in the mood to do it so um yeah
that's life eight six what what did
Magnus play I just saw the Magnus game
pop up because of course I mean I don't
study chess so I don't know these things
yeah what did Magnus play here uh let's
see Madness played baseball he played B6
okay
ah because you can take with the queen
right away okay fairness yeah that makes
that makes more sense and see if we can
get back to your game yeah so that was
kind of kind of what I saw there
um but but anyway no I mean this is uh
yeah this is all maybe slightly better
for it probably I should have played C5
but just keep going like basically
somewhere around Queen B3 I played this
A5 move and already I'm starting to
drift a little bit and I think if Sam
had found this concept with Knight D2
and then some Bishop F3 maybe right here
maybe even later but at some moment in
the next like five moves if you found
this idea of going Knight to Bishop
three I'm playing for E4 this would have
been very uh very scary for me but he
didn't do that I mean I just felt like
it was a little bit too tentative he
wasn't 100 sure what to do and they
played Rook A1 basically you know sing
the boogeyman for no reason because if
he doesn't go Rook A1 I mean again if he
plays Knight D2
rookie a bishop F3 I mean nobody cares
nobody cares about the queen side here
yeah oh the computer also all the
computer also doesn't care at all things
black is only a little bit worse which I
notice me is very surprising because it
just feels like E4 is coming in
somewhere here yep and it should be
scary like rookie one E4 some
combination but basically the point is
white has more space and so when Sam
trades the Rooks off this already helps
me so like just conceptually you
shouldn't be trading the Rooks so it's
already I think it's a mistake that's
not to say white isn't still better but
I think it becomes much much harder to
come up with a straightforward plan I
mean for a computer it can just
dilly-dally play random moves all over
and improve slowly but I mean for us at
least you you have to have a concrete
idea and once we trade trade the works
on A7 I don't think there was a concrete
idea and then Sam played 91 which I
think was just a bad move
um he just misunderstood the position
next move oh Knight three one
immediately yeah he just misunderstood
because see Sam thought I had to play B5
and then he was going to go Knight D3
and go to E5 or C5 which of course makes
perfect sense but I don't have to play
B5 and then once I go Knight E4 again
less space so obviously I want to trade
pieces and if he doesn't trade the
knights I mean I think already maybe
black can even try to claim an advantage
somewhere so I thought what he did was
correct
um again I thought everything here was
very Bishop five I thought shows that
I'm kind of like in form because it's a
scary move to play if I'm wrong
um if I'm wrong I'm gonna just lose this
game but I can tell from the evalot
clearly I wasn't wrong so it worked out
and the rest of the game is just very
forcing and you spent a little bit of
time at this point calculating
everything after Queen to G5 did you
calculate all the way until the end yeah
I mean basically went when uh Sam was
thinking or no when I was thinking about
Bishop 5 I already saw this whole
position with Rook A1 and everything
else
um I mean I just assumed it was good
enough I didn't actually calculate all
the way to the end but I assumed with
the queen there had to be some way to to
save it and so that's sort of what I was
just calculating a second time and it
just I think everything was completely
forced I mean I think we basically
played this more or less perfectly
although I'm surprised to see it thinks
Queen F4 apparently
is good enough to draw too interesting
yeah interesting queen f41 queen to C1
yes I thought what I did was just much
more principled with Queen C1 and then
check and then yeah C5 to break the
break the structure and yeah there just
was nothing for either Queen C1 I also
saw but in Queen G2 with this uh this
symmetry moving the queen all over the
board on on the back ring the fifth
fifth row whatever you call that term I
found a way Hikaru you haven't played in
a very long time you were mentioning
that uh yesterday but now do you feel
like there's any rust left or do you
feel in shape I mean I I think uh I mean
I wouldn't say there's Russ I'm
obviously playing chess almost every day
but
um certainly I've survived the openings
and I figure if I survived the openings
then I have good chances against anybody
so we'll see if I can keep doing that
guys any questions our congratulations
uh well done and good luck and your next
round
thank you uh just turning to the game of
Naji and Anna Anna we know has been
playing on increments but uh now there's
a a nice back rank Checkmate combination
in the position as you can capture The
Rook Queen takes and capture the bishop
thanks to the Rook d8 that's going to
win the game and uh with this Victory no
playoffs
yeah she goes uh ahead in the Champions
bracket and Anna will fall into the
elimination bracket yeah and that's
that's a huge victory for
because she's
she doesn't play that much sort of a
little bit like hakaru yeah she did tell
me that she is a chess teacher yes by a
profession so she's there with the game
yeah if you're teaching you're still
having the thinking and you're thinking
about each other and uh you know just by
the way that she's playing against Anna
I feel like she's come incredibly well
prepared exactly and you can feel the
passion whenever she starts moving her
pieces and you can see on her face she
almost never gets from off off from the
board right up from the board she just
enjoys the process she enjoys the game
at least to my eyes
uh agreed wholeheartedly and for me that
very confident Rook G1 move sacrificing
the night in the middle of the board uh
demonstrated to me at least that hey you
know she's she's here to win and there
you have it you have it she is our
second Victor carrying on her journey in
the championship bracket exactly Anna
zatonski will now be playing for her
life or not playing for her life playing
for survival an elimination bracket
Arena Crush by the way significantly
better now
upon to the good uh better minor piece
as well wouldn't surprise me if she's
looking at a 2-0 score as well all she
needs Arena that is is a draw to advance
but she looks like she's winning it yeah
and only two games left and can we take
a look at atuses against Alice League
because that looks
and incredibly crazy when we when we
left it we kind of left it around these
parts you just played D5 a couple of
Rook checks and we're now wow that pawn
uh it starts to get really scary it's
it's just winning well the problem is
Queen to E5 threatens Queen takes F6 and
after a real G6 King H7
5 just threatens Queen takes F6
oh
okay but you know there's another Pawn
racing up the ball I know I was thinking
about C5 as well right
uh by the way 10 seconds well wrote to
G6 King to H7 that's yeah
by the way a very practical uh by Alice
Lee they're not waiting but playing
quickly King H7 and not saying to your
opponent you know you're gonna get these
30 second increments and enjoy them uh
play very quickly and the problem is if
you do go Rook to F6 at least you can
stop the clock and claim a three-fold
repetition
E6 attack okay
E6 as a possibility it might not be
enough right that feels
terrifying yeah because you know but by
the way do I have a choice because you
are
with the move Rook E6 the multiplicity
of threats D7 Bishop F said shall we
take a look okay
Rick takes King goes to H2 and we've got
to get behind this guy and now with this
okay she's done it she's done it so fast
and look at how let's go I mean she's
the one who's acting as though she has
no time she has plenty perhaps King to
G7 by the way did I make a mistake
Bishop D5 can I play it can I play a D7
well yeah that's what I wanted to do
yeah yeah this this one looks yeah oh my
God the help of the king let's go King
G7 first at what moment right now right
now King G7 trying to think yeah
and then the rookies
to go back to f8 right no no ah dude
yeah Bishop D5 King F6
you're gonna have to run with the bishop
right you mean after C5 and one thing I
wasn't sure about D7 is like kind of
feel like it's the seapoon that I want
to promote now I get the blockade on
yeah if you have the blockade on dark
squares not working but if
sorry sorry it's okay so if you bring in
the king what happens if I push the C
Pawn
so just a second we agree that Rook D1
is bad but if I go here you want to see
Park that goes here and
now I have to preserve the bishop yes
you do yes I do
do you want to go to see it there's some
trickies maybe no yeah
the game is over
it
yeah you have to uh support upon the sea
Pawn with Bishop D5
okay so pardon me King H2 King G7 Bishop
to D5 C5 King F6 and Bishop D5
so C5 first king F6 oh I apologize C5
first king F6 and Bishop D5 Bishop D5
what really yeah she's bringing in the
king
but now I can continue this
it just doesn't seem like you're in time
D7 look at fade you have seven but
I will continue with Rook to d8 and it's
just the problem is I still have the a
pawn so once I manage to block your
pawns my a pawn is running correct
well you can she's playing I think
that's her best practical chance but are
we talking about Alice winning here with
the move oh yeah yeah oh yeah why not
right I mean that a pawn is going to be
dangerous but there is a construction
that white can set up but probably it's
enough for a draw go go for it so you've
got C5 on the board and we're expecting
King F6 yeah what's the construction so
you can and she's done it you can put
your Bishop on on D5 yes okay and stinky
five King E5 and then D7 okay I have to
drop back yeah and then you can just go
see okay you have a move here so you can
probably bring in your king no no you
have to go see six is what I would say
okay then I have yeah and then and now
you run with the King but you can now A5
yeah what I wanted to run with the King
to G3 oh sorry of course you did yeah
because I played King H2 to G3 but
somehow the system okay yeah and then
pin goes up
King goes up again
no
King takes yeah okay and then I'm
probably
I think I'm just going to
tag your Bishop like all the all the way
there is some sort of a race though
right
but I understand the construction you
want you want your Bishop on D5
defending the a bar and then to rush
with the King okay one question though
yes when you do play the move King to G3
yeah there is H5 no I actually wanted to
do something else I wanted to put the
King on C7 first
and then whenever you go to H5 I'm going
to go root to F6 so now I start pushing
my Pawn
you go all the way to each one and now I
defend with Rook F6
the man's got a point it does have a
point he's going to play Rook D6 and
that a pawn is
I I think whenever black gets the
blockade that we've been discussing with
the King on C7 I think that any chances
of losing just go out the door and
probably you're actually close to
winning
and suddenly wow
that was a composer by a young Alice Lee
wow and look at her she's playing all of
these moves King
G7 F6 King E5 and perfect wow uh very
very impressive play Here by Alice looks
looks like she's worked it out and she's
doing it with four minutes on a clock
yeah she has a just under two and a half
minutes a hundred two and a half and uh
a Tusa has just under a minute now and a
just a mountain to climb if she wants to
to take this match to tie breaks and we
have a guest with Christian Studio we
are indeed with Nazi by Kiza after a
tremendous Victory Nazi congratulations
first of all this was a very tense match
but it felt like you were putting on the
pressure from the get-go even yesterday
with the black pieces it felt like you
had the diamond position did you feel
like that as well uh yes it I did feel
like that and Anna is a very tough
opponent for me I have never been in
hell this is my first time uh turns out
yesterday I missed a chance there was a
tactic that I missed in time trouble
uh so today I was really hoping to get a
position where I could fight for a win
and not get very dry cattle and drop
position so I was quite happy with the
line she chose when she took on F4 uh
all the way yes after that we get messy
Pawn structure and I was even
considering to cast along although I
think that did you know this variation
up to this point or I glanced that at
this point I prepped so much but I
didn't expect this exact line and I just
very quickly looked at it so I just had
an idea that it's pretty okay for white
and I can attack on the king side so I
was happy with that and she was spending
also a lot of time and it felt like this
was a trademark of this matchup Anna was
spending a lot of time you were playing
very quickly did you prepare
specifically for this type of situations
uh I mean I've known Anna for a long
time and she's always in time trouble
when we were teammates at the Olympia
she was sitting next to me and after I
moved 10 she would have 10 minutes and
it would make me nervous so I was
expecting that and today honestly I was
planning on that that if she gets in
time trouble and I have a chance to
attack I will definitely go for it and
it did feel like your attack just simply
was coming naturally in the position and
you played this move that really
impressed us Rook to G1 yes yes how did
you come to uh this conclusion oh I love
that movie I I didn't expect F6 and when
she played it um
I immediately started one and if she
takes on E5 I can take on E5 with either
pawns but I was gonna take with d Bishop
before checking F1 and I'm getting that
Bishop back with A3
A3 and B4 uh there's also Knight F6
thread and if she tries to Define it
let's say B5 to make space you have nice
benefits right yeah and uh yeah this
just felt natural I didn't really
calculate I was playing more
instinctively at this point
and of course she uh played this move C5
which allowed you to go Knight to C4 the
key moment was here actually before D
takes C5 I paused because I noticed I
had D5 and it looked very interesting
because I'm threatening D6 if she takes
Queen D5 I win
and
but then I saw she can play bishop d8
and it's ridiculously passive as that is
I couldn't find anything else after that
but
there's nothing immediate and uh it's
frustrating you wanted the material yeah
you want to take on C5 yes sir probably
recommends that as well
just to interrupt you for one second
Alice Lee did indeed finish this match
with two zip impressive score
Let's uh continue
Knight to C6 and you are feeling like
you're taking over at this point right
yes plus she didn't have any time so
that helped a lot
yeah I like that I brought the queen
over because Queen did his job on H5 and
I had to bring it back to the queen side
getting closer to these pieces on this
side putting some pressure on E6 very
nicely done my only problem in this game
was that at times I had too many good
options yeah and couldn't decide which
one to make
and Irina has won her game as well and
she finishes it with two zip
wow very competitive uh matchups all the
games were decisive
yeah no playoffs in the women's section
uh did you have any problems at any
point did you feel like you're sleeping
at any point or it just felt smooth no I
thought I was winning pretty much after
winning the pawn uh she did keep finding
the only moves uh with 30 seconds on the
clock but I still had the time Advantage
so
I didn't let her Escape
as a congratulations a huge victory for
you against Anna satinsky guys any
questions our congratulations if you're
gonna win a game
winning uh when it was a decisive moment
that's a good time
to finally get a victory our
congratulations and I know exactly what
you meant when you said as an Olympic
teammate you were sitting next to her
and you're getting nervous I was the
team captain
I'm nervous for the whole round you know
but our congratulations good luck uh in
the next round yes well done and uh this
was really impressive I mean uh
Alice just at this moment she played all
of these incredibly exact moves we were
looking at D7 yep rook f8 and atusha
thought okay this will throw her off uh
with the move Bishop back because now I
want to go D7 and uh go with the pawn
instantly I was watching the whole thing
during The Rook takes in King E6 and
that's it the eight Pawn uh
yeah it's very impressive and no
playoffs for the ladies definitely not
so Arena also defeated yes she did he's
very convincing me as well I mean it's
difficult to kind of pick a favorite I
think everyone who's won their match has
played it in a very dominating manner
right and I have to say it's been very
impressive stuff
well we were I was wrong I I predicted
that was one player who was facing in
the elimination with Ty but that didn't
happen in any of the four matches uh
from yesterday where we had a Victor
they all went through here everybody
went through every everyone did one did
a job
that they were meant to do and as we had
four draws uh we will have three
playoffs and we'll get back uh very
shortly with what to expect but I do
believe there's going to be a 15-minute
Gap and uh to get us on that other side
I think we have somebody in studio
well let's take a look at the results
first yes definitely
and one decisive result and that was
Hikaru Nakamura going through against
Sam Sevin and he will meet in the next
round the winner between Iranian and
Dominguez meanwhile Sam shankland and
Wesley so and Fabiana Carona and of Roy
Robson will be battling it out in the
playoffs that's exciting those are three
very very good players
and just one day yeah your elimination
and he is awaiting the loser between
Iranian and Dominguez and uh women's
elimination and Championship bracket I
mean we have four decided results and it
was Arena crushed that was triumphant
against tatev abrahamian and it was also
talking Genova who was triumphant
against
crashed out to pakiza whereas Ellis Lee
13 years old what a talent demonstrating
to us where she is the player in form
and she's getting close to 2400 I mean
this is yeah impressive stuff exactly
and these are the elimination yeah they
these players are fighting for survival
tatter faces off against kachika nemtaba
and Anna zatonski will meet atusa
percussion
and here goes our playoffs it says Ray
Robson against Fabiana caruana and these
guys finished very quickly
plenty of time to prepare to rest to eat
do whatever it takes to get them through
to the next stage and the second playoff
is between Sam shankland against Wesley
so as
overpad here is a fearsome opponent he
starts off with a white pieces against
Wesley and we also have lenia Dominguez
beginning with the white pieces against
Lavon aronian absolutely and they will
again the first set of playoffs will be
10 minutes per side with a five second
increment draws then they go to the
blitz three plus two and then they go to
the Armageddon yeah everything the very
exciting uh playoffs coming up and now
we have our guest in studio with
Christian Alice you won your game
yesterday and today you had to defend
you played the Petrov but the Petrov is
such a difficult opening to master and
you haven't played it before is that
correct
um I think I've had a few games before
but not as my main opening in the Petrov
um so this game I think I I actually
didn't really like the opening position
I got
um I like the Early Middle game position
um
but then later I feel like I played too
passively did you feel like she was
building up some pressure in the middle
game yeah I felt like she played like
really well but it was just hard for her
to play um I think she was probably
winning but she was in time pressure at
what point did you feel like she was
piling on the pressure I think after she
was like we traded off into like the
um
like the two Rooks and Bishop versus uh
all the way there okay okay yes um but
earlier I think
um like somewhere around here yeah
around here I felt like
um I was oh actually I'm supposed to
explain
I guess that makes sense I probably
draw uh maybe and then Queen to E4 this
is a difficult move to see yeah that's
like 30 minutes if you take take your a
pawn just runs yeah I definitely didn't
see that if
because
um I at least have a draw there with
Queen F4 exactly yeah and you play The
Rook to f8 wouldn't you feel like she
maybe has something
to disturb you I felt like
maybe around when she was able to like
get the Deep on a bit more forward yes I
feel like it was definitely hard I
wasn't sure I didn't see it an exact one
for her
um ever but of course I was like also in
time pressure so
um I think after she was able to like
get this works C6 movement I felt like
my position was kind of uncomfortable
because if I do kimchi 7 then there's
work C7 and I didn't really like that
um so after like Queen E3 uh 22 Rook to
F6 yeah King G7 and it doesn't seem like
she had anything else yeah I thought it
was this maybe she has like
um after we traded I actually wasn't
sure because I felt like I'm either like
completely winning or completely losing
and we were winning yeah with King G7
yeah I felt like maybe she could like uh
try to do like 57 C5 C6 or Bishop uh B7
C5 C6 but I didn't actually see any
place where it ever worked because I
have a skinny five move
um but yeah I was definitely like uh not
an easy game for me to play I think
um practically speaking it could have
gone wrong at like any moment if
um and I got a bit lucky like here I
have a skinny five move but yeah after
Bishop FC was happy with his like
working exception trading it's the
component game yeah Alice
congratulations a huge victory for you
tomorrow you still have a big match
against Nazi pakiza to prepare for we'll
let you go get some rest thank you our
congratulations to you Alice as we get
ready for our playoffs uh for the
opening rounds of matching they're going
to be starting in a few minutes we just
need to get our setup going here let's
see what we've got
definitely let's check out what lies
ahead for our players in the playoff
first of all they will play a two-game
rapid uh Porsche playoff and uh both
sides will have 10 minutes plus five
second increment if the match is tied
after these two games then time is
slashed they will play a two game three
minute plus two second increment and if
the match is still tied after all these
games and then we finally go to my
personal favorite the Armageddon game
where white begins with five minutes
whereas black will have four minutes but
gets draw odds and don't worry the
position well you do get an increment
but only after 61. so an arbiter's
favorite I know Alberta's don't like
armageddon's for this reason I I was
gonna say I mean it's great fun for us
oh the audience the commentators but I
tell you for the players they really
feel it I mean it's like this uh the the
tension
never
stops literally from the time the the
clock is pressed you you feel like
you're in some kind of a survival mode
yeah
and we have another Berlin end game in
Wesley's game
Wesley versus Samsung
because and yes there is also a Berlin
end game in Lebon versus Dominguez I was
about to say because the the play is so
fast will probably want to focus on a
marquee matchup and then we'll go from
there I suggest a moment Ray Robinson
versus Ray Robson versus Fabi the two
Berlin endings can boil
well that's a nice way to put it yeah
that's a really nice one I'll keep my
eye on the uh
um the non-berlin one which is the Ray
Robson against Fabiana Carona as if
anything heats up there yes I will let
you guys know uh by the way in the game
between Ray Robson and Fabiano
um I played left polygamsky is white
played a really wonderful game against
me
um
uh a while ago with the move Knight A4
and it really it's like one of those
moves that kind of just takes you by
surprise you look at the move and you go
well okay I take
it goes A3 I go back and he takes and
somehow he managed to get something on
the queen side with I was reluctant to
play D5 C5 and this move uh I can tell
you I would have loved to have competed
against the move Rook E1 here because
walking into that pin just doesn't feel
like that should be a good move it just
doesn't and Knight A4 is indeed the main
line but Rook 31 seems to be a very very
intriguing wrinkle that resources yes
and he played well it has been played
quite a few times but yes only six times
compared to Knight A4 which has been
played 600 times so wow that's a big
difference so
really Trail Blaze
wow okay yeah interesting uh when he
played against me it was a surprise but
okay uh rookie one
ID five yeah E4 so Fabi says absolutely
not I will stop you at the pass I will
play D5 and of course if I'm allowed to
capture and capture and capture I will
make a very easy quality as black so
right here right now what does what does
Rey have to do to to get it gain an
advantage Christian D5 makes a lot of
sense because you are taking advantage
of the newly created pin for the Knight
on C3 after D5 probably the best way to
continue for white would be to take on
D5 okay I would assume you're going to
take with a knife okay and now just the
simple Bishop to D2 I don't have to
complicate matters I cannot take on D5
because you have Bishop takes E1 so what
I have to do I have to go Bishop D2
simplify the position keep it as it is
play Rook to C1 maybe get the isolated
pawn and potentially try to create an
attack against your king and now that
you just play the move Knight D5 the
Knight on F6 was defending the king side
not anymore right so these are the type
of intrigues that we're going to see in
the upcoming moves okay intriguing
indeed isolated Queen Pawn position D5
so C4 takes D5 the most challenging okay
surprisingly race thinking
that's very surprising for my eyes
because I can only imagine that he's
considering the tossing in A3 here and
in case of Bishop takes c3b but I
thought he would know this position
because he prepared this he came with
this idea of Rook to E1 quickly that's
from home and this is the stem game in
the position it's a game between uh pet
charge and uh korobof from uh October
2022.
that's one out of only two games played
in this position so you do FC that was
the stem game C4 takes D5 on the board
1965 and this is where and Bishop D2 as
you
suggested yeah yeah yeah and right now
Fabi is going to
start thinking about a way to calm the
position down yeah and just keeping an
eye on the two Berlin and games and slow
boil it's like well it was kind of
interesting especially against the Sam
Shanklin against Wesley Soho is that Sam
has got more time than he started with
he's on 10 minutes whereas uh Wesley is
on seven minutes but uh it seems like
position is a Berlin
Sam is very well prepared isolated Queen
Pawn uh iqp and I'm trying to think of
uh games that Fabi is played against the
isolated Queen pawn and
they're not rushing to my mind it's not
as though this is a common feature in
his games uh it's not it's uh
huh
no but I mean these players are so good
they know everything they certainly do
uh but I'm just I'm trying right now for
when he had an isolated queen palm
position do you know what I'm talking
about here uh the Christian that that
it's not common in in in his games that
he's that is true that is true yeah we
don't see that very common so perhaps
this is a targeted effort by Ray to go
into certain positions that maybe Fabi
doesn't feel as comfortable in but he
does play very logically this bishop to
E7 makes a lot of sense Knight takes D5
could potentially become a threat if you
leave the bishop on B4 also that
27 guards this G5 Square so any sorts of
Knight G5 that Bishop is going to be a
good Defender around my king this is
what he's doing right now playing Just
logical moves this is going to be an
interesting one and it's going to be a
long one because white well I'm going to
get my attack ready Queen to E2 okay D1
maybe Rook ac1 I'm not in a hurry to do
anything it's going to be a slow boil as
we are seeing in the uh games as well
Queenie 2 Rook D1 the other idea that I
had in mind was actually Rook C1
immediately usually speaking in an
isolated Queen Pawn position
you're not exact you're not anxious to
trade anything including a pair of Rooks
but in this particular case I was
thinking that you know you you you're
ready to do your standard Motif
operations of H4 Queen D3 and so forth
um your quick take uh gov if you had uh
Ray's position after would you go for
the Queenie two Rook D1 would you
I think I would play Queen E2 I mean
moves that kind of also spring to mind
are you know put something on G5 another
thing that I've had done to me on
occasion is H4 I don't care about
material
that's a key move and uh this precise
type of position you're not even worried
about Bishop Texas I think it's a poison
Pawn actually yeah in many cases right
now I mean if you were to play H4
there's no way you can go Bishop takes
yeah right you just like leave that
alone and go okay you're welcome to put
your Pawn on H5 if you would like to
um you prefer white prefer black
I I I play a lot of this uh these
positions but on the black side so
instinctively I do prefer black but I
also know how dangerous they are
especially with the player who is an
attacking mood and knows how to keep the
pieces and the tension on the board so I
think it's a good choice by Ray actually
because it will force Fabiano to double
check triple track every single move
because there's so much Dynamic
potential on the board for white this is
where I think that Ray has got to do
this I mean he's taking some strategic
risk with the isolated Queen's Pawn but
Fabi
um
and he's such a great player such a
versatile player they're it's not like
there's a lot of chinks in his armor and
if there is one he's not happy when he's
playing the defensive role he prefers to
he prefers to have the initiative on his
side of the board so I think Rey's made
a good decision jump in here uh
Christian how does the engine evaluate
this position is very balanced around
zero zero zero so nothing has changed
from uh that perspective nevertheless as
you are mentioning and Visually at least
it does feel like white has the momentum
right in the position I35 that Knight is
probably going to land on G3 the Knight
on e4 maybe looking at the H5 Square
every single piece except the Rook on A1
feels like it's geared towards the black
king right here's the word the attack in
the position and this is what concerns
surely concerns Fabi right now Knight F6
I like that some pieces on the board and
that's exactly what he does and you know
you also have the white Bishop coming to
B5
alert alert okay okay alert
oh but you can still go
so let's see if we want to go Rook to d8
yes indeed alert alert so I take no but
then I take on F6 check
oh that's a check oh my goodness
does this actually work
standard stuff
okay let's try it in a different way
um after Queen D5 I'm going to go Queen
to F1
Queen the F1
okay now you take a minute back wow
Queen to F1
well D2 is hanging right yes it is
indeed but it is uh where at least you
don't have it
because if you put a rook onto DA's
keep five corners okay I guess
construction well night you no yeah but
who's Bishop E Yeah Yeah Bishop D5 E5
yeah was played so none none of this
will happen yeah uh
well just just uh making just checking
Bishop to D5 by the way
um if we go back just a second here in
this kind of position remember this
wonderful uh hippopotamus where it was
something like this where there was a
sacrifice on F7 sacrifice on G7
sacrifice on H6 and Michael Tall spent
50 minutes
not thinking about the position but
thinking about a poem
and then when he woke up he had no time
on his clock and sacrificed three pieces
calculated was this the one where he sat
there and thought about this how how he
was going to save a hippo from the mud
but uh okay we it does look like one of
the games is going to finish in a
drawers Dominguez
Bishops of opposite color there's no way
oh no that's an easy anything can happen
here let's stay with this one just to
see the handshake because we know it's
coming
sure is A3 King G6
there we go
exchange some pawns give me a four
just find the repetition guys I think
they are I think they are Bishop to see
Bishop to B6
come on come on what are you playing for
uh are they racing the Armageddon or the
racing to Blitz well we'll see they're
still Levon has the white pieces
yesterday Lavon put lenya on the
tremendous pressure and there comes a
handshake draw agreed
is so well Wesley is in some trouble oh
Wesley's still a little bit worse right
definitely on shaky grounds right now
but
I do feel we need to stay with the Fabi
game versus Ray Robson because this is
such a calm much complicated battle
yeah
yeah it was Ray Robson after the move
Bishop to D5 by the way he played Bishop
F4
which I I mean I've been waiting for the
Rook to come to D1 for some time and
that was a for me a little bit of a
surprise is now he's played the move
Queen G4 okay uh so starting point
everybody student body right
um from our American football we have
this play in football where the whole
team goes to one side of the field and
forces the ball down Queen to G4
anticipating Bishop H6 as well as Knight
H5 and just putting as many of the bits
around Black's King and and talking
about sacrifices I mean some just bring
to mind obviously they don't work but
they're there to be playing around with
Bishop takes H6 anyhow there's also
Knight F5 in the air at the right time I
like that yeah yeah at the right time
you gotta you gotta do you've also got
the Rook the Rovan roving Rook the Rooks
finger or whatever you call it okay
Bishop come yeah I will the first move
that uh I would like to play is to blunt
the attack with Bishop G5 with the queen
trades by the way the golden rule
your house is on fire you train Queen so
Bishop G5 and he's done it I have to go
Knight H5 right he's got to play Knight
H5 otherwise you're going to play Bishop
takes and queen G5 so Knight H5 G6 is a
serious question that is the serious
question are you hanging around uh what
are you doing
and these players are so well mashed up
right now four minutes I don't know
[Music]
okay just because I immediately
responded with F5 oh
I what huh H5 F5 whoa wow so Knight H5 I
was thinking G6 F5 well
it would cross my mind it would be
something that you've got to take I mean
there's just no but if you can take then
that kind of simplifies everything well
the problem is if I let if I if I make a
move like Queen here now my Bishop's
just dead it's not a is no longer an
attacking uh
Powerhouse could you kind of switch
plans for instance okay oh you're going
to play that yeah uh so I was thinking
hold on excuse me if I play ampasar and
what's the rule of om Passat you must
you have to be here
it's a force move what's the uh Queen
takes
and what's the body count after say
Bishop here I mean
I'm munching on BTS
yeah sorry and Ray understood that it's
a fourth move he took on F6 right
uh could I take on G5 I guess Queen
takes F2 I can
step aside is this
good bad ugly help me yeah well maybe we
can even start with Queen H3 right
but Queen H3 you have Queen H4 so that
seems to
equalize at least yeah
um
Rook takes E6 let's go from the
beginning guys so after Knight to F6 can
I take on G5
you can I did consider that but there is
um
like text Queen and then Bishop takes
clubs because
my spiders
yes I was looking at taking on F2 but
unfortunately
you can't always get what you want what
you want why not that's what they say
rookie two
Rook takes F2 rookie two oh you wanted
to go I thought Knight takes F2 was your
plan
I didn't have a plan
but plan
Knight takes F2 wait a minute I do have
a plan
I was looking at none of this will
happen
and Bishop G3 well he went for the first
variation yes right
the first variation was Bishop to G3 but
then you guys told me you were going to
take my Pawn on B2 and I immediately you
know paused as like oh man he did not
take the pawn on B2 he played because of
f4 H4 and maybe Queen G6 yes
ah this would have maybe
scared him away from the pawn so he did
what I'm sorry he played Bishop to F4
he's trying to trade off very practical
going to the equally the queen can come
to uh G6 yeah but I'm very happy with
white now suddenly I'm thinking that I'm
the one your Pawn structure is a little
bit it tatters
and uh I defend that too yeah defend F2
very important but we've actually seen
trades happen instead yep we did we
entered the end game and everything was
traded off and F3 was the last move D4
I just don't see it I don't see it
anymore well we have worked D1 Cheapo in
the air
Depot alert yeah but now you have to be
careful rooted
I've given you warnings
you did send me the notice
an eviction
notification it came in The Scarlet Red
Envelope
um yeah King f8 uh I was thinking I'm
still a little bit better after Rook E3
wow F7 he's trying to regroup and play
Rook to C7 Rook the F7 Rook to C7 Rook
to C1 okay but
I can play for a long long time this
position is white I mean Rook C1 I like
I'm expecting Rook to C7 right now okay
and I will get active I will happily
trade a pair of Rooks and bring my king
uh swiftly up the board I remember that
quote that I read in a book yeah you
describe yourself
I described it she said I'm like a dog
for the bone
well a grinder you said the grindmeister
yeah hello yeah wow uh dog with a bone
okay let me just sorry I'm gonna just
refresh my board and uh we're up to date
uh I think this will be more or less a
draw I I don't think we're going to see
much of our own computer doesn't does
the computer think that white has
anything no no no no no all right I
think we should go to the Wesley game
because it's still defending a very
difficult end game right now let's do it
yeah well this is one of the problems of
the Berlin is that you are giving up the
potential passer on the king side by the
way only 57 seconds for Wesley against
four minutes for Sam Shanklin
but I mean he he'd have
McQueen side is lovely you know if he
gets his Pawn going to A3 and most
mobilizes The Rook okay that's why
none of that none of that in the air
give me that pawn right but now we have
Bishop takes
let's go
G6 do it
I will probably be forced to play Bishop
to F6 but then you have um he's done it
he's done it yeah I mean you have to
worry about Rook too wait whoa whoa
Brave
simple and clinical just like that you
give me this Pawn that's a check and
then I will come back to stop the point
well he's playing missed something
because
somebody's missing something now this is
a passer
on my hands what is happening in this
one
they said I have to stop your a pardon
me I have to stop your Jeep on
this is no problem suddenly uh what
who's playing for the win Wesley's going
to be playing for the win I mean he's
going to round up the pawn on G7 well
I'm thinking he's going to put his
Bishop F6 Rook G8 and hello say hello to
my little friend
that pawn on B3 is what a turnaround
actually has gone to G4 big threat on
the board of course Wesley's
I'm not sure that B3 takes A4 was
necessarily a bad move it just didn't
the following okay but you're never
losing this position right you're not
are you sure you can go King E6 King F7
and once we trade the Rooks like put the
King on P3 and the game is over isn't
the bishop could have gone to F6 this is
another one of those fortresses yeah
yeah that would be amazing oh my king to
C2 I keep the bishop on E3 just so that
you know King is gonna dance and the
light squares not not budging right and
even though I might be two pawns up I
won't be able to break the blockade he
does have the saving race yes remarkable
but good defense by Wesley I mean he was
in the dark house in this one it felt
like it yes uh time is it a factor I
don't know well when it comes to time
you see Wesley has just over 30 seconds
whereas Sam he's sure
okay
and we see Bishop F6 now Bishop to E3
Bishop E3 kind of invites Bishop to D4
right
so he did play King B3 and he's going
for that blockade uh that we talked
about Rook takes G7 Rook takes G7 and
you can't
pushing a rook component if you go
Bishop takes Pawn as opposed to mm-hmm
and you're in a nasty pen right
yeah D4
okay well he's
he's trying to trick
Sam somehow I'm not exactly sure how
he's whether he's tricking himself or
he's tricking Sam King back
okay I think he's gonna trick him by
moving the route to A8 and then the king
will be replacing the hating Rook right
that's when I want to Queen my Pawn the
moment you play Rook A8 is when I want
to play G8 equals guys this is not that
easy anymore no he's threatening now
Rook A8
that's huge What A Swindle wait a minute
Rook A.A
oh Rook A2 the only part probably
but Rook A8 Rook a two Rook E8 that's a
very good point or rookie 8 immediately
in that case then what's happening
this is not easy anymore guys
it could be lost I mean Rook A3 check
and B3 is a winning threat
What A Swindle by Wesley saw truly
why he's so great he's excellent at
finding those moves under pressure
it's not over
I still have enough
resources to make a draw right age eight
that's a Kind of a Funny move I I
thought he was going to go Rook to E8
and he's doing it now well I mean Rook
A8 Rook A2 Rook E8 built in time on the
clock and then you can uh
take a control of the Eli line now
King A4 King B5 that is
I I can't believe that the releasing the
bee Pawn no is a good idea you cannot do
that but how am I supposed to defend
this it's not easy let's give a check
first right Rook F2 Rook F2 the king
would go backwards
okay okay playing steps back using the
bishop for as a shield
and then um I mean if you try to guard
the third row I mean the black remote
down with like rookie and Bishop to D4
and perhaps Bishop F4 right now try to
distribute four defense E3 but no no no
I think this is winning I think this is
winning if I'm Sam shankun right now I'm
starting to be worried oh yeah
definitely the panic button
okay and so and meanwhile I think in the
Ray Robson Fabiana game that's going to
finish in a draw okay but
can you go B3 I think I'm gonna go King
F7 first because B3 is the one move I
want to play when your king is not going
back to A2 so yeah king of seven that's
a little bit more feels right
[Music]
Rook oh oh oh did I blow it no no I
think it's okay you can just go
okay
or Bishop D6 well Bishop D6 Bishop D4
that's a construction I want
but now that you don't have B3 maybe I
can try to focus on attacking that C5
Pawn
true so perhaps I can start with root
King to B5 Bishop to D4 and then Bishop
to D6
check
it's a kind of a little dance going on
there between the rook and the King
just to give you an update it doesn't
seem like the game between Ray Robinson
and Fabiano caruana is going anywhere
but to draw
yeah
yeah Fair
well in this particular game Sam is
staunchly defending against Wesley's
extra Pawn truly
um Wesley never got the chance to really
get in the move Bishop to D4 I mean he's
just dreaming of just getting out of
that like awkward pin for the moment
yeah I think he's just making some King
moves just to build time you know he's
down to 13 seconds he does get five
second increment per move
and five seconds is not really okay now
right yeah the bishop is not that safe
on us
the bishop comes to check
okay three oh that was his trick
The Rook has a step backwards and now
the king Take C5 is on tap what is going
on in this game Bishop E5 is on tap
Bishop takes C5 is on tap did Wesley
blow it
and he got out of the threat of Bishop
E5 but there goes the pawn well I guess
it is Sam right now that is playing for
a win because I believe talk about uh
back and forth game
my goodness and what you don't want to
see is Rook Bishop versus Rook with two
seconds on the clock
yeah we do have a result the other game
between Ray and Fabi was a draw so we
more or less expected Rook to B8 what is
he doing I Rook to B8 nine eight seven
centralizing Bishop wow I don't like
that move Rook B8 was like just freezing
White's pieces right
now right
he's really playing with fire right now
it it's a strange
this has been a strange game so Rook
Rook B7 keep the Rook active no
what the heck was king of King E6 it was
like sure oh my gosh well actually I'm
I've just uh checking the table bases
and they're saying it is a
drawing because he's going to be able to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn right
but you don't want to see those type of
end games
uh not unless you really really
absolutely sure of how to draw them
predictions do you think white is going
to win or not draw but uh I'll take I'll
take Sam you'll fix it I'll take some
you think he's going to win The Rook of
Bishop versus I feel we're going to see
the rook and Bishop versus rook and
perhaps we're going to see a win by him
yeah but I I was going to say the move
King F5 was a very very shocking
decision by Wesley to to even
a little unsure
uh King C5 let's go okay
sex is possible
King 86 is also a similar idea just
great move you you can see if I play C7
be careful don't allow Rook day C5
hey copy that
Rook F2 just to throw the kick I was
about to say but either way you're going
to play Rook F7 just to push the king a
little bit to the to the Borderland so
that you can play C7
Rook D7 Rook D7 we have
we're gonna see broken Bishop versus uh
I think what Sam is trying to get is
more than that I think he's trying to
get some Bishop to D4 Bishop to E5 and
play C7 without allowing black to
sacrifice the vision fair fair
check F7 King has to go to G6 in that
case King G6 Rook G7 oh I beg your
pardon so you have to be it's now losing
Bishop E5 Bishop E5 exactly
Bishop E5 and after Rook d8 Rook D7
correct you can no longer sacrifice the
bishop for the part
and you don't have Bishop F2 to try to
go on the other diagonal
Bishop
oh my goodness
check
now yeah this was more or less my
question
oh only one move to draw and that's
actually to stop off Rooks I was about
to say Rook takes C8 Bishop to d8
you've got the table base how is it how
is the current situation it's losing
apparently
for Wesley because Bishop D6 what you
were describing there
um Bishop C7 super passive well the idea
was that he he wants to be able to
sacrifice his Bishop King C5 King B5 but
the bishop is on
d8
Bishop d8 King E6
oh well the bishop has gone down too
let's go Bishop D why did Dean go Bishop
to d8 it just seconds this must be
winning the clock exactly C seven wins
Rook A3 is also a great move driving the
king away to a worse Square
what it's amazing the thing that Wesley
was up upon he was yes he had G5 and B4
and he lost both of them yeah and you
can just actually see from the body
language there that Wesley is he's
completely frustrated and we see
yes big question
and again Bishop to d8 why didn't he
what was it that he didn't like about
Bishop to d8
he didn't like something I'm not sure
why he keeps going to perhaps he's
looking at C7 Bishop to H4 followed by
Bishop to d8 I think this is his plan
uh-huh
oh really oh that enforces the trade of
roads with the trade of Rooks the
position is now a draw according to the
table basis
okay King F comes back
I'm not sure about Kinga
right yeah doesn't the king work its way
around yeah King D7 King D5 and you keep
contact with that point yes exactly you
cannot win this this is like a Fisher
end game and I have Bishop d8 also
uh Bishop d8 is yeah
yeah and anywhere on the day uh yeah
anywhere on the diagonal
wow what a game truly
well and now I have Bishop d a bishop to
d8
because your king is keeping contact
with the pawn on Seasons
okay is it still okay it's still a draw
Bishop d8 was a kind of a zoo or
whatever
uh
King C4 is going to go he's going to B5
yeah yeah King C8 followed by King to B7
okay
come on King to D5 King to B7 Bishop to
d8 that's on a draw King B5 is also good
this is a drawer Bishop goes back well
the bishop is going to come to see
okay C7 right
that's where he's going okay but then
I've got to stay on the diagonal oh
Bishop has to go
push me five trembling yeah good thing
you touched the bishop because if you
touch the king that was resignation on
the moment and it's now a draw yeah yeah
no I reckon I've never seen Wesley's
hands shake like they are shaking it's
nervous it's it's the nerves
but he did build up a lot of time on his
clock right now he has 30 seconds to
think it through yeah and it's just
quite simple just to maintain the
connection with that C7 Square
absolutely
water safe
[Laughter]
he played that really
unnerving I mean where was the vision of
going other than V6 and it went high in
the air it was a nice hot yes without
Bishop
okay the bishop goes to A5 as before
this is a repeat right okay
Bishop can go anywhere along that
diagonal um
okay we have a new Point Bishop A7 but
that doesn't really really because
Bishop B8 is not a threat he will take
on B8 who
oh there's a trick
is it just me or Wesley Sands are
actually trembling it feels like Wesley
is definitely definitely nervous Bishop
to F4 Bishop to C7 Bishop D2 it still
looks like he's got the draw in his
pocket
hasn't spoiled anything after Bishop to
D2
Sam is definitely doing his very best to
nerve Wesley though
or tennis game truly well Wesley's been
in this situation before so it just has
to hold his nerve put his Bishop on D2
and now okay keep that connection with
the C7 Square
d8 yep
we've definitely there we go
wow
uh Wesley was my pick guy I had some
skin in the game on that one
we're sweating on that one when he
dropped those two pawns and where was
the win you said there was a table base
win at one moment there was one where
the Rooks were still on the board the
Rooks were still on the board must be
when he had the option of playing C7
right
and it was when the white which member
Which movement number by the way talk
about Century there was another one so
it wasn't Rook f8 okay this is in fact
kind of ridiculous wow check this out so
this is the position yeah he should have
played C7 Bishop to H4 was Wesley's idea
to try to go Bishop to d8 sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn but now the only
move that wins is Rook to A3 check okay
if you go to E2 then I go King to E4
let's say you go Bishop to d8 right yes
now I give you a check and I'm the first
one to Checkmate you before you take my
Pawn King to E6 and you're going to get
trackmated here how nasty is that yes
but not easy to see what if you go here
right to G4 King to C6 the only move the
idea being that if you go Bishop to d8
now I have a check
and then I go to G8 I mean this is study
like uh this is truly study like uh very
difficult to find with five minutes on
the clock right almost impossible to
find with 30 seconds on his clock so
sure he must be disappointed that he
didn't take it home but it wasn't easy
Wow Let's just review our results as we
get ready for the second game of the
playoffs uh
you know we can see that there was a
draw but it felt like boy these players
were giving it everything they had they
did the lower rated players all got
black uh a pardon me all had white for
the first game so uh now the higher rate
of players will be uh with white for the
second game
um we didn't pay too much attention to
this particular match-up that was the
Berlin as well I did any fireworks
happen in that game no no no no no no
that one was smooth sailing for the
player with the blacklist which I
believe it was levoir defended quite
accurately right now he has a good
chance with the white piece to try to
pile on the pressure on his opponent
yeah we'll have to review some of that
footage because it definitely felt like
Wesley he was making me nervous you know
a little tremble a little bit unsteady
with the hand and then he would put his
Bishop on B6 and Jovi you told us about
his heart rate about that again so of
course in Berlin in Berlin in the
Armageddon series they had wrist watches
that monitored the heart rate and uh Sam
had a very steady heart rate you know it
was like around about 85 and you know
when he felt the stress you know he shot
up to 120 but but in Berlin Wesley
actually began the game often with about
130 and shot up to 170. now just to kind
of give you a comparison like you know
actually and we're a normal resting
heart rate is anything under 100. if
you're over a hundred that means you're
under some stress right and think of
under 120 is concerned signing
call this 1-800 number as soon as you
can yes and uh yeah I mean they I mean
170 is almost kind of scary right lenia
Dominguez got the highest heart rate he
had 181. and uh Wesley did ask us you
know when we told him that he had a
heart rate of over 175 you know he said
well were you prepared to call us on
were you prepared to call it ambulance
and we were like
we
have the defibrillator ready and they
are underway for this next game I need
to just
um yeah I mean I need help
is what I need
you can't see that
exactly
they are off and we can see the Italian
estate by Wesley Knight to C3 that's an
interesting approach and by the way the
Italian with Bishop to E7 we don't see
that very often generally the bishop
comes out to C5
um
A4 okay Wesley
pouncing on the queen side Knight 25.
hmm
an invitation to repeat the moves but
will Wesley do it with Bishop to C4
unlikely
unlikely and uh
surrogance Sam shankland
sorry I'm just getting a little
technical difficulty on my end I'll be
right with you yeah okay we are now in
the
well uh Joko piano a quiet game quiet
game very complicated and I mean there's
some some games that are Brewing up
quite nicely and one that kind of
catches my eye actually is between
levonne aronian and lenia Dominguez
they've given the Berlin arrest
thank you
I mean how does this position
look like Christian because then we see
something very imbalanced Levon is
coming with some interesting ideas
for sure yes yes but it does seem like
linear is at least aware of what he
needs to be doing in this type of
position which is to Target The Pawn on
D5 right you have the Knight on F6 maybe
the other night is going to B6 pile on
the pressure on the pawn on D5 or get
that Knight either C5 or E5 he has a lot
of options but the key is the Knight on
D7 where is that guy going to go
always thought in these positions I'm I
I'm supposed to be playing rookie 8 and
94. I always like this bishop on G7 I
need to be down the Knight on C5
I'm just ready to go like rookie Aid and
uh n94 virtually every type of position
uh in this particular case uh well
you're inviting me to play Queen
B6 and in case of Queen D2 then Knight
C5 and I'm aspiring to play the move
Knight E4
looks good I have to say although you
can just go Bishop H6 and try to trade
off
try and trade off those dark Square
Bishops because that's my favorite thing
in the world when I get a structure like
this is just trade off the dark Square
Bishop just try to soften up the black
king
nothing more than that and then just
play on the open lines
yeah one of the uh it's one of those
things where the D5 Pawn asset or
liability it's very nice that after for
example a move like Knight B6 you you
can't play Bishop E6 you but there's
always this concern that it could become
a liability liability so again if I'm in
on black shoes the move that I find
attractive is Queen B6
just and again if you do play Queen D2
Knight to C5 looking at 94 as a way of
taking off some of the pressure Bishop
F5 and so forth
Lanier is taking his time which
indicates to me that he's actually
considering H7 H6 well guys I have to
tell you there's finally some sort of a
separation going on in the game in a
match I might add between Ray Robinson
and Fabi because Ray's on the backflip
he's on the defense he got a very bad
position very difficult position out of
the opening
feels like Fabi has come to this game
very well prepared and right now the
engine is showing that Bobby has a
decisive Advantage a decision
Advantage yes like what on Earth did he
do that was so bad it doesn't feel so it
doesn't feel I mean black is upon up
right right for the moment but you are
going to lose the dark Square bishop and
I am going to pick back up
the pawn on D4 after that also my Bishop
is going to go on the long diagonal I'm
going to have very active pieces against
very passive pieces specifically that
Bishop on C8 so it does feel like
finally we see some separation between
these two players this match has been so
tense and so balanced up to this point
exactly he did Play Bishop D6 Knight
takes D4 you were mentioning that yeah I
agree with you wholeheartedly if you get
the dark squared Bishop you know then it
it's white all the way but are we sure
we're getting the dark Square Mission
well maybe you're not but you go Bishop
C5 root to D1 right now yeah take it
back
edge of the board
yeah you're right
not really big yeah I'm not a big fan I
agree with you uh this is uh well we
have it on the board actually and what's
more concerning is Fabi has 24 seconds
more than what he started with and Ray
Robson down to his last five minutes and
50 seconds six minutes right now
and Bishop C7 was Ray's choice in this
position which by the way the computer
he says terrible three what terrible
three and there must be something yeah
Bishop to D2
uh threatening Bishop before this is a
decisive Advantage right now for Fabiano
caruana but this is this because of
moves Bishop to D2 that's that's the
move that's the move right now and
what's the answer after A5
wow
I have some ideas after A5 I can go
Knight takes A5
followed by Rook to A4 now
oh
you laugh at me when I grab pawns
but is this the reason why it's plus
three yeah
if you take with the Rook now it starts
to make sense right yeah I like the the
Bishops are on the traffic I actually
think Bishop to B4 is uh problem and
also Bishop to B4 now you start to see
responses lots of nice things happening
for white if you take with the bishop uh
Rook to A4 and here the problem is after
Bishop takes D2 two pieces are hanging
at the end of the line he didn't do it
he played Rook to D1
which still puts a lot of pressure on
black you still don't have a clearer
going to go E5 let's go E5 yeah why not
wow Rook to D1 that is uh confounding he
didn't see these lines the ideas it felt
very computer-like to be honest yes it
was but Bishop to D2 nonetheless if you
have to play A5 then I'm gonna go Bishop
to C3 if I don't see Knight takes A4 and
Rick B8 played but I do wonder you know
your idea of Bishop D2
still very good and now
85.
I was waiting for uh Rook V8 before
it's on the board
and now I see a huge Advantage for white
suddenly now now it becomes very
self-evident how uh White's position
plays itself the threat of Bishop to B4
skewering The Exchange
is well is there any answer no this is
just no answer no
my goodness it's that bad wow
and look at Ray right now and in K I
mean whoever wins this the second game
because everybody Drew their first game
whoever wins the second game goes on in
the bracket and the loser goes down into
the illumination bracket yeah so uh
obviously it would be a big loss for Rey
and instead of saying loser I meant to
say the runner-up
goes to the elimination bracket there
are no losers in check
I would say you win or you learn
yeah yeah I like the winning part not as
much as the learning part yes all right
so how can you even remember well I I
have to move the Rook Rook dates Rook d8
Bishop B4 and live on the back rank okay
what do you do now 28 leave it my
goodness this doesn't look beautiful
it's not a beauty yeah
I never said that but I mean okay how
bad is it if I go Bishop takes yeah it's
bad yeah oh but Ray looks devastated
right now look at him oh
oh look at this uh B7 Pawn One cannot
live like this okay can you give
something up for instance Brooke takes
work I have an iPad I have an idea
and then this is where you kind of cough
and the light Square Bishop comes out to
F5 no I was actually thinking
about five with Elan too like you just
throw it out let's try it out the final
trick I was thinking Knight to D5 right
there and just you know try to dangle
some material but I mean really yeah
we have the tape guys unfortunately so
we right we go back to the tape Bishop
by five is yes yes
so this is the situation this is what
Ray is facing and uh we think Bishop B4
is just uh a a clean victory yeah down
to his last two minutes right now his
dance I think he just has to give up
material and just hope the best
A5
okay in this type of instances you
almost feel like resigning on the spot
you know you don't need to do that and
you don't you shouldn't do that right
but it just feels like there's no
Dreadful and I've seen so many
interviews where the top Grand Masters
Of The World come out and they say ah I
wanted to resign and they never resign
somehow they save the game but here I
wanted to resign he did play Rook d8 by
the way our uh initial uh
grovel idea and Bishop B4 we think
Knight D6 is just going to
win and keep you updated on the other
two games yes not that much is happening
still very balanced the other two
yeah I
I actually felt the things I actually
brewing in the uh
yeah but not as not as not as fiery as
what's happening now right because here
we're seeing just
this is these guys are good yeah they
followed our main one of our Mainland
this is a source of concern I think
probably you're right we're going to see
something I think this is a resignation
he's done it and you can see by the way
yeah it is like out of it he's checked
out but it's so miserable right it is 67
1967 Rook to D1 and now you don't have
what the time you cannot touch yeah any
of your pieces exactly
this is like a dream Catalan a dream any
anything I mean but you just gotta
survive I mean but how do you survive
the question well you make a move like
age six you know
especially when there's no return game
you know you're just like this is it
this is the
this is it yeah yeah because to D1 why
yeah Rook to D1 and I'm just thinking go
H6 and look at Ray Ray looks like he's
devastating yeah yeah he's he's eaten a
disagreeable frog yeah yeah no it's just
paint
right now he's just pain in this game
85.
okay A5 we're okay six I'm gonna unwind
and then what
repair job right coming but no it's not
Queen
here uh truth be told I would be very
attracted to the move a four and B3
because
if I'm going to fix the queen side I'd
like to fix them with the pawns on dark
squares
I would be attracted to just can I be a
bit more forceful I want to go Bishop to
E4
yeah Bishop to E4 right then on H7 yeah
and if I defend that with Bishop D3
ah I'm really trying to be sadistic in
this position I I want to not allow your
Rook to get out
but not only that but also to pin the
Knight yes that is
that's actually very very nice I I think
that is actually the most
promising Bishop to E4 Bishop to D3 and
let me just put that on the board just
to show our audience how very attractive
this is because you're threatening to go
Bishop B5 and then everything is frozen
and you can't even play Knight F6
because there is the the check and Rook
d8 winning material he's played Queen to
D3 okay he's going for the pawn
[Laughter]
when when you don't know what else to do
right just grab the material Golden Rule
the golden rule number two makes a lot
of sense yeah well your idea of Bishop
to B5 kind of does okay you can go age
six because you know Bishop takes porn
is not possible because of Knight C5
true after Queen B5 where is your next
turn
I mean yeah yikes yeah you have to go
Queenie seven and just
so it's not pretty I don't like it I
mean this is a pawn that I will one day
Clip right
yeah and then you kind of just stop
there right with your knight on D7 and
I'll take it and go A5 and
yeah okay but you you've got to do this
type of thing one last gasp yes
Dreadful Dreadful
uh just checking in on Lanier
okay
very intriguing game going on there
we'll definitely get back to it the
blood is being spilled in this game
between Fabi and Rey
and
yeah this is the big one right now
because this could please play nd5 yes
in A4
race fighting yeah he's doing everything
he can to stay in the game yep
the problem is is there's just no
no active play for him he's going to
lose the Apon Rook takes a force on tap
do you even want to take that point I
don't know it's just a it's such a bad
position I feel like you do because I
mean there's no way that I can put the
bishop back on D6 because when I have
the bishop on D6 and then I go Rook
takes A4 what can I there's no Knight C5
pardon me can I take on B7 doesn't that
win
a lot Bishop takes B7
you have to take on B7 yeah
Bishop B6 coming at the end and that's
just going to be a pin that I'm 100 sure
you can't yeah that's even easier yes
right yes yes Bishop takes B7 Rook takes
D7 followed by Queen takes B7 yeah this
is all that's a handshake over and uh
Ray 20 seconds left on the clock and you
can just see the frustration his body he
knows it's over and so he's just thrown
in E5 attack The Rook
he never got into this game it was
something right out of the opening where
it it all went wrong incredibly early it
was like we were HIV speaking for myself
when when Christian informed is that it
was minus three I was like what it
didn't feel terrible at the time in fact
Rey was upon up when the computer was
saying minus three now we're we're
really understanding why E5 what's the
what's the kill let's move the Rook
summer yeah
I was thinking as a final survival try I
mean black once white white just moves
The Rook anywhere go Rook A7
Bishop thanks to you and then Rook takes
this album
that was close
it really quotes on this one it's just
so sad right
leadership takes E5 wow okay that was
I'm gonna say uncalled for
maybe that's really a strong move Bishop
take C5
okay what
is a seven
okay you can well that's can I throw in
he's staying in the game
are you yes he's staying in the game he
hasn't uh not convinced about that well
I understand I mean uh
it's the best he could have hoped for
sure Bishop shakes bishop and now Knight
takes efficient forced Knight takes C5
yeah maybe Europe takes A4 just gift me
that pawn that's through is that really
three that's three cheese that's a lot
down one two up three right
that's a swing
there's also Bishop
F5
Queen coming it's also queen Coming yeah
although there's night scene I don't
know that Rook takes A4 move that's your
Rook E4 by the way to six the vouchers
are yeah yeah rookie four actually has
my attention because anytime I can
provoke you to weaken the light squares
that much more uh when I am the one with
the light Square Bishop I I would love
to introduce that little move going for
your move yeah sir yeah
yeah
rookie4f6 Rook takes A4
that just ensures that whenever we do
Play Bishop F5
the king side is that much more loose
remarkably
oh my goodness
Lanier and Wesley are going to win their
respective games
wow wow they broke through
[Laughter]
wow okay Queen to G8 that's that's a
really powerful move Bishop F5 we're
just witnessing
uh between Fabi and Rave that we are
looking also I I think this one might be
a handshake very very soon yeah the move
Queen G8 was really
super yeah
yeah and now we've got Queen takes G7
check followed by rook 64. and that's
that's it right that's it
yeah but it
okay we see him reach for that pawn on
G7 I mean
is there any hope in surviving no for
instance the king coming up to East six
there's Queen F5 at the end but
the queen no he's no way
well he's gone for Rook 35. what are the
keys on F1 yeah yeah Knight takes every
check I saw the same thing for a second
I thought the king is on G1 exactly I
had a heart attack right like not
allowing Knight takes F3 check
yeah there's nothing for it the Queen
the queen is overextended no um Sam has
a two and uh 40 seconds two minutes and
40 seconds to enjoy this position and
Wesley has uh just under just over one
and a half minutes yeah I think there's
only one player enjoying yeah I meant it
sarcastically sorry Chris right
enjoying his extra time yes
it's time to resign
uh
why does he must be beating himself
because he had such a golden opportunity
in the last game well the first game
that they played it was a real swing
game it was like people you know Wesley
had his chance as well and it whoa
but Rook takes D4 and queen C6 and
you're just about to close the show Fabi
as well just about to close the show you
can take the pawn on G7 he's done it
you have to play Knight F7 because Queen
takes E5 is on tap yeah but uh isn't The
Rook gonna no no no you can't you can't
you can't you've got to be careful no
I'm going to take on D7 and I'm gonna
take on F7 or 95. yeah you're going to
take on F7 and go Knight E5 check right
oh pardon me you can just play Knight E5
as well now he
now do we play G4
right yeah G4 F4 and then take on F7 yes
he's done that and that's enough and
that was enough and uh a headshake
ahead and uh shall we yes
elenia Dominguez but did Fabi win I
think we should stick with the other one
because I think no the Fabi the Fabby
one looks like it's never mind and we
just saw a result
yes Queen D1 check and Lanier goes
through
and leaves us our remaining game Folly
well no Blitz today
all the way not today not today I wrote
the C5 very clinical A5 A6
is coming
well you do have a threat of no I
apologies
to go behind the pawn on B5 nice
that's
I'm counting a lot of White ponds I
don't know about you guys but I see a
lot of white ones and one of them is
gonna make B7 transition yes yeah even
though B7 Knight to D7 okay I'm not
going to give you any chances
I'm thinking A5 A6 A7 uh it kind of got
my vote you know he's going for it yeah
he wants to take on B6
why give him the satisfaction yeah
exactly just go B70 be sure okay
okay yeah that's that's certainly uh
good enough
you can go H5 if you want you can go to
D5 check
by the way that move H5 sure looks good
too I mean I know too too many good
looking moves but H5 especially because
the you're using your Double H Pawn I
worked with D4 I mean defending that
pawn
use four
I think he wants to go Rook A4
I mean
um
this is not sadistic it is it is it is
enjoying himself too much right now he
really is
uh it's Rook d8 no pardon me uh okay
come on E3 okay he wants to go Bishop to
E2 I think he just wants to defend the
Rook on D4 or Bishop to B7 in order to
play A6
it's one should instigate ignition a
resignation but nope F4 okay you can now
go a six a six
nothing's stopping that one no and
and takes
yeah one last gasp there uh there's not
much left wow
yeah time to call it a day and there we
see a handshake Fabiana Corona wow into
the championship bracket we finally saw
a top I mean in the open section A win
with the black pieces it had been a
white uh White winning all of the games
but I didn't see how a linear won that
was that game with D5 uh Christian the
the where did Lavon blow it well let's
take a look because I wasn't watching
this game either it seems that at this
point
he got tempted by this idea of playing
Knight to A4 and jump to B6 that looks
good the problem is that after Queen to
B5 and once we exchange everything
you're going to see the power of the two
Bishops and the controlling power of the
two Bishops because once we exchange the
Queens this B2 Pawn is hanging this A2
Pawn once I attacked that Rook on A1
with Bishop takes B2 is going to be
hanging as well this is just not a good
position and unfortunately for him he
was unable to oh my goodness wow 100
sure what I did here so let's you guys
take it back okay your force me yeah to
pick up where you left off and you were
saying that uh in this position he got
tempted by the move Knight A4 and then
Queen B5 and the two Bishops ooh Rook E2
rookie one and it's just
completely overwhelming when you get a
rook onto the SEC and that's a nice
touch take control of the dark squares
Rook takes F2 that hurt and then Bishop
to D4 and Then followed that by Rick
take the knights
and now Rick's Queen comes down to D1
and that's just game over I am picking
up the Rook on F2 and then I got wow so
I mean essentially
it was here where I well
that uh he's missed this combination of
Rook takes F2 ninth wave four was just a
bad move just a bad Nightwing four was
just the wrong direction at this point
you had to consolidate in the position
leave the Knight on C3 stop the action
of that bishopon G7 play move such as A4
maybe A5 block that pawn on B7 keep the
queen to the defense of that pawn on B7
and just play a normal game night wave 4
was just too aggressive yeah I'm
thinking I would have played myself in
White Shoes to neutralize the bishop on
G7 I would have played Rook to D1
followed by Bishop to D4
um
but uh Knights came by a linear and uh
sum it up for us where do we stand uh
jovia after uh a very entertaining day
too absolutely I was on the edge of our
seats and there we can see it in the
Champions bracket Hikaru Nakamura will
face off against lenia Dominguez who
qualified after that fantastic win
against Lavon aronian and then we also
have Wesley so meeting Fabiano caruana
both players staggering across the
finish line here it is staggered but
it's enough yes and they continue they
are on their second life still and
moving down to the Elimination Brackets
these places these players are on their
last grasp they are playing with their
backs against the wall Sam Seville meets
livon aronium
whoever loses will get eliminated and
Sam Shanklin will play Ray Robson and
these guys will play a much faster time
control of 25 minutes plus 10 second
increment whereas in the Champions
bracket they're going to be playing
classical chess and in the ladies and in
the women's brackets that we see the
Champions bracket Arena Crush will face
off against begum took into Nova and uh
Nazi pakiza will play off against a 13
year old Alice Lee who has been so
impressive
and moving down to the elimination
bracket these players again are in a
must win situation if they lose they go
home tatv abrahamian will face off
against Katarina nemsava and Anna
sotonsky will face off against newcomer
atusa
wonderful and Christian with one of our
winners Lanier this was such a tense
balanced match between you two that it
started off with the classical match it
felt like you had some sort of a pool
but he defended just incredibly well and
it ended up with this game Samira for us
yeah it was very uh even much of course
in the classical game I got a nice
position but I think he knew quite well
the the end game that it's just a draw I
mean it looks of course very scary for
black but uh if you know it's raw then
did you know so scary I remember
checking it like but long time ago
because I remember there were a couple
of games of one U against Lego I think
and uh and maybe another game of
jakobenko against Alexei probably uh and
I was checking it back then and I
remember it was a draw with very precise
play but then it all depends depends on
some Pawn placement and I thought it's
like a nightmare for for black in
practice but I think he knew quite well
uh and then yeah I didn't have much to
do and then yeah the the tie breaks of
course in the first game I didn't get
much with white and then it all came I
mean the the second game I was I think I
got a decent position from the opening
did you feel like he was taking
unnecessary risks or I thought no I mean
I I thought it's just a normal position
uh I was expecting something like Rook
81 in this position and then play for
Bishop D4 try to trade his Bishops I
thought black has a has a good position
anyway but uh but it's probably balanced
that's what I thought during the game
and after Knight A4 did you start yeah I
mean reading about potential I thought
finishing them I thought I have to play
Queen B5 but I didn't know that it was
so great but once I started thinking I
realized that it's quite unpleasant for
for white now because I have the Bishops
and then the Rook is coming to E2 and
and yeah White's position is just really
unpleasant at this point and I think
after that I had to find a couple of
size move like this Rook C2 because yeah
the point was that if I play Rook a E8
which is a natural move the Knight C3
holds for white and I cannot take on B2
now take and then right yeah because the
thing is after Knight C3 I always have
Queen takes B2 in general that's why for
example instead of rookie E1 Knight C3
uh it's not possible this time because
now right yeah that's the point but
that's why Rook C2 is very strong just
keeping the the Knight on A4 out of out
of the game and now always Knight C3
I'll take on B2 with the queen yeah and
yeah and then I had to find this uh okay
Rook ac8 I think was also precise with
the Rook F2 ideas and then it was just a
I had to calculate with a little time
but uh thankfully I had the Berlin event
just to work a little bit the
calculation with with a few seconds so I
was I was able to do it quite quite well
a big match is uh coming against Hikaru
Nakamura player that feels like he's in
great shape how are you going to
approach that one yeah so he he seems to
be in great shape but I'm just quite
happy that I qualify against such a
strong opponent like the one so I'll uh
just uh try to enjoy victory for a
little while for a couple of hours yes
and then I'll see how I will approach
the next one linear we'll see you
tomorrow thank you congratulations our
congratulations indeed and good luck uh
with your match against Hikaru a very
impressive uh finish there especially by
linear I like what he was saying about
the position of Rook C2 in order not to
allow the Knight C3 yeah and then to
finish it with Rook F2 is very very nice
very beautiful yeah and very accurately
calculated how much time on the Vlog I
have to say I mean for a rapid game that
was really high quality stuff if you
said you know Lanier dominguez's best
games and said that was played at a
classical Tempo yeah you'd say yeah that
was a really good game very good game
and for levonne it just goes to show
that having a bad plan is not
necessarily better than no plan at all
another guest with Christian Wesley this
was uh just an incredible match and yeah
I want to start with this game because
this was just wild and we were looking
at the camera your hands were trembling
at some point did you feel your heart
pumping
yeah for sure thank God there's no heart
rate monitor
but thank you yeah thank Christian for
you always cheer me up when everybody
come here that's good that's good talk
to us about this game
your I mean on the back foot somewhere
around here and objectively in fact you
were lost yeah yeah did you think that
you were lost at this yeah
I mean I thought I was drawing but then
he kept kicking my kick making farther
and farther away in fact I was just
discussing with Fabiano just before
coming here
um we're trying to find a win for white
after Bishop E1 so this was the critical
win yeah
and now this is some sort of a study
like hey Chuck why King G4 if you go
King G4 then I can go King C6 and I have
the pin on the eighth round
and if I don't go to G4 then you go
check made it
if you go here I go here we it's crazy
yeah but it's simply crazy yeah I mean I
I should have taken the door early on I
think what was winning on move 92 even
from other moves yeah like like why it
has all the time in the world yeah but
uh
ah look at fate
maybe is winning as well but still you
managed to survive in this one and after
that you took over in the last game
tomorrow you will be facing in fact
Fabiano Carona yeah how do you feel
about that matchup uh well it's going to
be an a very exciting match I hope I can
put my best chess you know uh Fabian of
a wonderful and great player the
defending U.S Champion so uh hopefully
it'll be all right I mean it's hard to
predict what's gonna happen
and uh yeah today I felt a bit tired
because I just came back from Berlin but
put in some 14 hours of sleep
and then come with a lot of energy is
that the best way to fight jet lag yes
sleep as much as possible yeah I mean I
take melatonin okay if you have your
bank account
we did not no yeah yeah she offered
what's in Berlin but I mean yeah
probably a lot of sleeping taking naps
and try to come with the full energy but
I'm very pleased to to win the day
everyone if that's a treasure Wesley
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you very much indeed our
congratulations is Wesley as well Wesley
I mean that jet lag I think really does
impact everybody and it's just really
hard to overcome and I think there's
like a seven hour time zone difference
between Berlin and
um St Louis so it's really tough it is
very tough and Wesley before or Berlin
has been in Dortmund so he'd really
gotten accustomed sorry yeah it really
gone accustomed to European Time the
time zone exactly and it is difficult
like right now you know I'm actually
waking up at five in the morning
I'm coming in from Amsterdam so I know
exactly where you're coming from but
let's jump back to Christian it's Fabian
Studio probably an important step to
defend your title this was a difficult
match it felt like nothing can separate
you to until the last game take us
through this last final match yeah you
know
um I had this idea or we had this idea
with my second in the second rapid game
already in classical and
we just weren't sure
if it's like worth it for a classical
game but now I'm starting to regret
because of course I mean the match was
very good overall but
um but it feels like maybe it was even
worth it for a classical game and which
one is the idea this Knight to D2 well
he had played C5 once uh against Fun
Forest like after in this position no no
in the game like after Queen C2 C5 he
had played before against one for us
see it down there yep and Castle is a
very rare move
there was a game of Friedman which went
exactly like the game CD4 Knight C4
Knight C6 Rook D1 and the thing is we're
Knight C6 is a very serious mistake yeah
and it's one of those rare moments when
a very natural move is a very serious
mistake black needs to play D3 here
to equalize yeah and it's still a tough
fight so it's not like
I was I wasn't too concerned about this
because I thought I'll still be able to
play a game with chances and the other
way that black can play is to take on D2
instead of DC4 which was a bit unusual
and not
it also kind of equalizes but it's not
easy for black to play like this and we
were actually shocked that after D1
Queen E7 A3 the computer gives you a
decisive Advantage did you know that
I just knew after Rook D1 on better I
didn't I didn't remember the move Queen
E7
so it didn't worry me because like when
he was thinking I was also thinking
Queen E7 is a semi-natural move to try
to get E5
but after A3 it looked really dangerous
um I didn't know it was this bad but
yeah I had a feeling I have a very nice
position and then Rook be it as a
blunder
but anyway it looks very unpleasant
especially with the time situation
absolutely a big matchup big victory for
you tomorrow you will be facing Wesley
so a very difficult opponent very
difficult opponent to beat in any time
control how do you feel about that
particular matchup yeah it's a very
tough match of course Wesley is really
proficient uh in every time control so
if it goes from classical to rabbit or
to Blitz it's not like it ever gets any
easier and we played a lot uh you know I
think we have a relatively balanced
score overall but we've played uh like I
don't know how many years how many games
we've played so so definitely we have a
lot of experience against each other I
think it will be will be a very tough
match and hopefully
um hopefully I'll be in good shape guys
any questions uh just a it's not a
hilarious moment or anything like that
um uh Fabi but there was this moment
where a bishop did D2 I've been I've
been doing my best to educate the
commentators about grabbing pawns you
perhaps saw the move Bishop D2 but stop
yourself after the move A5 but you did
have this moment of a five nights A5
which is actually really good for you
uh it you played Rook D1 and went on to
to win nicely did you see anything like
this or you just stopped yourself after
no after A5 I considered let's say Rook
C1 E5 and Rook H4 which is pretty
typical to put the Rook on H4 in some
positions I considered things like that
Knight takes A5 didn't
even cross my mind
um if you told me there's a way to win a
pawn probably I would
would notice this but
um I think this is one of those cases
where it's good to see a little bit less
because I mean Rook D1 and Bishop D2
ended up being much more
um much cleaner I guess as it turned out
than than this might be and rather than
calculate all this stuff and
take up the courage to to play it you
know I think it's easier to just play
Rook D1 Fair uh good luck in uh your
next uh match coming up tomorrow thank
you good luck wow wow we're very very
eventful day I I must say that uh I
enjoyed uh the matches and really as uh
Bobby said it there was very little
between them and uh Ray just came into
this position that looked very natural
and suddenly he's just lost I mean it's
like wow but it felt like there was
something maybe in the air because you
know these
I mean they were neck and neck and you
couldn't really tell the players apart
but then you know game four Bam Bam the
action happened and it was an incredible
day of events oh just to say it's a good
day for me
actually it's a good day for everybody
well except for illusion yeah I mean
sorry well he's gonna get a competitor
certificate you know you competed with
the best here you go and in the ladies
participation trophy yes and in the
ladies we all went for wow everyone ah
everybody's good everybody's happy
impressive
final thoughts Christian day two I mean
what uh what a great day and I know
these competitors are not getting any
rest because tomorrow still there's
classical games as well as rapid and
Bliss games because finally the
elimination bracket is going to be
starting so I'm definitely having my
eyes on that it's going to be an
exciting day filled with rapid Blitz and
classical chess all-time formats this is
American chess
American Cup Jovi is wonderful great I
agree have fun calling the action
alongside you yeah the feeling is mutual
and tomorrow we are we are going to be
revved up for some more drama more
Thrills and Spills on the board so
please join yasa myself and Christian to
follow all the action all the drama and
we'll see you tomorrow same time same
place
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited